OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. THERE ARE
24 BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
HOWEVER, ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 2046
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. 16
BILLS TODAY ARE ON CONSENT. THEY
ARE AS FOLLOWS. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 456. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB 1939. ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
3262. ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 810.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 1575. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 1796. ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB 1871. ITEM NUMBER 11 AB
1805. ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 1821.
ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 1930. ITEM
NUMBER 17 AB 2044. ITEM NUMBER
20 AB 2173. ITEM NUMBER 21 AB
2179. ITEM 22 AB 22, 66, 22, 68.
ITEM 23 AB 2345. AN ITEM NUMBER
24 AB 2630. AND ALSO AB 1955.
JUST KIDDING. SO WE WILL BEGIN
WITH A SPECIAL ORDER TO HEAR AB
1955 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARDE
WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, PLEASE
TAKE YOUR PLACE AT THE PODIUM,
TODAY'S WITNESSES ARE ASKED TO
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THREE
MINUTES TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEE
IS ABLE TO COMPETE, COMPLETE
TODAY'S AGENDA IN A TIMELY
FASHION, SEEING NO QUORUM, LET'S
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE
FIRST BILL, WELCOME AGAIN,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
WHO WILL BE JOINING US SOON? I'M
HERE TODAY. I'M SORRY. WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. LET ME WAIT
FOR ONE MORE MEMBER. LET'S WAIT
FOR ONE MORE MEMBER. APPRECIATE
YOUR, YOUR TIME. I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. I WAS ON A ROLL
THERE. IT WAS A GOOD ROLL. YEAH
I WOULD ASK ANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO MIGHT BE WATCHING
ON A MONITOR SOMEWHERE TO PLEASE
COME JOIN US.
YOU CALL. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
WELCOME TO MY COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR GLAZIER. SENATOR WILK,
GOOD MORNING, I WAS ALL RARING
TO GO. GOT STARTED. NOTICED YOU.
YOU WERE WATCHING. ALL RIGHT,
LET ME ONCE AGAIN SAY, WE STILL
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM. THIS IS A
SEVEN MEMBER COMMITTEE, AGAIN,
WITNESSES WILL BE ASKED TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY. THREE MINUTES
TO ENSURE THAT WE'LL COMPLETE
TODAY'S TESTIMONY, AND WE WILL
NOW START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND
WELCOME ONCE AGAIN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD, YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
READY. WELL THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND AGAIN, SENATORS, GOOD
MORNING. I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 1955 THE SUPPORT
ACADEMIC FUTURES AND EDUCATORS
FOR TODAY'S YOUTH ACT, OR THE
SAFETY ACT. SINCE 2020, THERE'S
BEEN A GROWING NATIONAL ATTACK
ON LGBTQ PEOPLE WITH A NUMBER OF
STATES AND CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ENACTING POLICIES THAT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRE TEACHERS TO
NOTIFY PARENTS IF THEIR CHILD
IDENTIFIES AS TRANSGENDER. THESE
POLICIES ARE KNOWN AS FORCED
OUTINGS, FORCED OUTING POLICIES
THAT REQUIRE EXPOSING STUDENTS
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT HARMS
EVERYONE'S PARENTS. FAMILIES AND
SCHOOL STAFF, AND IMPORTANTLY,
THOSE STUDENTS BY UNNECESSARILY
PUTTING STUDENTS AT RISK AND
REMOVING THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FAMILIES TO BUILD TRUST AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THEIR OWN
TERMS. ALTHOUGH MANY LGBTQ YOUTH
HAVE SUPPORTIVE FAMILIES, SOME
UNFORTUNATELY CONTINUE TO FACE
REJECTION AND ARE EXPOSED TO
SERIOUS HARM IF PREMATURELY
FORCED TO REVEAL THEIR IDENTITY.
YOUNG PEOPLE THRIVE WHEN THEY
HAVE A PARENTAL SUPPORT AND FEEL
SAFE SHARING THEIR AUTHENTIC
SELVES AT HOME. IN FACT, WHEN
LGBTQ YOUTH HAVE THEIR PARENTS
SUPPORT, THEY HAVE STABILITY AND
THEY FEEL SAFE SHARING THEIR
IDENTITIES WITH THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO BE THEIR
AUTHENTIC SELVES, AND THEY CAN
BE. IT CAN BE HARMFUL FOR LGBTQ
YOUTH TO SHARE THEIR FULL
IDENTITIES BEFORE THEY'RE READY.
FORCED OUTING POLICIES HAVE A
MEASURABLE IMPACT ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF LGBTQ STUDENTS, AND
HAVE LED TO A RISE IN BULLYING,
HARASSMENT, AND DISCRIMINATION.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WHEN ONE
POPULATION OF THE STUDENT BODY
IS BULLIED, HARASSED AND
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST, ALL
STUDENTS ARE IMPACTED, AS WAS
STATED BY CHI, AN LGBTQ YOUTH
WHO BRAVELY JOINED US IN
ANNOUNCING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION. STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN FORCIBLY OUTED BEFORE
THEY ARE READY TO FACE
HARASSMENT AND ABUSE BOTH AT
SCHOOL AND AT HOME. CONSEQUENCES
OF SUCH BULLYING, HARASSMENT AND
ABUSE HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO LGBT
C¯ STUDENTS GETTING KICKED OUT
OF THEIR HOUSES AND
UNFORTUNATELY, SOME ATTEMPTING
TO TAKE THEIR OWN LIVES. HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR AN EMPATHETIC
TEACHER WHO ALLOWED CHI TO BE
ABLE TO COME OUT TO HIS PARENTS
ON HIS OWN TERMS, HE WOULD NOT
ONLY WOULD HAVE BEEN DEPRIVED OF
THE TIME. EXCUSE ME OF THE TIME.
EXCUSE ME. I'D ASK THE AUDIENCE
TO PLEASE GIVE THE AUTHOR AND
ALL OTHER WITNESSES A CHANCE TO
SPEAK. AND IF YOU DON'T DO THAT,
WE'LL HAVE YOU REMOVED. PLEASE
CONTINUE. KAI'S TRUTH WAS THAT
BECAUSE OF AN EMPATHETIC
TEACHER, HE WAS ABLE TO COME OUT
TO HIS PARENTS ON HIS OWN TERMS.
IF NOT FOR THAT, HE WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN ABLE. HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN DEPRIVED OF THE TIME NEEDED
TO FORM SOME OF THE BEST
DISCUSSION WITH HIS FAMILY WHEN
COMING OUT. BUT HE ALSO SHARED
THAT HE WOULD NOT BE WITH US
TODAY. HIS STORY IS ONE OF
COUNTLESS YOUTH WHO ARE HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY FORCED OUTING
POLICIES THAT TARGET LGBTQ
YOUTH. IN OUR STATE. FORCED
OUTING POLICIES NOT ONLY RUN
CONTRARY TO ACADEMIC RESEARCH,
BUT ALSO THE LAWS AND POLICIES
THAT TARGET OR INVITE TARGETING
OF STUDENTS ON THE BASIS OF
GENDER OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION,
WHICH ARE PROHIBITED UNDER STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. AS SUCH, I
PARTNERED WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE LEGISLATIVE, LGBTQ CAUCUS TO
INTRODUCE THE SAFETY ACT TO
STRENGTHEN EXISTING PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FORCED OUTINGS OF
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS. FIRST, IT
DOES FOUR THINGS THE SAFETY ACT
PROHIBITS AND INVALIDATES ANY
POLICY, RULE OR ADMINISTRATIVE
REGULATION THAT REQUIRES A
FORCED OUTING. SECOND, THIS BILL
AFFIRMS THAT TEACHERS AND
EMPLOYEES SHALL NOT DISCRIMINATE
ON THE BASIS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
OF STUDENTS AND SHALL NOT BE
COMPELLED TO DISCLOSE SUCH AN
IDENTITY UNLESS REQUIRED TO DO
SO BY LAW, SUCH AS DUE TO
SUSPICION OF HARM AS MANDATED
REPORTERS. THIRD, THIS BILL
PROTECTS TEACHERS FROM FACING
RETALIATION FOR SIMPLY DOING
THEIR JOBS, TEACHING, AND
PROVIDING A SAFE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT. AND FOURTH, THE
SAFETY ACT PROVIDES PARENTS,
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES OF LGBTQ
STUDENTS WITH CRITICAL RESOURCES
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THEM IN
WORKING TOWARDS ACCEPTANCE ON
THEIR OWN TERMS, WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE FROM OTHERS. NOW BY
STRENGTHENING SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROTECTIONS AND
SUPPORTING FAMILIES, WE WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
SAFE, SUPPORTED AND NOT ISOLATED
DUE TO ANY PART OF THEIR
IDENTITY, AS WELL AS TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO HAVE
PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS AND WORK
TOWARDS FAMILY ACCEPTANCE ON
THEIR OWN TERMS. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
KRISTIE HURST, A PARENT AND THE
CO-FOUNDER OF OUR SCHOOLS USA,
AND SHAE STEVENS, A TEACHER AND
PARENT HERSELF. ALSO HERE IS
JENNIFER CHAO, THE INTERIM
DIRECTOR AND STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
THE ACLU, TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE WITNESSES. PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
AND I THINK, MR. HURST, ARE YOU
YOU ARE FIRST. YES YOU'RE FIRST.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE FIRST. OH.
I'M FINE. YOU CAN BE FIRST. ALL
RIGHT. PLEASE GO. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. WELCOME. HI. IS THIS
GOOD? IT'S GREAT. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS CHRISTY
HURST. I AM A PUBLIC SCHOOL
PARENT OF THREE CHILDREN AND
ALSO THE CO-FOUNDER OF OUR
SCHOOLS USA, A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING QUALITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS.
PARENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CONTACT US DAILY. CONCERNED
ABOUT FORCED OUTING POLICIES AND
THE EXTREMIST SCHOOL BOARDS THAT
PASSED THEM, THE PARENTS SPAN A
VARIETY OF RACES, ETHNICITIES,
CLASSES, POLITICAL GROUPS AND
RELIGIOUS VIEWS. THEY'RE UNITED
IN RECOGNIZING FORCED OUTING IS
HARMFUL, DOES NOTHING TO IMPROVE
EDUCATION, AND IS A WASTE OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES. AFTER CHINO
PASSED FORCED OUTING POLICY LAST
JULY, I RECEIVED DOZENS OF
LETTERS FROM STUDENTS, PARENTS,
TEACHERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS,
AND I'VE PROVIDED THEM FOR YOU,
THEY SAID. MY CHILD IS ACTUALLY
NOT SAFE AT THEIR SCHOOL. I'M A
TEACHER WHO HEARS HOW AFRAID
STUDENTS ARE OF THIS POLICY. Kò
NOT ONLY IS THIS DISCRIMINATORY,
THEY ALSO CREATE A CLIMATE OF
FEAR AND BULLYING IN SCHOOLS.
THAT'S BAD FOR ALL MY STUDENTS.
THIS DISTRICT NEEDS TO STOP
WASTING OUR TAX DOLLARS AND
START DOING WHAT BENEFITS ALL
OUR CHILDREN. FORCED OUTING HAS
MADE OUR DISTRICT THE SUBJECT OF
RIDICULE AND MOCKERY. IT DAMAGES
OUR COMMUNITY, ITS IMAGE AND
ALSO AFFECTS OUR HOME VALUES,
WHICH ARE CLOSELY TIED TO THE
REPUTATION OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. MY FAMILY HAS STARTED
LOOKING INTO OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. PARENTS DID NOT ASK
FOR A SCHOOL BOARD TO DICTATE
HOW WE RAISE OUR CHILDREN,
STUDENTS SAID. I FEEL BELITTLED,
UNCOMFORTABLE AND UNSAFE IN MY
SCHOOL. THE DISTRICT'S JOB IS
NOT TO PROTECT THE FEELINGS OF
PARENTS, IT'S TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF ALL STUDENTS. I SHOULD
NOT BE FORCED TO TELL MY PARENT
WHO SAYS SLURS AGAINST LGBTQ
PEOPLE, THAT I AM WHAT THEY HATE
. I AM AFRAID THAT I WILL BE
CAST AWAY FROM MY FAMILY IF THEY
FIND OUT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CANNOT SURVIVE ANOTHER
YEAR OF THIS NOT BEING RESOLVED
BY THE STATE, BECAUSE THE
EXTREMISTS WON'T STOP WASTING
PUBLIC MONEY ON THEIR POLITICAL
CRUSADES. THE TIME TO RESOLVE
ANY AMBIGUITY IS NOW TO PASS THE
SAFETY ACT, BECAUSE WE NEED
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS. WE
NEED SCHOOL BOARDS TO BE FOCUSED
ON EDUCATING KIDS, NOT POLITICAL
CRUSADES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MISS STEVENS, WELCOME. THANK
YOU. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
OKAY. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
SHAY STEVENS, AND I AM A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER IN ONE OF THE 12
DISTRICTS THAT HAS PASSED A
FORCED OUTING POLICY. I'D LIKE
TO SHARE A PERSONAL STORY ABOUT
THE IMPACT THIS HAS HAD ON THE
CULTURE AND SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOL
. WHEN WE BECAME PRIVY TO THE
FACT THAT OUR BOARD WOULD BE
VOTING ON THIS POLICY, WE
ENCOURAGED OUR STUDENTS TO COME
TO THE BOARD MEETING AND BE PART
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
INEVITABLY, MANY IN OUR LGBTQ
STUDENT COMMUNITY FELT COMPELLED
TO ATTEND. WE SAT IN OUR
SCHOOL'S LIBRARY LISTENING TO
GROWN ADULTS BERATE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS BY REFERRING
TO THEM AS ABOMINATIONS,
ACCUSING THEM OF PEDOPHILIA AND
CALLING THEM ALL SORTS OF
DEHUMANIZING NAMES. SOME EVEN
BROUGHT PREPARED SIGNS TO HOLD
UP IN FRONT OF THE CROWD. ONLY
ONE IDENTIFYING STUDENT SPOKE AT
THE PODIUM AMID SNEERS AND
WHISPERS AS I LOOKED AROUND THE
ROOM, MANY OF THE KIDS SAT IN
SILENCE, TEARS STREAMING DOWN
THEIR FACES, UNABLE TO FIND THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP AND DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST THOSE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT THEM.
ENCOURAGING THOSE STUDENTS TO
ATTEND THAT MEETING WAS THE
GREATEST MISTAKE OF MY CAREER.
SINCE THEN, IT HAS BEEN ONE
DISCRIMINATORY POLICY AFTER THE
NEXT FROM THE BAN OF ALL FLAGS,
SAVE THE AMERICAN OR STATE FLAG
TO ATTEMPTS TO BAN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR OUR STUDENTS, BOARD
MEETINGS HAVE GONE FROM
TRADITIONAL 45 MINUTES TO 4 TO 6
HOURS. WE'RE CHASING OUR TAILS,
TRYING TO DO OUR DAY JOBS WHILE
ALSO FIGHTING TO MAINTAIN A SAFE
AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. IT HAS BECOME
BLATANTLY CLEAR THAT THIS PUSH
FROM THE OUTSIDE, FROM OUTSIDE
POLITICAL PROPAGANDISTS, HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH PARENTAL
RIGHTS AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THIS
IMBALANCE OF POWER HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT I, HAVING THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING AN EDUCATOR
WITH A VOICE, HAD TO COME HERE
TODAY AND SPEAK TO THE DAMAGE
THESE ROGUE BOARDS ARE DOING TO
OUR CHILDREN. STUDENT SAFETY
SHOULD NEVER BE COMPROMISED BY
EXTREME IDEOLOGY. IT IS OUR
SOLEMN DUTY TO PROTECT AND SERVE
EVERY STUDENT IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
PLEASE ALLOW US TO TEACH IN A
WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT WHERE
CHILDREN FEEL SAFE, STAND WITH
EDUCATORS AND PASS ASSEMBLY BILL
1955. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AT THIS POINT,
I'D ASK ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO'D LIKE TO COME
FORWARD AND TESTIFY AND SUPPORT
THE BILL TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION, AND YOUR
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SIR. GOOD MORNING, CRAIG
PULSIFER HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
PROYECTO TRANS LATINA, SAN DIEGO
PRIDE, SAN JOAQUIN PRIDE CENTER,
THE TRANS LATINA COALITION, TOM
HOMAN LGBTQ LAW ASSOCIATION AND
WEST SIDE ACTIVISTS AND OUR
SCHOOLS LÀ. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. MY NAME IS TONY HUANG.
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. KATHY
MALIG. SHE HER TRANS FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES. I VOTE AS WELL
AS AMERICAN ATHEISTS, THE
CALIFORNIA LULAC CALIF SCHOOL
BASED ALLIANCE HEART OF LA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB, THE INLAND
EMPIRE, PRISM COLLECTIVE, AND
THE LGBTQ CENTER OF ORANGE
COUNTY. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
NICOLE MORALES, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT SHONDA WESLEY,
ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILIES, OUR
VOICES AND STRONG SUPPORT, AND
ON BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ALLIES, PARENTS AND FAMILY WHO
HAVE ASKED ME TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR AB 1955 MISS
BOUDREAU AND ERIC ERICA BAUMAN,
WHITTIER NICOLE AND DAVID
BECKSTRAND, EL CAJON CLAIRE DE
VRIES, FOLSOM, MARA HUI,
SACRAMENTO. KRISTI BARNES, WEST
SACRAMENTO, MI EMILY LEVY, SANTA
CRUZ. CLAUDIA VIERA ALLEN, ELENA
SOBRANTE, JILLIAN LEVI
ESCONDIDO, JOSH CLARK,
SACRAMENTO MONICA BOSKOVICH
MATHER, DANA WATTS, ORANGE
COUNTY, PETER DOLAN, JEFF
ENSLEY, CHICO AND FROM
SACRAMENTO KRISTEN WAGNER, KIM
MICHELINI, QUEEN BèC, NICOLE
ROBERTS, MORGAN. COTTON,
STEPHANIE BAXTER, KELLY STOUT,
KRISTEN STOUT, PAULA KNOLL,
ELIZABETH. CAMPBELL, RENEE.
STOKES, CHRISTINA. NIKUMI,
MELANIE BEAN, AND VALERIE
OLDHAM. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. SYLVIA ROMO FROM
SACRAMENTO WITH THE BUILDING
SKILLS PARTNERSHIP. ALSO A
PARENT OF A TRANS YOUTH AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE EMILY LOWE
PARENT FROM DAVIS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. FRANK BAILEY
GREATER PLACER COUNTY PFLAG IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. DIANE BAILEY, FOR
PFLAG GREATER PLACER COUNTY I
HAVE A TRANS SON AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
MY NAME IS LAURA BARRETT. I LIVE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I HAVE A
NON-BINARY YOUTH IN MY FAMILY.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AB 1955. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI, ANNIE CHOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT, ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE L.A. LGBT CENTER, NORTH
COUNTY LGBT RESOURCE CENTER, ONE
INSTITUTE, OUR FAMILY COALITION,
OUR SCHOOLS USA, CARLSBAD AND
PFLAG FRESNO. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, MY NAME
IS KRISTEN MILLIKEN. I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO. I HAVE A NON-BINARY
YOUTH IN MY FAMILY. AND I'M HERE
Dð BECAUSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. JACKY JACKY HOWARD
WITH CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, ON BEHALF OF MY
THREE KIDDOS IN PLACER COUNTY
SCHOOLS, THANK YOU. NEXT HI. MY
NAME IS RANDI KAYE STEVENS. I'M
A PARENT HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I
WANT ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS TO BE A
SAFE PLACE FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE, I'M KAREN
HUMPHREY. I'M WITH THE NATIONAL
WOMEN'S POLITICAL CAUCUS OF
CALIFORNIA, AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
HI. I'M SUE GRANZELLA, RETIRED
MEMBER OF FROM 32 YEARS AS A CTA
MEMBER. AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. TIFFANY UMOK, ON
BEHALF OF CFT AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. KAT BESSE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, DOCTOR JONATHAN
HIGGINS WITH RAINBOW PRIDE YOUTH
ALLIANCE HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
KANON DURHAM OF PRIDE OF THE
PIER IN ORANGE COUNTY AND A
TRANS MAN. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
HI. MY NAME IS BREE FROM
GLENDORA. I'M A QUEER NON-BINARY
EDUCATOR AND ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AND EVERY SINGLE LGBTQ YOUTH WHO
IS NO LONGER WITH US AND CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES, I SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE EVERY CHILD NEEDS A
SUPPORTIVE LEARNING. THANK YOU.
I'M ANGIE GOVAN ON BEHALF OF
GLENDALE UNIFIED PARENTS FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF PASSING AB
1955. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. JESSICA GARCIA,
SAN MATEO BOARD MEMBER, PFLAG,
SAN JOSE PENINSULA. STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO. CLAUDIA SILVA,
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. LARA
PUBLIC PUBLIC SCHOOL PARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
JESSICA MARQUEZ, ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
PROUD SUPPORT, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
LINDA ORTEGA FROM THE MOUNT
DIABLO EDUCATION ASSOCIATION AND
THE CONCORD AREA. I AM A PROUD
AUNTY OF TRANS AND TRANSGENDER
CHILDREN AND STUDENTS AND, A
SISTER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS ANNE
BOWLER FROM PLACER COUNTY AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
MILLIE YAN, A PARENT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL KIDS IN PLACER COUNTY AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 1955.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO.
JACOB DARUVALA FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE REPRESENTING PARENT RENEE
BOLADO, THE TRANS YOUTH
LIBERATION AND DIVINE TRUTH
UNITY FELLOWSHIP CHURCH. AND WE
ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, MY NAME
IS MICHELLE TANG. I'M WITH OUR
SCHOOLS PLACER AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 1955. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. REX CARPENTER I'M
WITH PLACER COUNTY. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. MY NAME
IS MEG WEISS. I'M WITH OUR
SCHOOLS PLACER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. HI. MY NAME IS
DAISY CATHERINE GARDNER. I AM
WITH OUR SCHOOLS, USA, LOS
ANGELES. I AM A PARENT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL CHILDREN AND A LGBTQ
YOUTH, I'M ALSO HERE FOR SAFE
REDLANDS SCHOOLS. TRICIA
KEELING, AMBER EASLEY AND OTHERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR EMILY MITCHELL. MY
PRONOUNS ARE SHE AND HER, AND I
AM HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LGBTQ PLUS ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
MITCHELL. NEXT, PLEASE. ELLEN
EBCLC RILEY, PROUD CITIZEN OF
THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND HOPING
THIS BILL WILL PASS BECAUSE IT
WILL PROTECT TODAY'S YOUTH
AGAINST WHAT MY GENERATION
EXPERIENCED. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. BARBARA BRUCE, LEADER OF
THE RAT PACK RESISTANCE ACTION
TUESDAYS AND THURSDAYS IN PLACER
COUNTY. I SUPPORT THIS, AS DOES
MY ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, CELIA MEDINA OWENS,
PROUD PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER.
SECOND GRADERS AT FOOTHILL
ELEMENTARY IN PITTSBURG,
CALIFORNIA. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME
IS BOB CARSON. I'M A PROUD
EDUCATOR FROM ANTIOCH, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR ROB DEER. I'M FROM
SANTA CRUZ. I'M A PARENT. I AM A
LIFELONG K-12 EDUCATOR IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR IN THE CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM AT CSU MONTEREY BAY, AND
ALSO DIRECTOR OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR THE SAFE SCHOOLS
PROJECT OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
AND OUR ORGANIZATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. I AM JULIAN
JACARANDA JACQUELINE. I'M A
STUDENT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
QUEER YOUTH AND STUDENTS FROM
SANTA CRUZ AND ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTY COUNTRY TO SAY THAT WE
ALL SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. SEAN MCMULLEN CHEN I'M A
TEACHER. HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER IN
MANHATTAN BEACH, CALIFORNIA, AND
A PARENT AND RESIDENT OF
MANHATTAN BEACH, CALIFORNIA. AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MARCELLA CHAGOYA, 25
YEAR LONG CAREER EDUCATOR,
MIDDLE SCHOOL. MY ENTIRE CAREER
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
FOR, REPRESENTING UNITED
TEACHERS LOS ANGELES AND LAUSD
AND CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND, CTA. THANK YOU.
HELLO. TALIA DIAZ CAETANO. I'M A
PROUD PARENT OF A FIRST GRADER
AND ALSO A PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATOR IN BOYLE HEIGHTS IN LA.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI MY
NAME IS CATHERINE EISENSTEIN.
I'M AN EDUCATOR AT LAUSD. I'M
REPRESENTING UTLA, CTA, CFT, AND
AS THE AUNT OF A CHILD WHO IS
NON-BINARY, I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. EVE BARNEZ WITH
THE SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
JESSIE AGUILAR. I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL ART TEACHER IN
BAKERSFIELD. I'VE BEEN TEACHING
FOR THE LAST 28 YEARS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. I'M HECTOR
VEGA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION DE MAESTROS UNIDOS.
I'M A US HISTORY TEACHER IN LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, JAY MASON,
PROUD EDUCATOR FROM CAMPBELL,
CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI. RENATA SANCHEZ I AM
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
INSTRUCTIONAL COACH WHERE I WORK
PRIMARILY WITH PROBATIONARY
TEACHERS GAINING THEIR
CREDENTIALS, AND FROM SAN JOSE,
AND I STAND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI THERE. I'M
ALISON CLAY, HIGH SCHOOL SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER AND POLICY
FERRIDAY'S AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HELLO,
MY NAME IS DANE KANTARCI. I'M A
TEACHER AT HAWTHORNE HIGH
SCHOOL. I TEACH WORLD HISTORY,
AP ECONOMICS, AP GOVERNMENT, AND
AVID AND HAWTHORNE HIGH SCHOOL,
CENTINELA VALLEY SECONDARY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND CTA
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. DAVID
NAVARRO, PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
AND FATHER OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. ANGELA DE RAMOS, FIFTH
GRADE TEACHER AND A SCHOOL BOARD
TRUSTEE IN SALINAS. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. KIM
LEWIS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MAUREEN GRAY. I'M A EDUCATOR IN
NORWALK AND LA MIRADA. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ISHMAEL
ARMENDARIZ, PRESIDENT OF THE
OAKLAND EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
AND ON BEHALF OF OUR 3000
MEMBERS, WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, I'M
KRISTIN LUEVANOS. I'M A
SECONDARY ENGLISH TEACHER IN
COMPTON, CALIFORNIA, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, I
AM COLONEL PAT THOMPSON AND I
SERVED 37 YEARS IN MILITARY
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. NEXT
PLEASE. HI, I'M STEPHEN FRASER,
SCIENCE TEACHER IN CHINO,
CALIFORNIA, AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS TRACY TAYLOR. I'M
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER IN
ONTARIO-MONTCLAIR, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS HèA SULLO.
I'M A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST FOR
CHILDREN FROM K TO HIGH SCHOOL,
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
FROM POMONA. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, ASTON WILLIAMS,
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JEANNIE KIM LAW
STUDENT AND PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA
OR PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KATHY MOSSBERG ON BEHALF OF
THE APLA HEALTH SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION AND END THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION, ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS STANLEY CLOVER. MY
PRONOUNS ARE HE THEY. I'M A
PROUD TRANS MAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. I'M THE REVEREND
ALEX DE SILVA SOTO. MY PRONOUNS
ARE THEY THEM AND THEIRS. AND I
SERVE AS SIERRA FOOTHILLS,
UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
GRATITUDE FOR IT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MY NAME
IS ALICIA WATKINS. I'M A
JOURNALIST WITH THE VOICES OF
PLACER, AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
TWO LGBTQ PLUS AND A PARENT OF A
TWO S¼ LGBTQ PLUS STUDENT, I AM
IN STRONG AND PASSIONATE SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. KARI FANTHAM, PLACER
COUNTY, PARENT OF AN LGBTQ PLUS
STUDENT. I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, FAITH LEE.
WITH ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
WE'RE IN PROUD SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. Dð
COONEY, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT DOCTOR AMBER BRADLEY,
GOVERNMENT TEACHER REPRESENTING
THE WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WEST SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. MEGAN ELSBERND, SEVENTH
AND EIGHTH GRADE TEACHER,
PRESIDENT OF LAGUNA SALADA
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION AND
PACIFICA SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO,
RACHEL. MERLOT FROM PACIFICA.
BOTH PARENT AND PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. MORNING.
CHELSEA GROVE, PARENT OF THREE
CHILDREN. AND, ELK GROVE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THIS IS SUPPORT. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, SHANNON
CATINELLA. I AM A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM THE PARENT OF
THREE CHILDREN SPANNING THREE
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA, IN THE
PLACER AREA. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROTECTIONS OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU TO THE
SERGEANTS. ANYBODY ELSE OUTSIDE?
OKAY. THAT'S ALL THE SUPPORT. SO
TERRIFIC. AT THIS POINT, WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. LET ME GET THAT
ESTABLISHED. MADAM CLERK, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NEUMANN HERE.
NEUMANN HERE. OKOBOJI HERE.
OKOBOJI HERE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ
HERE. GLASER HERE. GLASER.
PRESENT. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HERE
. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK.
PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. WE DO NOW HAVE A QUORUM.
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE. SO
FOR THE PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE,
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE
. AND AS YOU DO, LET'S WELCOME
JULIE FROM MISSOURI, WHO IS
WATCHING LOYALLY AS SHE ALWAYS
DOES. SO THERE'S AN INCOMING
RIGHT THERE. SHE KNOWS SHE
WASN'T ON THE EMAIL. SHE KNOWS
THERE'S JUST TWO. ALL RIGHT. I
SHOW TWO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES,
MISS AURORA. REGINA AND DOCTOR
ARTHUR DELAMARE, WHICH OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST? I CAN GO
FIRST. YOU LIKE THE OTHER
WITNESSES? YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT. HI. THANK YOU, MY NAME IS
AURORA REGINA. UNTIL THE EVENTS
INVOLVING MY DAUGHTER, I WAS A
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT. I VOTED FOR
SAME SEX MARRIAGE. I AM A
PLAINTIFF IN A LAWSUIT THAT I
FILED AGAINST CHICO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR THEIR SECRET
SOCIAL TRANSITION OF MY 11 YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER IN THE FALL OF
2022, FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF HER
GRANDFATHER. MY DAUGHTER WAS
DEPRESSED. I ALSO HAD BREAST
CANCER AND HER FAMILY WAS GOING
THROUGH A DIFFICULT TIME. MY
DAUGHTER WAS INFLUENCED BY HER
SCHOOL TO BELIEVE THAT HER
SADNESS WAS BECAUSE SHE WAS
REALLY A BOY. WHEN SHE TOLD A
SCHOOL COUNSELOR THAT SHE FELT
THIS WAY, THE COUNSELOR DID NOT
TELL ME. INSTEAD WITHOUT
CONTACTING ME, THE COUNSELOR AND
MY DAUGHTER'S TEACHER ARRANGED
FOR THE ENTIRE SCHOOL TO BE
BEGIN USING A MALE NAME THAT MY
DAUGHTER HAD PICKED OUT AND
REFERRED TO HER WITH THE MALE
PRONOUNS. THE SCHOOL CEMENTED
AND ENCOURAGED THIS MALE
IDENTITY FOR MY DAUGHTER BEHIND
MY BACK. OVER THAT PERIOD, MY
DAUGHTER'S DEPRESSION WORSENED.
FINALLY, MY DAUGHTER TOLD HER
GRANDMOTHER, MY MOTHER, ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON AT SCHOOL. MY
MOTHER TOLD ME I WAS HORRIFIED
THAT THE SCHOOL HAD DONE THIS
WITHOUT EVEN INFORMING ME. MY
DAUGHTER WAS JUST CONFUSED ABOUT
HER IDENTITY. WHEN I LEARNED OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON, I WAS ABLE TO
GET MY DAUGHTER THE THERAPY SHE
NEEDED, BUT BECAUSE SHE HAD BEEN
SOCIALLY TRANSITIONED AT SCHOOL,
SHE FELT TRAPPED IN THE NEW BOY
IDENTITY THAT THE SCHOOL WAS
ENCOURAGING. SHE CONTINUED TO GO
BY THE BOYS NAME AND PRONOUNS
FOR THE REST OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
BECAUSE SHE FELT TRAPPED. MY
DAUGHTER STILL STRUGGLES WITH
HER MENTAL HEALTH TODAY. LATER,
WHEN I COMPLAINED TO THE SCHOOL
ABOUT WHAT HAD HAPPENED, I
LEARNED ABOUT THE SCHOOL'S
PARENTAL SECRECY POLICY, WHICH
TAKES PARENTS OUT OF THE
EQUATION. THIS DRIVES A WEDGE
BETWEEN THE PARENT AND CHILD. I
UNDERSTAND MY DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL
CONTINUES TO DECEIVE PARENTS TO
THIS DAY. HAD I NOT FOUND OUT
WHAT THE SCHOOL WAS DOING TO MY
DAUGHTER, SHE LIKELY WOULD HAVE
KEPT IDENTIFYING AS A BOY. LIKE
MANY CHILDREN, SHE PROBABLY
WOULD ALSO HAVE MOVED TOWARDS
IRREVERSIBLE MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS LIKE A MASTECTOMY
BEFORE I LEARNED WHAT WAS GOING
ON, SHE HAD ALREADY HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT BREAST
BINDING WITH THE SCHOOL
COUNSELOR. AB 1955 IS MISNAMED.
IT SHOULD BE CALLED SCHOOL
SECRETS ACT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
IT IS. IF IT PASSES, CHILDREN
WILL BE ADVERSELY HARMED.
SCHOOLS SHOULD NOT KEEP SECRETS
ABOUT CHILDREN'S ACUTE DISTRESS
WITH THEIR BODY. GENDER. GENDER
DYSPHORIA CAN BE A SERIOUS
CONDITION CONDITION, AND PARENTS
NEED TO BE INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S TREATMENT. IF YOU
WANT TO PREVENT SUICIDE AND
TRANS IDENTIFIED CHILDREN, YOU
INVOLVED PARENTS. PARENTS ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE THEIR
CHILDREN THE MOST AND
UNCONDITIONALLY GENTLE. GENDER
DYSPHORIA IS A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE, COMPLETELY DIFFERENT FROM
SEXUAL ORIENTATION, AND
DYSPHORIC CHILDREN NEED HELP
FROM THEIR PARENTS, NOT SECRECY
FROM THEIR SCHOOL. THE
CHILDREN'S SECRET ACT PUTS
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AT RISK WHEN
THEY NEED THEIR PARENTS THE
MOST. I AM NOT THE ONLY PARENT
WITH THIS STORY. READ DUTIES
OPPOSITION LETTER. VOTE NO ON AB
1955. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
DOCTOR LARA ME AM I PRONOUNCING
IT CORRECTLY. CLOSE ENOUGH. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR ARTHUR DELORME. I
AM A CHIEF OF PEDIATRIC
GASTROENTEROLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DAVIS. I AM A CLINICAL PROFESSOR
, AND I CARE FOR TRANS
IDENTIFIED CHILDREN. MY COMMENTS
ARE STRICTLY MY OWN OPINION. AS
A PEDIATRICIAN AND A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE, AND ARE NOT INTENDED TO
REPRESENT THE POSITION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR A
TRANSGENDER CHILD. IS A CHILD
WITH A GENDER IDENTITY DISORDER
OR GENDER DYSPHORIA. UNDER THE
CURRENT DIAGNOSTIC AND
STATISTICAL MANUAL OF MENTAL
DISORDERS, THE DYSPHORIA IS
CHARACTERIZED BY A CHILD'S
SEVERE AND PERSISTENT DISCOMFORT
WITH HIS OR HER SEX. UNTIL ABOUT
A DECADE AGO, GENDER DYSPHORIA
AFFLICTED FEWER THAN 0.01% OF
THE POPULATION, AND MOSTLY YOUNG
MALES. THAT FIGURE BEGAN
INCREASING EXPONENTIALLY RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME SCHOOLS STARTED
TEACHING THAT A PERSON CAN BE
BORN IN THE WRONG BODY. SOCIAL
MEDIA CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
MASSIVE SURGE IN ADOLESCENCE.
MOSTLY FEMALES, INTO ADOPTING
TRANS IDENTITIES. LAST YEAR,
REUTERS REPORTED THAT IN 2016,
THERE WERE 1000 CALIFORNIA KIDS
DIAGNOSED AS GENDER DYSPHORIC.
BY 2020, THAT NUMBER HAD
TRIPLED, AND THAT INCREASE
CONTINUES TO STEADILY, STEADILY
CLIMB. NOTHING IN MEDICINE
INCREASES LIKE THAT WITHOUT
EXTERNAL FORCES. THE CASS
REVIEW, PUBLISHED LAST MONTH, IS
THE LARGEST SYSTEMATIC REVIEW IN
THE WORLD REGARDING GENDER
DYSPHORIC YOUTH. THE REPORT
RAISES SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT SOCIALLY TRANSITIONING
MINORS USING NEW NAMES OR
PRONOUNS OR WHATEVER, STATING
THAT THE TRANSITION IS NOT A
NEUTRAL ACT BUT A PROFOUND
PSYCHOLOGICAL INTERVENTION WITH
POTENTIALLY IRREVERSIBLE
CONSEQUENCES. THE CASS REVIEW
ALSO NOTED THAT DYSPHORIA IS
OFTEN COMBINED WITH OTHER ACUTE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT MUST
BE ADDRESSED. DOCTOR CASS FOUND
THE QUALITY OF THE EVIDENCE TO
TRANSITION MINORS WAS, QUOTE,
DISAPPOINTINGLY POOR. NEW COURT
DOCUMENTS REVEAL THAT JOHNS
HOPKINS 2020 REVIEW REACHED THE
SAME CONCLUSION THÀNH PARENTS
MUST BE INVOLVED IN THEIR GENDER
DYSPHORIC CHILDREN AT THE
INCEPTION OF THE ADOPTION OF A
NEW IDENTITY. SCHOOLS SHOULD NOT
CONDUCT PSYCHOLOGICAL
INTERVENTIONS WITHOUT PARENT
PARENTAL CONSENT. PARENTS PLAY
THE MOST VITAL ROLE IN THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELLNESS OF
THEIR CHILDREN. GENDER DYSPHORIC
YOUTH ARE AT GREATER RISK OF
SUICIDE THAN THEIR PEERS FROM
THE DISTRESS OF THE DYSPHORIA,
NOT FROM BEING UNAFFIRMED.
UMMED. KEEPING THE BEHAVIOR OF
THESE VULNERABLE CHILDREN SECRET
FROM THEIR PARENTS IS ILL
ADVISED AT BEST. I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB 1955, IN ANY FORM, AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS, THANK YOU. WE'LL GET
TO QUESTIONS, PLEASE HOLD YOUR
APPLAUSE. ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO'D LIKE TO COME
FORWARD IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. AS
WITH THE SUPPORTERS, WE WOULD
ASK YOU TO STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. AND THAT IS ALL.
GOOD MORNING. I'M ALSO HERE AS
AS A TECHNICAL WITNESS IF YOU
NEED ONE ON THE LAW. MY NAME IS
AARON FRIED. I'M A LICENSED
ATTORNEY. I REPRESENT OUR DUTY.
PROTECT KIDS, CALIFORNIA AND
DEMOCRATS FOR AN INFORMED
APPROACH TO GENDER. I'M A MOTHER
OF A DAUGHTER WHO USED TO
BELIEVE THAT SHE WAS A BOY.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS DENISE
AGUILAR, CO-FOUNDER OF FREEDOM
ANGELS IN OPPOSITION, ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SONYA SHAW
OF CHINO VALLEY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. THORNTON, CO-FOUNDER OF
FREEDOM ANGELS. AND ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE CALIFORNIANS THAT DON'T
KNOW ABOUT AB 1995 55 AND
SUPPORT AND DO NOT SUPPORT
PARENTAL ALIENATION, WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. MY NAME IS JULIE
LANE. I'M A LESBIAN DEMOCRAT
FROM SAN FRANCISCO. HERE IS A
MEMBER OF WOMEN ARE REAL WOMEN'S
DECLARATION INTERNATIONAL AND
WOMEN'S LIBERATION FRONT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF NO
ONE CAN CHANGE THEIR SEX. THE
COALITION OF LESBIANS, GAY MEN
AND BISEXUALS AND THE COALITION
OF SANE PEOPLE. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
CRAVENS. I'M A RECENT CANDIDATE
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
DISTRICT 11. I'M WITH WOMEN ARE
REAL, AND I AM A LIFELONG
LIBERAL. I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
BEVERLY TALBERT, LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT AND LESBIAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. CONCERNED ABOUT GAY
AND LESBIAN YOUTH BEING TOLD
THEY ARE BORN IN THE WRONG BODY
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE GENDER
NONCONFORMING. JUST YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU.
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. NICOLE. YOUNG MOMS FOR
LIBERTY PLACER COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING KIMBERLY CRABTREE
FROM PLACER COUNTY. CHRISTINA
MUNOZ, DAN STERGER, GRETCHEN
STEPHENS, APRIL HUCKABEE, AND
AMANDA KUNTZ. WE ARE ALL IN VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU,
MISS YOUNG. NEXT, PLEASE.
CHEYENNE KENNEY FROM OAKLAND,
CALIFORNIA AND STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
LANCE CHRISTIANSEN, VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY CENTER, IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
BRINA SHEEHY, REPRESENTING
PROTECTION OF THE EDUCATIONAL
RIGHTS OF KIDS ADVOCACY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI, JOANIE. GREET
MOTHER OF A 15 YEAR OLD, 13 YEAR
OLD AND EIGHT YEAR OLD IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. I'M A REGISTERED NURSE.
I'M A LOCALLY ELECTED BOARD
TRUSTEE, AND MY SCHOOL DISTRICT,
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF. TAKE
A STAND, STANISLAUS, CALIF.
NURSES UNITED AND NUMEROUS
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD NOT ATTEND
TODAY THE FOLLOWING NAMES KAREN
WHITLOW, JOSEPH WHITLOW, KELLY,
SELMAN, MICHAEL GÓMEZ, CASSANDRA
GÓMEZ, ANTHONY RUSSELL, ANNA
RUSSELL, VANESSA SANTOS, CANDICE
WYRICK, LAURA ESTRELLA, AND
STEPHANIE DEGREES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. MEGAN SHORT,
MOTHER OF FOUR SCHOOL AGED
CHILDREN IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
ELIZABETH KENNY I COME FROM
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA. I REPRESENT
POOR MOMS AGAINST OVERREACHING
HANDS. THIS BILL IS GOING TO
DESTROY THE TRUST EVERY PARENT
HAS. THANK YOU. YEAH, I OPPOSE
IT. THANK YOU. WE SEE O'CONNOR
ON BEHALF OF FREDERICK DOUGLAS,
FOUNDER, NATION OF CALIFORNIA,
AS WELL AS CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA, REPRESENTING MOMS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO.
MY NAME IS MARGARET RAIDER. I AM
THE MOTHER OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS. NO CHILD IS SAFE WHEN
LIES OF GENDER IDEOLOGY ARE
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL. I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. MY NAME IS LEANDRA LEPE
AND ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
OTHER LGBTQ FRIENDS WHO
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF PARENTS,
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS AVA
DUBOSE AND I AM 13 AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. MY NAME IS SABRINA
WILLIAMS. ON BEHALF OF MOM AMI
CALIFORNIA. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. MY NAME IS COURTNEY
GRAVES AND I AM PART OF MOM AMI
CALIFORNIA. AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS JODI
BUDDHA. I'VE BEEN AN EDUCATOR OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR 25
YEARS, CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR. AND I'M AGAINST
THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE SOUTH
PLACER REPUBLICAN WOMEN'S
FEDERATION, LADIES OF AUXILIARY
BOARD OF PLACER COUNTY, AND MOMS
FOR LIBERTY. I'M AGAINST THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ZACHARY HULSEY. AND
AS A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT MYSELF,
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. CHARLOTTE JOHNSON,
CONCERNED PARENT. WE PARENTS
DEEPLY RESENT SCHOOLS MAKING US
PARENTS THE ENEMY. IS ANYONE
EVEN YOUR POSITION? PLEASE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
HI, MY NAME IS BETH BOURNE. I'M
THE CHAPTER CHAIR FOR MOMS FOR
LIBERTY, YOLO COUNTY. MY
DAUGHTER WAS SOCIALLY
TRANSITIONED AT DAVIS. HERE'S A
BIG ARTICLE IN THE SACRAMENTO
BEE ABOUT HOW SHE GREW OUT OF
HER TRANS IDENTITY, AND I JUST
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW, I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE MY
DAUGHTER WAS ABLE TO GROW INTO A
YOUNG WOMAN. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, JESSICA
SPADE, MOTHER OF FIVE, TRUSTEE
IN A LOCAL PLACER COUNTY SCHOOL.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR SUMMER PALKO WITH
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HELLO, LESLEY SAWYER,
MOMS FOR LIBERTY. SHASTA COUNTY
ALSO HERE FOR KATIE AND AUTHOR
GORMAN OF MOMS FOR LIBERTY,
SHASTA COUNTY AND PROTECT KIDS
CALIFORNIA. WE SUPER STRONGLY
OBJECT TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS PAULA
LEAVITT. I'M THE CALIFORNIA C
CHAPTER LEADER OF GAYS AGAINST
GROOMERS AND WE STRONGLY,
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
GREG BURT, VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL AND IN
OPPOSITION WITH OUR 70,000
SUBSCRIBERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. PASTOR
BRANDON CAMPBELL, FAITH BAPTIST
CHURCH IN WHEATLAND AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BAPTISTS FOR BIBLICAL
VALUES IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. CHRISTINE CAMPBELL,
I'M A CONCERNED PARENT AND
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. PEGGY DELGADO,
FATHER, I'M A SCHOOL BOARD
TRUSTEE, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
BRIDGE NETWORK IN SACRAMENTO
THAT WORKS WITH AT RISK YOUTH
AND ALSO A SURVIVOR OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA THAT DEALT WITH
GENDER IDENTITY ISSUES. I'M ALSO
A AFFILIATED WITH AMEN CLINICS
AS A BRAIN HEALTH PROFESSIONAL,
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE SCHUELLER. I'M A
CONCERNED PARENT, GRANDPARENT,
AND A GREAT GRANDPARENT. WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR CHILDREN, SO
THEIR POSITION PLEASE, PLEASE
COMPLETELY, STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ETHAN LEE. ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF, I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. ALLISON
NOVELLO OF REALITY ENCOMPASSED
VALUES FOR OUR WOMEN AND STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB 1955. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS. MY NAME IS DAVID
BULLOCK. I'M REPRESENTING THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. EXCUSE ME,
SFV ALLIANCE, LA COUNTY CHAPTER
OF MOMS FOR LIBERTY, MARY C
WELLER, TRUTH EXCHANGE, THE
FACTS, LAW, TRUTH, JUSTICE, LAW
FIRM, TAXPAYER OVERSIGHTS FOR
PARENTS AND STUDENTS, INFORM
PARENTS OF CAPISTRANO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND YOUR
FAVORITE GOAT FARMERS FOR BETTER
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. BULLOCK. NEXT, PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING. MIKE MURRAY,
PARENT FROM ROCKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. SPEAKING ON MY
BEHALF AND ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
COUNCIL, PLEASE TRUST THE
PARENTS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
COMING FROM OUTSIDE? DO WE HAVE
ANY? I THINK WE DO. NONE. WE'RE
DONE. WE'RE GOOD. OKAY. LET US
COME BACK TO THE DAIS HERE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES, IF I COULD. I THINK
IF WE COULD HAVE THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES COME FROM EACH SIDE.
COME BACK TO THE TABLE, PLEASE.
ALL FOR SURE. I UNDERSTAND. AND
WELCOME BACK, COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR REGARDING THE BILL,
SENATOR GLASER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. I KNOW IT'S NOT
AN EASY ONE, GIVEN THE TESTIMONY
WE HEARD TODAY. I JUST HAD SOME
BASIC QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ASK
YOU ABOUT, DOES THIS IS THIS
BILL CONSISTENT WITH THE
EDUCATION CODE IN REGARD TO
PARENTS ACCESS TO THEIR SCHOOL
RECORDS? YES, IT IS. DOES THIS
BILL INTERFERE IN A PARENT'S
COMMUNICATION WITH THEIR CHILD
IN ANY WAY? NO. THEY ARE FREE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM IN ANY WAY
THEY SEE FIT. DOES THIS BILL
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF A COUNSELOR
OR A TEACHER TO COMMUNICATE WITH
A PARENT, IF THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
IN THE STUDENT'S BEST INTEREST?
IT DOES NOT LIMIT THEM. IN FACT,
IT REQUIRES THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT IF IT'S IN THE STUDENT'S
BEST INTEREST. DOES THE SCHOOL
GET INVOLVED IN ANY MEDICAL
PROCEDURES OF A STUDENT? NEVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN FACT, I
WOULD ADD THAT THAT IS ALWAYS
GENDER AFFIRMING. CARE FOR
MINORS. IT'S ALWAYS IN THE
STATE, IS ALWAYS SUBJECT TO
PARENTAL, CONSENT. THANK YOU
SIR, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR
GONZALEZ, THANK YOU, AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR GLASER. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I OFTEN
SAY IN THESE ENVIRONMENTS THAT I
AM ALSO A MOM OF A PUBLIC
STUDENT. PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENT.
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE OF WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE CHILD. I ACTUALLY
HAVE A NEIGHBOR WHO IS
TRANSGENDER AND GOING THROUGH
HIS EXPERIENCE AND LEARNING FROM
HIS EXPERIENCE IS NOT ONLY MADE
ME A BETTER SENATOR, BUT A
BETTER MOTHER. JUST
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE GOING THROUGH AND
THAT THEY'RE NOT, ISSUES THAT
PREVENT A PARENT FROM STILL
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
CHILD ABOUT THEIR IDENTITY. AND
SO WITH THAT, IT IS BRAVE OF YOU
AND THE LGBTQ CAUCUS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND
ULTIMATELY, OF COURSE, SUPPORT.
AND I KNOW IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MOVED, BUT WE'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
IT ALONG TO MOVE IT AGAIN, ANY
OTHER COMMENTS, QUESTIONS?
SENATOR BOGAN HELLO. REMEMBER,
WARD, FIRST I WANT TO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT IT IS
ENCOURAGING TO SEE THAT ONE
THING THAT EVERYONE HAS IN
COMMON, WHETHER YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL, IS THE FACT THAT EVERYONE
CARES ABOUT OUR CHILDREN AND
EVERYONE IS TRYING TO DO WHAT
THEY FEEL OR UNDERSTAND TO BE
BEST FOR THAT CHILD. AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THAT AND NOT
AND UNDERSTAND THE ANGER ON
EITHER SIDE OF WHAT IT ENTAILS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ROOT OF ALL ANGER, IS FEAR.
SO AS WE NAVIGATE THIS, THIS
VERY DELICATE SUBJECT, AS WE ALL
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS OR FRIENDS,
COLLEAGUES, OR, OR CONSTITUENTS
THAT ARE MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THAT WE LEARN,
NECESSARILY NOT NECESSARILY
ACCEPT, BUT BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, RESPECT, AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAVE. AND
I'M TRYING NOT TO GET EMOTIONAL
ON THIS PART BECAUSE I DO SEE I
DO SEE THE NEEDS WITH THAT. AS
WE ARE GOING TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL, I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
AND WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW ALONG
WITH THEM VERY DELICATELY. BUT I
DO WANT TO PREFACE SOME FACTS,
WITH THIS BILL, LET'S BEGIN. AND
I WANT TO CLARIFY, BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WHAT I HEAR AND I TRY
TO BE VERY OBJECTIVE IN WHEN I
HEAR DISCUSSIONS ON LEGISLATION,
I TRY TO HEAR BOTH SIDES AND TRY
TO FACILITATE THE DISCUSSION,
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE GET SO
INVOLVED IN OUR OWN
UNDERSTANDING AND OUR OWN,
BIASES THAT WE CAN'T SEE THE
OTHER SIDE. AND SOMETIMES WHAT I
SEE IS COMMUNICATION THAT GOES
LIKE THIS. SO IN, IN PURSUING
THE LINE OF QUESTIONING, I'M
GOING TO BE VERY, VERY, TRY TO
BE AS CLEAR AS I CAN BE. SO
PREFACE MY DISCUSSION WITH A FEW
FACTS ABOUT THIS BILL.
CURRENTLY, IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE ARE EIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ONE CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT HAVE PASSED A PARENTAL
NOTIFICATION POLICY, AND NONE OF
THOSE POLICIES REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO REVEAL A STUDENT'S SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. AM I CORRECT? I
BELIEVE THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY
AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING AND
REFERRING TO THIS BILL AS AN
OUTING. AND I THINK THERE IS A
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT, RIGHT
NOW, CURRENTLY, AS THERE IS A,
A, A CONTENTION BETWEEN WHETHER
OR NOT PARENTS ARE INFORMED OR
NOT INFORMED, WE'RE VIEWING THAT
AS A MEANS OF PUBLICLY LETTING
PEOPLE KNOW WHERE A CHILD IS
WITH THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
THEIR GENDER DYSPHORIC, AND, AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THAT
REALLY QUICK, SO WHAT I
UNDERSTAND IS THAT I MAY YES,
ACTUALLY, MY NOTES WERE MISSED.
CORRECT. ACTUALLY, THE CHINO,
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT DOES
HAVE A POLICY THAT IS BOTH ON
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY. AND CERTAINLY GIVEN
THE STATUS OF THE AMBIGUITY THAT
WE HAVE TODAY, ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT COULD BE ABLE TO PASS A
SIMILAR POLICY AS WELL. SIMILAR.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO REQUEST
I'M NOT SURE IF ANYBODY HERE HAS
THE LANGUAGE ON THAT BECAUSE
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY'RE THAT IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THAT. OH I DO HOLD ON. I'M A
CHINO PARENT. AND AS WELL AS THE
HEAD OF OUR SCHOOLS, USA. AND
THE CHINO POLICY REQUIRES THAT
IT IS ACTUALLY UNDER AN
INJUNCTION AT THE MOMENT. BUT
WHEN IT WAS PUT INTO PLACE, IT
REQUIRES PARENT NOTIFICATION. IF
A CHILD ASKS TO USE A RESTROOM
OF A GENDER UNDER OTHER THAN
WHAT THEIR BY UMMANZ ON THEIR
BIRTH CERTIFICATE. IF THEY ASK
TO PLAY ON A TEAM, AND ALSO IF
THEY ASK TO USE A PRONOUN OR A
NAME IN THEIR OFFICIAL OR
UNOFFICIAL RECORDS, THAT IS HOW
THE POLICY READS IN CHINO. SO
AND I AND THAT'S THE SIMILAR
POLICY THAT HAS BEEN ADOPTED BY
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I BELIEVE
ANDERSON HAS THE SAME POLICY.
THERE'S A FEW MINOR CHANGES
ACROSS THE STATE, BUT CHINO IS
THE ONLY DISTRICT THAT HAS EVER
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED THE POLICY,
FULLY. BUT AGAIN, IT IS UNDER A
TEMPORARY IT'S UNDER AN
INJUNCTION AT THE MOMENT. AND
THEY HAVE REVISED THE POLICY AS
WELL. BUT THAT HAS NOT COME
FORWARD OR NOTHING HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE NEW REVISION. AND MISS
FREUD, DO YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE, PLEASE?
BECAUSE I WROTE THE POLICY FOR I
WROTE THE PARENTAL NOTIFICATION
POLICIES. SO THE PARENTAL
NOTIFICATION POLICY FOR CHINO
VALLEY DOES NOT TOUCH ON GENDER
OR, SORRY, SEXUAL ORIENTATION AT
ALL. NONE OF THEM DO. I WROTE
THE MAJORITY OF THEM. THEY ALL
DEAL WITH WHETHER A SCHOOL IS
PARTICIPATING IN THE SOCIAL
TRANSITION OF A CHILD. SO WHEN A
CHILD ASKS THE SCHOOL TO CHANGE
THEIR NAME, WHEN A CHILD ASKS
THE SCHOOL TO CALL THEM
DIFFERENT NAMES OR ACCOMMODATE
THEM BY PERMITTING THEM TO USE
DIFFERENT BATHROOMS OR DIFFERENT
SPORTS TEAM, IT DOES NOT COVER
WHERE A CHILD WHERE A TEACHER
HEARS THAT A CHILD IS
TRANSGENDER, THERE IS NO
NOTIFICATION POLICY OR
REQUIREMENT WHATSOEVER. IT'S
ONLY IF THE SCHOOL PARTICIPATES
IN THE SOCIAL TRANSITION, WHICH
IS A PSYCHO SOCIAL MEDICAL
INTERVENTION FOR THE CHILD. I
APPRECIATE THAT, MISS HARRIS, TO
YOUR POINT, THAT AT LEAST
IMPLICITLY, THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING. IF A PARENT IS
NOTIFIED ABOUT A STUDENT'S
CHOICE OF RESTROOM, CORRECT?
CORRECT. BUT AGAIN, IT IS UNDER
AN INJUNCTION. BUT THAT WAS IT.
AND IT IS. IF A STUDENT ASKS TO
EVEN USE ANYTHING, IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE LIKE CHANGED IN THE
RECORD. IF A STUDENT ASKS A
TEACHER TO CALL THEM BY A NAME
OTHER THAN WHAT IS ON THEIR
OFFICIAL RECORD, OR GO BY A
PRONOUN OTHER THAN WHAT IS ON
THEIR OFFICIAL RECORD, THAT
WOULD PROMPT A NOTIFICATION.
OKAY, NOW, SENATOR CHO B¢O ASKED
FOR CLARIFICATION SO WE CAN MOVE
ON. I DON'T KNOW IF WE PROVIDED
IT OR NOT, SENATOR. THANK YOU,
SO BASICALLY CHANGE THE RECORD.
SO THESE POLICIES ONLY REQUIRE
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION IF THE
STUDENT REQUESTED THE SCHOOL
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOCIAL
TRANSITIONING. CORRECT AND THE
SOCIAL MEANING THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE REQUIRING DIFFERENT
BATHROOMS OR DIFFERENT NAME
PRONOUNS. OR IF THEY WANT TO USE
SEX SEGREGATED SPACES THAT DON'T
ALIGN WITH THEIR BIOLOGICAL SEX.
IF A STUDENT REQUESTS TO GO BY A
PRONOUN OR A NAME OTHER THAN
WHAT IS ON THEIR OFFICIAL
RECORDS, THAT PROMPTS A
NOTIFICATION TO THEIR FAMILIES
OR PARENTS THAT WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
CLEAR. OKAY, SO MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ADOPTED, THE, THE
, THE SECRET SOCIAL TRANSITION
PLANS AT THEIR SCHOOLS,
BASICALLY NOT INFORMING THEIR
PARENTS OF THEIR CHILD STRUGGLES
WITH GENDER DYSPHORIA. THE PLANS
ARE A RESULT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS, WHAT IS THE WHAT IS
INTERESTING IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
LAWYERS HAVE ADMITTED IN COURT
THAT THE SECRECY, THE COR MY
WORDS, BY THE WAY, NOT MY WORDS.
I'M READING HERE THAT THE
SECRECY POLICIES ARE NOT LAW. AB
1955 WILL REQUIRE THE SCHOOL
RULES TO KEEP THE STUDENTS
GENDER DYSPHORIA PRIVATE FROM
THE PARENTS, UNLESS THE STUDENTS
GIVE PERMISSION. IS THAT
CORRECT? SO FIRST I WOULD OBJECT
THAT CHARACTERIZATION THAT
SCHOOLS ARE ADOPTING SECRECY
POLICIES. OKAY. PRIVACY PRIVACY
POLICIES ARE UPHELD UNDER BOTH
THE US AND THE STATE
CONSTITUTION. AND IN FACT, THAT
IS WHAT HAS BASICALLY COME UNDER
CHALLENGE IN MANY OF THESE COURT
CASES. AND SO AS WE ARE SEEING
ULTIMATELY GENERAL CONSISTENCY,
THAT A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY PREVAILS OVER OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING
EVALUATED, STILL SOME AMBIGUITY
UNDER SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
DETAILS. WHEN A CERTAIN ELEMENT
OF THAT THAT CASE NEEDS TO BE,
PERMITTED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. SO THAT THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY SORT OF THE COMMON
BASELINE HERE THROUGH THIS BILL.
OKAY. AND AB 1955 WOULD APPLY TO
A STUDENT OF ANY AGE, IS THAT
CORRECT, IT DOES APPLY AS
GENERAL POLICY THROUGHOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. HOWEVER, THE SUPPORT
DIRECTION UNDER THE FOURTH POINT
OF THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
APPLICABLE FOR GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH 12, BUT IT IS FOR IT
COULD POTENTIALLY APPLY FOR ANY
FOR ANY CHILD, ANY AGE. IT
APPLIES FOR ANY SCHOOL OR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. OKAY. GOT IT. OKAY. SO
UNDER THIS BILL, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO A TEACHER OR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE IF THEY TELL THE
PARENTS OF A STUDENT'S STRUGGLES
WITH GENDER DYSPHORIA, OR THAT
THEY HAVE ADOPTED A TRANSGENDER
IDENTITY WITHOUT THE PERMISSION
OF THE STUDENT, NOTHING WOULD
HAPPEN UNDER THIS BILL. IF A
TEACHER, AS A MANDATED REPORTER
DOES FEEL THAT THERE IS REASON
FOR CONCERN, IF THERE IS AN
EXHIBITION OF, YOU KNOW,
DECLINING PERFORMANCE IN
SCHOOLS, STRUGGLES, MENTAL, YOU
KNOW, CLEAR, ATTRIBUTION OF
MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES OR THE
WORST, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW, A
SELF REPORTED, YOU KNOW, WORRY
OR RISK OF HARM FOR ANY OF THESE
REASONS USING I THINK BEST SENSE
JUDGMENT. THERE IS AN ALLOWANCE
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO EXERCISE
THEIR DUTY AS MANDATED
REPORTERS. BUT WHAT THIS DOES DO
IS IT DOES NOT ACTUALLY CREATE
OR PERMIT AN OVERARCHING POLICY
THAT PROHIBITS FORCED OUTINGS.
AND THAT IS THE DISTINCTION
THERE USED BASICALLY AN
INDIVIDUALIZED DISCRETION TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND ALSO WOULD
PROHIBIT, I THINK, THE ACTIVITY,
THE OVERARCHING ACTIVITY THAT
WE'RE SEEING AT SOME OF OUR
SCHOOLS THAT ARE PUTTING
TEACHERS IN A VERY DIFFICULT
PLACE WHERE THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE THE GENDER POLICE, THEY WANT
TO TEACH. SO WHEN WE SAY FORCED
OUTINGS, WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
TECHNICALLY REFERRING TO IS
INFORMING THE PARENTS, NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK ANY ANY POLICY OR ANY
TEACHER WOULD, PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
A CHILD'S, SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
UNLESS THAT CHILD REQUESTS TO BE
PUBLICLY REFERRED TO BY CERTAIN
PRONOUNS, I DON'T THINK ANY ANY
TEACHER WOULD PUBLICLY INFORM
THE REST OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ABOUT THE CHILD'S PERSONAL,
IDENTITY. RIGHT? YOU'RE. WHEN
YOU SAY OUTING, YOU'RE REFERRING
TO PARENTAL NOTIFICATION,
LETTING THE PARENT KNOW OF. YEAH
YES. SO I'LL SIMPLIFY. YES. BUT
MAYBE SUMMARIZE IN LATER
THOUGHTS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO.
PLEASE. SO, MISS CHO, JUST TO
ADDRESS SENATOR, YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
STATEMENT IN THE MIRABELLI CASE.
SO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DID SAY
THAT THE GUIDANCE ISSUED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DOES NOT BINDING. BUT
THAT'S TRUE OF ALL AGENCY
GUIDANCE. WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DID SAY IS THAT THE LAW
THAT UNDERLIES THE GUIDANCE,
CALIFORNIA'S ANTI-DISCRIMINATION
LAW, CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION,
THAT IS WHAT IS ENFORCEABLE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS ISSUED A
CLARIFICATION THÀNH, TO SAY THAT
SPECIFICALLY. AND SO IT'S NOT
TRUE THAT THE, THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS SAID THAT THE K¾T
GUIDANCE IS NOT ENFORCEABLE.
BRIEFLY, MISS FRIDAY, THEY HAVE
SAID IT FOUR TIMES. I HAVE THE
COURT DOCUMENTS THAT THE
GUIDANCE IS GUIDANCE AND IT'S
NOT MANDATED BY LAW. WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT ACTUALLY WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION PERMITS, IS THERE A
PRIVACY RIGHT BETWEEN A CHILD
AND A PARENT, DO CHILDREN HAVE A
PRIVACY RIGHT AGAINST THEIR
PARENTS? THEY DO NOT. AND THAT'S
WHAT THE FEDERAL COURT SAID IN
THE MIRABELLI CASE, IS THAT AS
BETWEEN PARENTS AND CHILDREN,
THERE IS NO PRIVACY. RIGHT SO
THAT IS THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES ALSO, THE FOURTH
14TH AMENDMENT PROVIDES THAT
PARENTS ARE THE, GET TO CARE AND
CUSTODY AND CONTROL OF THEIR
CHILDREN. SO THIS LAW IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS WRITTEN. AND
THIS STATEMENT IN THE BILL THAT
SAYS THIS IS JUST DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW IS A FALSEHOOD. I
WOULD LOVE FOR THE AUTHOR TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT LAW IT IS
ACTUALLY, THAT PERMITS AND
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO LIE TO
PARENTS, IF I MAY, THE REGINA
CASE, I BELIEVE YOU'RE THE LEAD
PLAINTIFF, DID HAVE THE LOWER
COURT DISMISSED THE CASE FINDING
UNDER THE US CONSTITUTION THAT A
PARENT'S RIGHTS WERE NOT
VIOLATED. THAT IS, ON APPEAL TO
THE APPELLATE COURT. SO YOU CAN
SEE THE AMBIGUITY RIGHT NOW AT
BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVELS. YEAH. AND I WAS SO I YOU
KNOW, I WAS KIND OF CURIOUS. I
WAS TRYING TO LOOK A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND I FOUND, THIS ARTICLE
LANDMARK COURT DECISION AFFIRMS
PARENTAL RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WISHES IT HAD A REALLY
INTERESTING POINT AND IN WHICH,
IT SAID, AMONGST OTHER THINGS,
THAT, AND THIS IS WHERE I'M
GOING BECAUSE I'M, I UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT OF THE BILL, BUT I'M
THE WAY THAT IT'S BEEN
FORMATTED. I'M AFRAID THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE FOUND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BASED ON
LITERALLY JUST, THE, THE, THE
COURT FINDINGS THAT ARE IN IT.
AND I APOLOGIZE IF YOU FOLKS SEE
MY WATERMARKS HERE, BUT I
SPELLED SOMETHING IN THE PAPER.
BUT THE COURT. SO THERE'S
VARIOUS, COURT CASES THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IN THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. BUT PART OF IT, THERE'S
SOME THAT SAID THE LAW'S
CONCEPTS OF THE FAMILY RESTS ON
THE PRESUMPTION THAT PARENTS
POSSESS WHAT A CHILD LACKS IN
MATURITY, EXPERIENCE, CAPACITY
FOR JUDGMENT REQUIRED FOR MAKING
LIFE DIFFICULT DECISIONS, IT
JUST GOES ON AND ON AND TALKS
ABOUT THE PARENTAL RIGHTS,
SUPERSEDING THE CHILD'S RIGHTS,
ON HERE. SO I'M READING ALL OF
THESE AND THERE'S JUST SO MUCH,
SO MUCH IN ALREADY THAT'S BEEN
DECIDED UPON FEDERALLY THAT
STATES BASED ON, YOU KNOW, THE
SUPERIOR COURT THAT IT TALKS.
AND I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SHARE THIS WITH YOU, AFTERWARDS
OF WHAT I FOUND. BUT IT IT
ACTUALLY SUPERSEDES THE PARENTS
RIGHTS, SUPERSEDE THAT OF THE
CHILD ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
CASES. AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH YOU JUST THIS PRINT
OUT THAT I HAVE ON THERE. SO,
OVERALL, I THINK WE NEED TO
CLARIFY THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING OUR, OUR CHILDREN'S,
COURSE IS, IS THE FACT THAT ONE
PARENTS DO NEED TO KNOW, I
REALLY, TRULY DO BELIEVE AND I
BELIEVE FROM, MY PERSONAL SPHERE
OF FAMILY AND FRIENDS DEALING
WITH, THESE TYPE OF, HEALTH
ISSUES, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES
, WHATEVER. YOU, YOU KNOW,
TRANSITION ISSUES, SEXUALITY.
VÆ, I CAN TELL YOU THAT NO
PARENT, WHEN THEIR CHILD IS
GOING THROUGH THIS AND KNOWS
THAT THERE IS A, A RISK FOR
SUICIDE OR THAT THERE HAS BEEN,
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS THAT THAT THOSE
PARENTS WILL NOT LOVE THAT CHILD
REGARDLESS. THEY MIGHT NOT
ACCEPT, BUT THEY WILL DEFINITELY
RESPECT THEIR CHILD. AND I KNOW
THIS. I KNOW, I KNOW THIS FROM
CONVERSATIONS WITH, FAMILY
MEMBERS, FRIENDS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS. AND IT MIGHT BE
RIGHT AWAY. AND THERE IS ANGER
FOR MANY, MANY PARENTS, AT FIRST
IT MIGHT COME OUT AS ANGER, BUT
I THINK A LOT OF IT IS THAT FEAR
OF WHAT IS GOING TO COME AFTER,
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE DEALING
WITH. SO IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
ISSUE. IT REALLY IS. IT'S A VERY
I WOULD SAY DIFFICULT. IT'S A
DELICATE ISSUE REALLY IS A
DELICATE ISSUE FOR, FOR PARENTS.
ON THAT END, I JUST WANTED TO
COVER ONE LAST POINT HERE. AND
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE SUICIDE,
COMPONENT, AND WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT, THAT THERE ARE ELEVATED
SUICIDE RISKS FOR TRANS
IDENTIFIED YOUTH. THE FIGURES GO
FROM 41% WHO HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
SUICIDE TO 78% IN LAST YEAR'S,
LET'S SEE, IN LAST YEAR'S BILL,
AB 1665, ALL THE WAY TO 87,
WHICH WAS THE FIGURE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S COMPLAINT
AGAINST THE CHINO VALLEY HILLS.
AND WHAT I BEG TO SAY IS, WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE SUICIDE ATTEMPTS,
THEY USUALLY DON'T HAPPEN AT
SCHOOL. IT HAPPENS USUALLY
PRIVATELY AT HOME OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE. AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I FEEL IT'S
IMPERATIVE THE PARENTS DO KNOW,
AND ONCE AGAIN, IT'S NOT REGARDS
TO THE, TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE
GAY. IT'S WHETHER OR NOT YOUR,
YOUR YOUR, YOUR, YOUR
EXPERIENCING GENDER DYSPHORIA.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART FOR ME IS THAT IF
A CHILD IS IN, IN, IN, IN IS IN
FACT GOING THROUGH THAT, THAT
PARENTS DO NEED TO BE NOTIFIED
SO THAT THEY CAN BE AWARE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT COULD TAKE
SOMEONE'S LIFE AT HOME, WHETHER
IT'S, MEDICATION OR WHETHER IT'S
GUNS OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PARENTS
TO BE AWARE THAT THAT IS
AVAILABLE AND THAT THEIR CHILD
IS GOING THROUGH THIS SO THAT
THEY CAN SECURE THE HOME, IN
ORDER FOR THOSE CHILDREN TO BE
SAFE, AND TO REALLY START HAVING
THE CONVERSATIONS AND THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO, TO FOR
THE FAMILIES IN ORDER FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AND START
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. SO THERE'S
COMPONENTS ON THE BILL THAT I
THAT I TRULY, TRULY SUPPORT. BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY, I THINK THE
BIGGEST, HOLD BACK FOR ME IS, IS
INFORMING THOSE PARENTS
IMMEDIATELY THAT THEIR CHILD,
NOT THE FACT THAT THEY'RE GAY. I
DON'T THINK MANY PARENTS, YOU
KNOW, THEY MIGHT HAVE PROBLEMS.
BUT THE ONE OF CONCERN TO ME IS
THE GENDER DYSPHORIC. JUST
BECAUSE THAT ONE HAS MEDICAL,
POSSIBILITIES THAT COULD BE,
THAT ARE MORE IMPACTFUL, AND SO
THAT'S WHERE I FUNDAMENTALLY
CAN'T, CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. BUT I UNDERSTAND THE, THE
EFFORT THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO, TO
ADDRESS, TODAY. AND I HOPE I'M
CLEAR ON THAT. AND, AND HOW
SENSITIVE I AM TO THIS SUBJECT.
AT HAND. AND I HOPE I HOPE THAT
WE CAN FIND MORE HEALING AMONGST
BOTH SIDES IN, IN TRYING TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS ON BOTH
SIDES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
TOWARDS THE BETTERMENT AND THE
WELL-BEING OF OUR CHILDREN,
RATHER THAN VILIFYING EACH OTHER
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
OTHER SIDE VIEWPOINTS AND
CONCERN. AND I THINK THAT'S,
THAT'S THAT'S JUST MY SEAT THAT
I'M GOING TO PLANT TODAY ON THAT
END, BECAUSE WE ALL, WE ALL DO
CARE ABOUT OUR KIDS, AS THEY GO
THROUGH, THIS, STAGE IN LIFE.
AND WITH THAT, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELL, MICHELLE, IF IT'S IF
IT'S ABOUT THE LAW, DO YOU WANT
TO ADD IT'S PLEASE CLARIFICATION
ON THE LAW. YEAH, JUST TO
ADDRESS SOMETHING THAT MISS
FRIDAY SAID. SO IT IS TRUE THAT
UNDER THE, UNDER THE SUPREME
COURT, PARENTS DO HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CARE, CUSTODY AND CONTROL OF
THEIR CHILDREN. THAT IS, ONE OF
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS IN
IN THIS COUNTRY. HOWEVER, THE
SUPREME COURT HAS ALSO SAID THAT
THAT RIGHT IS NOT ABSOLUTE AND
THAT GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE TO
ENACT LAWS AND POLICIES, THAT
TOUCH UPON THAT RIGHT WHEN THERE
IS A NARROWLY TAILORED AND
COMPELLING GOVERNMENT INTEREST.
AND THE SUPREME COURT HAS ALSO
FOUND THAT THE CREATION OF A
SAFE AND WELCOMING SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT IS A COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST. SO I JUST
WANTED TO, PUT THAT FINER POINT
ON SOMETHING THAT MISS FRIED
SAID BRIEFLY. GO AHEAD, GO
AHEAD. IT'S MR. HURST. YEAH. OH,
THERE WE GO, YOU KNOW, I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE SENATOR WAS
SAYING REGARDING PARENTS. AND SO
I WANTED TO JUST SAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, I AM A PARENT. AND OF
COURSE, I'M INVOLVED IN I THINK
PARENTS NEED TO KNOW AND SHOULD
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON. THIS IS
NOT THE WAY TO FIND OUT, BECAUSE
NO MATTER HOW WE FEEL AS
PARENTS, THE FACT REMAINS THAT
WHEN YOU FORCIBLY OUT A CHILD,
IT HARMS THEM. THAT'S IT. THIS
IS HARMFUL AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I WOULD NOT WANT MY CHILD
FORCIBLY OUTED TO ME, BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO HARM MY
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY CHILD. IF
MY CHILD IS EXPERIENCING
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE OR
STRUGGLING MENTALLY, THE SCHOOL
HAS POLICIES IN PLACE THAT
REQUIRE THEM TO NOTIFY ME. SO SO
I KNOW THAT MY CHILD IS SAFE
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
THAT, I WILL BE INFORMED. AND
FINALLY, I JUST WANT TO END BY
SAYING AND POINTING OUT THAT,
THE SENATOR BROUGHT UP
INCREASING SUICIDE IDEOLOGY
THOUGHTS. AND I HAVE IN MY
ORGANIZATION PARTNERED WITH THE
RAINBOW YOUTH PROJECT USA, AND
WE HAVE A CRISIS HOTLINE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THAT
WAS BROUGHT HERE WHEN FORCED
OUTING BEGAN. AND SINCE ITS
IMPLEMENTATION, THAT HOTLINE HAS
RECEIVED OVER ALMOST 1500 CALLS
JUST FROM CHINO VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND THESE ARE
FROM AFFIRMING HOMES. ALSO,
BECAUSE THESE POLICIES ARE
HARMING ALL STUDENTS, IT IS
BRINGING DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING
MISTREATED. WHEN WE SEE THESE
POLICIES BEING BROUGHT FORTH,
THEY'VE ALSO RECEIVED ALMOST
5000 CALLS FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR NUMBER ONE
CALL. IS THAT THE STUDENT IS IN
CRISIS BECAUSE THEY'RE FEEL
THEIR GOVERNMENT HATES THEM.
THEIR GOVERNMENT AND THEIR
SCHOOL BOARD DOES NOT WANT THEM
TO EXIST. THAT IS UP FROM THE
YEAR BEFORE THE CRISIS. REASON
BEING FOR FEAR OF BEING FORCIBLY
OUTED. SO WHEN YOU SEE THESE
INCREASED IN NUMBERS, I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THAT IS TRUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THEIR NATIONAL NUMBERS. THE
INCREASE IS DUE TO THESE
POLICIES. MISS SCHRADER, YOU
WANTED TO MAKE A POINT OF LAW,
AND I'D ASK YOU TO KEEP IT
BRIEF. YES. ABOUT SETTLE ALL OF
THE QUESTIONS AROUND THE ACTUAL
LAW HERE TODAY. YES. SO PRIVACY
IS SO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
FOR A PRIVACY RIGHT TO EXIST,
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN EXPECTATION
OF PRIVACY. THAT'S FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WHEN A STUDENT TELLS
EVERYONE AT SCHOOL AND ALL THE
TEACHERS AND ALL THE,
ADMINISTRATORS AND ALL THE
STUDENTS KNOW THAT THE CHILD IS
TAKEN ON A TRANSGENDER IDENTITY,
THEN THAT PRIVACY RIGHT IS LOST.
IT'S GONE. AND THE ONLY PERSON
WHO DOESN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
CHILD'S TRANSGENDER STATUS IS
THE PARENT THAT IS NOT CALLED A
PRIVACY RIGHT. AND IT IS NOT
PERMITTED. SO THERE IS NO
PRIVACY, RIGHT? WHEN A CHILD
TELLS EVERYONE, EVERYONE. AND
THAT IS TRUE WITH SEXUAL
ORIENTATION TOO. THERE IS A CASE
FROM THE APPELLATE COURT THAT
SAYS ONCE THE STUDENT TALKS
ABOUT THEIR, THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR PRIVATE ISSUES
AND THEY'VE THEY'VE PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCED IT TO THE ENTIRE
SCHOOL, IT IS NO LONGER PRIVATE.
SO WHEN A CHILD TELLS EVERYONE
AT THE SCHOOL TO CALL THEM BY A
DIFFERENT NAME, USE A DIFFERENT
PRONOUN, TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY.
THAT PRIVACY RIGHT IS GONE. AND
THE FEDERAL COURTS HAVE FOUND
THAT TO BE TRUE. THANK YOU, IF I
MAY, BECAUSE I ACTUALLY PLEASE,
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, THAT
IS NOT TRUE. ANYBODY'S ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES TO WHOM AND THE TIME
AND THE MANNER THEY CHOOSE TO BE
ABLE TO DISCLOSE ANY PART OF
THEIR IDENTITY IS THEIRS TO OWN.
ALWAYS, WHEN YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITY OR YOU LOVE
SOMEBODY WHO IS A MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY, YOU'VE SEEN THIS PLAY
OUT. NOT NECESSARILY. THE FIRST
TIME I HAD TO COME OUT IN
COLLEGE, I HAD TO COME OUT
AGAIN. WHEN I MOVED TO A NEW
COMMUNITY, I HAD TO COME OUT
AGAIN. WHEN I RETURNED TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL. AND SO JUST
BECAUSE I HAD DISCLOSED TO SOME
IN SPACES OF WHO I WAS, DID NOT
MEAN THAT I HAD TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE A NEW ENVIRONMENT AND
DECIDE ON MY OWN TERMS TO WHOM
I'M GOING TO COME OUT. OUTING IS
A DEEPLY PERSONAL SITUATION, AND
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO RETAIN CONTROL OVER THAT
IN ANY SITUATION. AND LET ME LET
ME ASK YOU A FEW QUESTIONS. AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FIRST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. SO YOU
KNOW, THE BILL IS ABOUT
INVALIDATING POLICIES THAT
REQUIRE A SCHOOL TO NOTIFY A
PARENT. RIGHT? BUT BUT THERE'S
NOTHING ABOUT THE BILL THAT
PREVENTS A SCHOOL FROM ACTING IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OTHERWISE OF
A CHILD. IS THAT CORRECT? THAT
EXISTS IN TODAY'S LAW. FAIR
ENOUGH. AND SO I GUESS TO THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
HONORING THE SELF-EXPRESSED
THÀNH OF A CHILD IN THE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT VERSUS I THINK THE
ASSERTION HAS BEEN MADE HERE
THAT CERTAIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WERE TAKING AN ACTIVE ROLE IN
THE TRANSITION OF A GENDER
DYSPHORIC KID. THAT'S NOT AT ALL
WHAT YOU HAVE IN MIND WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT DOESN'T
THAT DOESN'T EXIST. LOOK, THE
SCHOOL'S OBLIGATION AND
HONESTLY, OUR OBLIGATION AS
STATE LAWMAKERS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS WITH A COMMON
THREAD OF GUIDANCE AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THAT ALLOWS THEM TO BE
ABLE TO DO JUST THAT. AND SO
ANYTHING AS WE SAW, I'M GLAD
THAT OUR WITNESS WAS ABLE TO
BRING UP, YOU KNOW, JUST JUST
JUST LET IT CRYSTALLIZE FOR A
SECOND. THE FACT THAT IN ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT STARTED
THIS OFF JUST LAST SUMMER, THAT
WE'VE HAD MORE THAN 1500 CALLS
TO YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
LINES AND JUST THAT NARROW
GEOGRAPHY, COMPARED TO 5000
STATEWIDE. NOW IMAGINE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WAS A
STATEWIDE POLICY. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT WOULD BE IN
DISTRESS. IT IS THIS CHANGE LAST
SUMMER IN INJECTING POLITICS
INTO LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY CAUSED MORE HARM
THAN GOOD. SO I AGREE, WE HAVE A
LOT THAT WE AGREE ON. AND I KNOW
THAT YOU COME FROM A REALLY
SINCERE AND GOOD PLACE, AND AS A
PARENT AS WELL, I HAVE A LOT OF
FAITH IN MY KIDS. I THINK
THEY'RE ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
SMARTER THAN ANY OF US GIVE THEM
CREDIT FOR. BUT THEY'RE GROWING
HUMANS AND THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO EVALUATE A LOT OF THESE
QUESTIONS, AND THEY SHOULD ALSO
BE ABLE TO, I HOPE, KNOW THAT I
HAVE A TRUSTING ENVIRONMENT THAT
THAT THEY'D BE ABLE TO BRING
THESE CONVERSATIONS BACK TO THE
KITCHEN, DINNER TABLE. AND I, AS
A PARENT, INVITE THOSE QUESTIONS
SO NOTHING I FEEL INTERFERES
WITH MY PARENTAL OBLIGATIONS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. BUT I TRUST AND I
WOULD WANT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT ALLOWS A
STUDENT TO THRIVE AND SUCCEED
AND EXCEL AT THEIR ACADEMIC
ATTAINMENT. AND SO, AT LEAST BY
INFERENCE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
DESCRIBING OR POINTING TO AN
OPPOSITE SITUATION WHERE WHERE A
CHILD DOES NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
BRINGING THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
THEIR PARENT. AND SENATOR OCHOA
MADE THE POINT. AND I KNOW IT'S
IT COMES FROM THE HEART THAT
THAT ALL PARENTS AT SOME POINT
ARE LOVING AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING. BUT I THINK CLEARLY
THAT IS NOT THE EXPERIENCE AMONG
MANY CHILDREN, WHICH IS
PRECISELY WHY THEY SEEK REFUGE
AND WANT THAT SANCTUARY THAT A
SCHOOL MIGHT PROVIDE THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE AT HOME. SO IF YOU
OR ONE OF THE WITNESSES COULD
SPEAK TO THAT, YOU MAY START. I
WOULD JUST SAY AGAIN, LET'S NOT
SAY ALL. MOST PARENTS ARE LOVING
AND ACCEPTING. AND ACTUALLY MOST
OF THESE CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN AT
HOME. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PARENTS WHO MAY HAVE ANGER OR
MAY HAVE SHOCK, OR, YOU KNOW,
MAY HAVE TO PROCESS A LOT OF
FEELINGS. AND THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE. AND THEY DO COME
AROUND, AS MANY OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED IT. BUT THERE ARE
MANY WHO ARE KICKED OUT WHO ARE
OSTRACIZED. SO YOU CANNOT SAY
ALL THERE IS A THERE IS A
HEALTHY NUMBER. IT'S A VERY SAD
NUMBER, OF YOUTH WHO ARE
IMMEDIATELY EXPELLED FROM THAT
HOME ENVIRONMENT. AND THIS IS
WHY OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY MADE UP OF
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
THIS IS WHY THOSE WHO TRANSITION
OUT OF THOSE SYSTEMS, 40% OF
YOUTH WHO ARE ON OUR STREETS
IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ YOUTH, BECAUSE
THERE IS A DISPROPORTIONATE
EFFECT ON THOSE YOUTH WHO DO NOT
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS WHY THE TREVOR PROJECT
OAN STUDY SHOW THAT 40% OF
YOUTH DO NOT FEEL THEY HAVE A
SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT
AT HOME, BECAUSE MAYBE THEY'VE
HEARD SOMETHING, MAYBE THEY'VE
HEARD THE WAY THAT PARENTS TALK
ABOUT OTHERS, RIGHT? NOT EVEN
REALIZING THAT IT'S SOMEBODY IN
YOUR OWN ORBIT WHO YOU DO LOVE.
AND THAT IS THE RISK THAT THEY
HAVE TO REALLY WALK. AND
SOMETIMES YOU FEEL LIKE TALKING
TO A STUDENT, A PEER, OR MAYBE
EVEN A TEACHER WHO YOU DO TRUST
IS A GENTLE WAY TO SORT OF TEST
SOME WATERS ABOUT BEING ACCEPTED
. YEAH, I, I ALSO WANTED TO
SPEAK TO THE LOGISTICS OF THIS.
SO LIKE IN THEORY. THE, THE
POLICY THAT MY SCHOOL PASSED
SAYS THAT WITHIN 72 HOURS OF
NOTICING THAT A STUDENT IS
NON-GENDER CONFORMING BY
CHOOSING A NEW BATHROOM OR
ASKING TO BE CALLED A DIFFERENT
PRONOUN, WE ARE TO NOTIFY THEIR
PARENT. LOGISTICALLY, THAT IS A
NIGHTMARE, BECAUSE HOW DO WE DO
THAT? AND WE'RE TOLD WE CAN SEND
AN EMAIL, WE CAN MAKE A PHONE
CALL, OR WE CAN SEND A LETTER
HOME. I, AS A PARENT, CANNOT
IMAGINE WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE TO
RECEIVE A LETTER IN THE MAIL
FROM A TEACHER THAT SAYS, I
THINK YOUR CHILD IS A, B, C, D
FOR WHATEVER REASONS, I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE IN HOW TO DEAL WITH
THINGS LIKE THAT. I DON'T HAVE
THE BACKGROUND, I DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO UNDERSTAND THIS
DELICATE TOPIC, TO WRITE THAT
LETTER HOME TO A PARENT. THE
LOGISTICS THERE DON'T MAKE
SENSE, AND ASKING US TO DO THAT
PUTS US IN A VERY PRECARIOUS
SITUATION, NOT ONLY WITH THE
STUDENT, BUT WITH THE PARENTS AS
WELL. BECAUSE WHAT IF YOU GET AN
ANGRY PARENT THAT THINKS THAT
YOU'RE OVERSTEPPING? OR WHAT IF
THAT LETTER THAT YOU SEND HOME
GOES TO AN UNCLE OR A FRIEND, OR
A GRANDPARENT WHO'S NOT
ACCEPTING, YOU DON'T KNOW WHO'S
GOING TO GET THE MAIL, YOU DON'T
KNOW WHO'S GOING TO GET THE
EMAIL. THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
THAT WE ARE BEING ASKED TO DO
THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY UNREALISTIC,
AND THE LOGISTICS OF IT ARE, IN
MY OPINION, CRUEL. I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WHAT YOU ARE ASKING.
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR, YOU'RE A
TECHNICAL WITNESS FOR ISSUES OF
LAW. IS THAT CORRECT? SO IS THIS
IS THIS ABOUT A MATTER OF LAW OR
SOMETHING ELSE? WELL, IT'S ABOUT
IT'S ABOUT THE LAW BECAUSE THE
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION POLICY
DOES NOT REQUIRE A TEACHER WHO
NOTICES THAT A CHILD IS GOING BY
A DIFFERENT NAME TO NOTIFY THE
PARENTS. IT'S ONLY IF THE
STUDENT ASKS THE SCHOOL TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT SOCIAL
TRANSITIONING BY CALLING THEM A
DIFFERENT NAME, BY CHANGING
RECORDS. BUT TO BE CLEAR, THAT
CAN TAKE ANY INFORMAL FORM RIGHT
WHERE THERE'S NO FORM THAT A
STUDENT HAS TO FILL OUT, RIGHT?
NO, IT MAKES A REQUEST. LET ME
FINISH TO A TEACHER, YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS THAT'S A REQUEST TO
RESPECT THEIR SELF-EXPRESSION AS
OPPOSED TO NATURALLY BEING A
REQUEST TO PARTICIPATE IN A, IN
THEIR TRANSITION, IN THE
PARTICIPATION IN THE TRANSITION
IS WHEN AN ADULT AGREES THAT YOU
ARE BORN IN THE WRONG BODY AND
THAT YOU ARE TRANSGENDER, AND
THAT YOU ARE ACTUALLY A BOY.
THAT IS ADULT IS NOT NECESSARILY
AGREEING TO THAT BY SIMPLY AT
ACCORDING THAT CHILD, THE
RESPECT OF THE SELF-EXPRESSION
THAT GOES WITH THEIR PREFERRED
PRONOUN. I THINK THE DOCTOR CAN
SPEAK TO WHAT AFFIRMATION IS NOT
EVEN REMOTELY WHAT IS NOT
ACCURATE. WHEN YOU SAY TO A KID,
OH YEAH, OKAY, JOHNNY, YOU'RE
SALLY NOW. NO NO NO NO NO NO NO.
AND THAT KID'S PERSPECTIVE. IF
THE KID SAYS, I'D LIKE TO BE
CALLED SALLY AND YOU SAY, OKAY,
I'LL CALL YOU SALLY. THAT IS NOT
SAYING BY ANY MEANS THAT YOU ARE
NOW SALLY. IT'S SIMPLY SAYING I
WILL RESPECT YOUR RIGHT TO
SELF-EXPRESSION. THÀNH. NO, IT'S
NOT THAT SIMPLE, SIR. WHEN AN
ADULT FIGURE, ESPECIALLY A
TEACHER, STARTS PLAYING INTO ANY
IN ANY WAY INTO THE, PERCEPTION
OF REALITY OF THE CHILD, AND
THAT PERCEPTION OF REALITY IS
STILL UNDER A GREAT QUESTION.
THE CHILD IS GOING, OH, THEY
THINK BLACK AND WHITE ADULT IS
SAYING X, THIS IS THIS IS SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE BUYING INTO IT.
SO HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT
MODES OF PLAY WHERE A CHILD
WANTS TO PLAY DRESS UP. IT'S A
MALE CHILD WANTS TO WEAR FEMALE.
THAT'S AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
SITUATION. HOW IS IT DIFFERENT.
IT'S DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE CHILD
IS THAT'S TAKING PLACE
PREDOMINANT ONLY AT A MUCH
YOUNGER AGE. WHEN THE CHILD IS
EXPLORING A LOT OF THINGS, BUT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE THE
CHILD ACTUALLY VERBALLY SAYS, I
WANT YOU TO START. I THINK I'M A
I THINK I'M A GIRL IN A BOY'S
BODY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
TO THE POINT ABOUT THIS FEAR OF
PARENTS AND THIS IS 33 PLUS
YEARS OF BEING A PEDIATRICIAN
AND DEALING WITH THE CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND TAKING
CARE OF HUNDREDS OF KIDS WHO
HAVE BEEN ABUSED IN VARIOUS
WAYS, BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
KIDS, EVEN WHEN I FEEL THAT THEY
SHOULD BE TAKEN OUT OF THE HOME,
ARE NOT TAKEN OUT OF THE HOME
BECAUSE THE CPS FOLKS SEEM TO
THINK THAT IN GENERAL, THE
PARENTS ARE THE BETTER PLACE FOR
THESE KIDS. I'VE LEARNED OVER
TIME THAT IN GENERAL, THEY TEND
TO BE COMPARED TO A LOT OF THE
FOSTER SITUATION, BUT THAT'S A
WHOLLY SEPARATE IT'S A WHOLLY
SEPARATE CONVERSATION. I GOT IT,
BUT THE REASON I BRING THAT UP
IS BECAUSE THIS BILL IS CUTTING
OFF THE LEGS OF PARENTS WHO THE
VAST MAJORITY OF TIMES CARED
DESPERATELY ABOUT THEIR KIDS,
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE A LITTLE BIT
DYSFUNCTIONAL. THE PARENTS I
MEAN, AND WHEN THEY AND IT'S
ACCURATE TO SAY SUICIDE TAKES
PLACE IN THE HOME ALMOST ALWAYS.
SO IF THE PARENT DOESN'T KNOW
ABOUT THIS, IF THE PARENT IS
TOTALLY, TOTALLY KEPT IN THE
DARK OVER WHAT'S GOING ON, YEAH,
THE KID IS AT FAR MORE RISK. AND
OH, BY THE WAY, THE KIDS WHO
START DOING THIS TRANSITION
THÀNH ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
ENTER THE MEDICAL. THE MEDICAL
PARTS AND THE SURGICAL PARTS AND
THE ONLY THE ONLY GIVING THE
DEVIL'S ADVOCATE TO THE FOLKS
WHO THINK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA,
THE ONLY JUSTIFICATION THAT WAS
EVER REALLY BROUGHT UP THAT
SAID, OH, WE SHOULD PROBABLY DO
THIS, IS TO PREVENT SUICIDE. AND
NOW WE SEE THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
IN FACT, THE PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS TRANSITION ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT SUICIDE AS
ADULTS. AND THAT'S THE REASON
THAT THE DUTCH CLOSED THESE AND
THE UK CLOSED THESE. AND NEARLY
ALL OF EUROPE HAS CLOSED THIS.
BUT AND DOCTOR THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S FINE. BUT I THINK NO
THAT'S A HUGE DEAL. I'M SAYING I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
CONSIDER I APPRECIATE IT. I'M
NOT SAYING IT IS FINE. I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO A POINT OF
KIND OF DIMINISHING RETURNS HERE
VERY, VERY BRIEFLY. YEAH. I JUST
WANTED TO BRING UP THE FACT OF A
NOT WHAT IF SITUATION, THIS
SITUATION HAPPENED IN OUR FAMILY
AND MY DAUGHTER WAS 11 AND SHE
WAS CONFUSED AND THEY KEPT IT A
SECRET FROM ME. AND WHAT
HAPPENED WITH HER WAS, IT
ACTUALLY MADE HER MORE CONFUSED
AND MORE DAMAGING AND, EVERYBODY
TALKS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE
BULLYING. WELL, SHE WAS BULLIED
AT SCHOOL WITH NO SUPPORT AT
HOME, BUT SHE SHE KEPT IT LOVE
THE MOST BY US. AND SHE WASN'T
EVEN SHE WAS KEEPING A SECRET
FROM US. SHE KEPT A SECRET FROM
YOU. RIGHT. AND THIS IS REALLY
THE OPERATIVE QUESTION, RIGHT?
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS AT LEAST YOU CAN
INFER A REASON OR A, A BASIS FOR
A CHILD KEEPING A SECRET FOR A
TIME FROM THEIR PARENTS ABOUT
THEIR PREFERRED CHILDREN. KEEP
SECRETS ALL THE TIME. SOMETIMES
THEY SNEAK A COOKIE, YOU KNOW,
AND IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'RE
A BAD PARENT BECAUSE OF THAT.
THAT'S NOT A COMPARABLE
SITUATION. SO YOU KNOW, SO THIS
IS THE QUESTION, RIGHT? YOU
KNOW, AND I GUESS AND I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR LERM IS, IS,
YOU KNOW, I THINK YOU CAN MAKE A
DISTINCTION. I BELIEVE AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT THE, THE,
THE LEGISLATURE IS TRYING TO DO
BETWEEN RESPECT FOR
SELF-EXPRESSION AND IDENTITY
VERSUS ACTIVE PARTICIPATION IN
GENDER TRANSITION. SO WHAT'S A
LINE THAT SHOULDN'T BE CROSSED
FOR YOU, DOCTOR, IN A SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT IS IT SIMPLY NOT
RECOGNIZING THE PREFERRED
PRONOUN? OR IS IT SOMETHING
BEYOND THAT? WHEN AN ADULT IN A
POSITION OF AUTHORITY IS CLEARLY
BUYING INTO THE, PERCEPTION THAT
THE CHILD IS THE DIFFERENT, CHEN
ORDER, AND THAT IS CROSSING A
LINE. NOW, HOW THAT IS MANIFEST
ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS IS A REAL
DIFFICULT TO PIN DOWN IN ANY
SITUATION. THÀNH I CAN JUST TELL
YOU FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE,
AFTER TAKING CARE OF HUNDREDS OF
KIDS NOW Ã THOUSANDS OF KIDS,
THAT WHEN A TEACHER, EVEN THE
TEACHERS THEY DON'T LIKE, AGREED
TO A CERTAIN MODE OF PERCEPTION
OF REALITY, THE KIDS START
SAYING, OH YEAH, YEAH, THAT
MAKES SENSE. I MUST BE RIGHT
ABOUT THIS. INSTEAD OF AN ADULT
TAKING THE TIME TO SAY, HEY,
JOHNNY, WHAT? WHAT'S GOING ON?
BUT BUT AGAIN, THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS, THIS LEGISLATION
THAT PREVENTS THE TEACHER FROM
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION. NO,
NO, THERE'S NOT. BUT THE THING
IS, THERE IS, IN THIS
LEGISLATION, A PREVENTIVE OF THE
TEACHER ACTUALLY RECOGNIZING
THIS IS GOING A LITTLE TOO FAR.
I NEED TO TELL MOM AND DAD
WHAT'S GOING ON. BUT THAT
TEACHER IN IN SORT OF CONVERSING
WITH THE STUDENT COULD SECURE
THAT STUDENT'S PERMISSION TO
TALK TO A PARENT. RIGHT. UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION, I DON'T THINK
WHAT THIS WHAT THIS BILL, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT DOES, IS IT
PROHIBITS THE BLANKET
REQUIREMENT OF NOTIFICATION IN
THAT INSTANCE OF. RIGHT. SO MISS
HEARST AND. OKAY, GOOD. I KNOW
YOU ASKED ME A QUESTION ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, KIDS BEING OUT OF
THEIR HOMES. AND I FIRST WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT THROUGH
MY WORK WITH THE CRISIS HOTLINE,
WE HAVE HAD CHILDREN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS PAST
YEAR WHO ARE KICKED OUT AND
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF BEING OUTED
AT HOME, SO I DO WANT TO MAKE
THAT POINT, I ALSO WANTED TO
STATE THAT IF A CHILD IS
STRUGGLING MENTALLY AND IN HARM
OR BEING BULLIED, THOSE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE PARENTS ARE
NOTIFIED THAT EXISTS OUTSIDE OF
THE PRIVY OF THIS POLICY AND OF
ITSELF. THAT'S ALREADY A POLICY
THAT EXISTS. AND PARENTS
ABSOLUTELY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
INVOLVED IN THAT. AND THEY ARE,
AND I JUST IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THE DOCTOR TOLD
THE NATIONAL CATHOLIC REGISTER
HE'S A PEDIATRIC GASTRO
ENTOMOLOGIST WHO DOES NOT
SPECIALIZE IN GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. SO I THINK THAT IT'S
TAKING WHAT HE'S SAYING IS MAYBE
NOT, I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SOME
OF THE TREATMENT. SO YOU'RE THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS WILL GIVE YOU
ALL THE RESPECT THAT YOU DO AS
THE WITNESS. BUT UNDERSTOOD. CAN
I JUST MAKE A CAN I JUST MAKE A
POINT ABOUT THAT? FIRST OF ALL,
THE IDEA THAT A CHILD IS THAT A
CHILD CAN TRUST WHAT A PARENT IS
GOING TO SAY OR WHAT A SCHOOL
BOARD IS GOING TO SAY IS, IS A
REAL BIG QUESTION. OKAY? WHEN
THEY TALK TO AN ADULT AND THEY
REVEAL SOMETHING TO THEM THAT IS
IN SOME WAY POTENTIALLY HARMFUL,
THEY, WE AS ADULTS NEED TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT KIDS ALL THE
TIME. AND I DON'T BELIEVE FOR A
MOMENT THAT SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
RETHINK OR THINK LOGICALLY,
NECESSARILY, AND PARTICULARLY
ABOUT THE BULLYING ISSUE I'VE
HAD. YOU KNOW, WE'VE ALL BEEN
THROUGH SCHOOLS HERE. I'VE BEEN
THROUGH PUBLIC SCHOOL HERE.
PLENTY OF PEOPLE IN HERE HAVE
BEEN THROUGH THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS, AND I'VE
NEVER SEEN A KID GETTING BULLIED
VERY SELDOMLY SEEN A KID GETTING
BULLIED, WHO ANY OF ANY OF THE
ADMINISTRATORS OR TEACHERS
TALKED ABOUT IT. THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT IT. AND THESE KIDS, I'M
NOT SURE WHAT'S THE POINT.
YOU'RE MAKING HERE? THE POINT
I'M MAKING IS THAT TO SAY THAT
THEIR INSTRUCTOR TO INFORM
ANYBODY THAT THE KID IS GETTING
BULLIED, THAT'S A NICE THING TO
SAY. BUT IN REALITY, THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN. SEPARATE
POLICIES, SEPARATE CONVERSATION
ABOUT BULLYING. RIGHT. AND I
THINK THE EVIDENCE IS QUITE
CLEAR THAT LGBTQ PLUS AND
TRANSGENDER KIDS DO, IN FACT GET
BULLIED. WHETHER OR NOT YOU SEE
IT SAY THAT, THAT THE SCHOOL
BOARD IS GOING TO BE IN THE, IN
THE BEST POSITION TO REPORT THAT
SCHOOL BOARD OR THE SCHOOL, THE
TEACHERS, WHOEVER THEY DON'T,
THEY FREQUENTLY FAIL A LOT OF
THE TIME TO TELL ANYBODY WE
SHOULDN'T ASPIRE TO BETTER THAN
THAT, ONLY ON A QUESTION OF LAW,
A QUESTION OF LAW. SO WHAT
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE MISSING IS
CURRENTLY ALMOST AT EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT THERE'S A POLICY CALLED
R ONE, R51 45.3. AND THIS POLICY
REQUIRES THAT SCHOOLS KEEP A
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS TRANSGENDER
IDENTITY SECRET UNLESS THE
STUDENT SAYS THAT THAT IT'S OKAY
TO REVEAL IT. SO IT IS THE CHILD
THAT IS MAKING THE DECISION, THE
CHILD WHO COULD BE FOR FIVE SIX.
THE CHILD WHO COULD BE SUICIDAL,
OR THE CHILD WHO COULD HAVE
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THE
CHILD IS THE ONE DICTATING
WHETHER THIS IS REVEAL. HOWEVER,
EVERYONE AT THE SCHOOL KNOWS
EXCEPT FOR THE PARENTS, THE
PARENTS WHO ARE THE ONLY ONES
WHO ARE ABLE TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
AND AURORA'S DAUGHTER WAS TOLD
BY THE SCHOOL TO LIE TO HER
ABOUT HER TRANSGENDER STATUS, TO
LIE TO HER OWN MOTHER. AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
SCHOOLS. OKAY AND THAT MAY HAVE
HAPPENED IN THAT INSTANCE, BUT
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S WHAT ALWAYS
HAPPENS. MR. VERY QUICKLY, I
KNOW YOU HAVE SOMETHING YOU
WANTED TO ADD. I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT KIDS
PERSPECTIVES, AND SINCE THERE'S
NOT A CHILD HERE, I'D LIKE TO
READ AN EXCERPT FROM A STUDENT'S
PERSPECTIVE SHARED IN THIS
BUILDING EARLIER THIS MONTH. HE
SAID, HAD I NOT HAD A SINGLE
SUPPORTIVE ADULT IN MY LIFE, HIS
TEACHER, I NEVER WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND THE STRENGTH TO
COME OUT TO MY FAMILY OR TEACH
THEM WHAT I HAD LEARNED ABOUT
WHO I AM. WITHOUT A SUPPORTIVE
ADULT, I WOULD NOT HAVE HAD MY
SUPPORTIVE PARENTS BESIDE ME
HERE TODAY AND WHAT THESE
POLICIES REALLY END UP DOING,
AND WHAT WE SAW IN CHINO VALLEY,
IS THAT THE STUDENTS WHO NEED
THE MOST SUPPORT ACTUALLY THEN
CLOSET THEMSELVES AND THEY ARE
UNABLE TO SEEK SUPPORT. THEY ARE
UNABLE TO COME TO THE SUPPORT OF
ADULTS IN THEIR LIFE AND
TEACHERS, AND LET THEM KNOW THEY
ARE BEING BULLIED FOR THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY AND THEIR
TRANSGENDER STATUS BECAUSE OUT
OF FEAR THAT THEN THEY WILL BE
FORCIBLY OUTED. AND SO WE ARE
ISOLATING THESE KIDS WHO NEED
OUR HELP THE MOST. AND I THINK,
I WOULD HOPE WE EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM, NO MATTER HOW WE FEEL, WE
CAN SET THAT ASIDE AND LOOK AT
THE FACTS AND THE FACT IS, WHEN
YOU FORCIBLY OUT KIDS, WE
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING HELP
AND SUPPORT AND IT IS HARMFUL.
ALL THE DATA SHOWS IT OVER AND
OVER, REPEATEDLY, AND FAMILIES
THAT ARE AFFIRMING DO NOT WANT
THESE POLICIES, BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT WHEN OUR CHILD IS FORCIBLY
OUTED, IT IS HARMFUL TO THEM AND
IT HARMS OUR RELATIONSHIP. AND
AS A MOM, OF COURSE, I WANT MY
KIDS TO COME TO ME AND I TRY TO
ENSURE THAT WILL HAPPEN BY OPEN
COMMUNICATION WITH MY TEACHERS,
WITH THE SCHOOL AND WITH MY
CHILDREN, EXPLICITLY LETTING
THEM KNOW THAT I WILL LOVE AND
ACCEPT THEM NO MATTER WHAT. I
SPEAK POSITIVELY ABOUT LGBTQIA
ISSUES, AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
THEY COME TO ME, IT WILL BE DONE
IN A HEALTHY COMMUNITY HATING,
SUPPORTIVE WAY. SO LET ME ASK
BRIEFLY. SO. THIS HAS TO DO
WITH, THE POINT ABOUT BEING A
PEDIATRIC GASTROENTEROLOGIST AND
THAT ROLE, A BIG CHUNK OF THE
KIDS THEY TAKE CARE OF ARE
ADOLESCENT WHO HAVE BELLY ACHES,
WHO I NEED TO DO A BIG,
DIFFERENTIAL AND WORKUP ON FOR
THEIR BELLY ACHE. AND THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE OTHERWISE,
NORMAL KIDS PHYSIOLOGICALLY, WHO
ARE NEUROTIC AND UPSET AND
ANXIOUS AND I'VE SEEN OVER THE
COURSE OF JUST THE LAST THREE
YEARS, A HUGE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF THESE KIDS BEING TRANS
IDENTIFIED FEMALE ADOLESCENTS
WHO OFTEN WILL BE COMING INTO MY
OFFICE. AND THIS ISN'T JUST A
ONE OFF. I'VE SEEN A BUNCH OF
THESE KIDS LIKE THIS. THEY'RE
DRESSED IN REAL BULKY CLOTHES,
OVERSIZE, OVERSIZE. AND WHEN YOU
REALLY GET INTO TALKING WITH
THEM AT LENGTH AND YOU GET TO
KNOW THEM OVER TIME, THEY JUST
WANT TO BE A LITTLE GIRL AGAIN.
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN
BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD TOO MANY
ADVANCES FROM NEFARIOUS ADULTS.
AND THE FLIP SIDE IS TRUE. I'VE
HAD KIDS LIKE THIS WHO COME INTO
MY OFFICE, WHO ARE, WHO ARE
TRYING WHO ARE TRYING TO FIND A
WAY TO BE A DIFFERENT SEX
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THEY DON'T
GET THE ATTENTION THAT THEY WANT
IN THE GIVEN SEX. AND IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT THEY
REALLY WHAT THEY'RE TRANSGENDER.
I APPRECIATE YOUR POINT, BUT THE
REAL QUESTION HERE IS WHAT
HAPPENS AT SCHOOL, RIGHT? SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT I GUESS
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AROUND GENDER DYSPHORIA. BUT THE
POINT WAS ALSO MADE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, BECAUSE OF THESE
POLICIES, LGBTQ OR QUESTIONING
KIDS GET CAUGHT UP IN THIS AND
ARE FORCED TO BE OUTED AS PART
OF THAT. IS THERE ANY WAY THAT
WOULD YOU MAKE A DISTINCTION,
LIKE WITHIN THE LEGISLATION
BETWEEN THE GENDER DYSPHORIA
PORTION VERSUS SIMPLY
RESPECTING, YOU KNOW, A KIDS
SORT OF EVOLVING SEXUAL
IDENTITY? I MEAN, I ASSUME YOU
CAN'T, BUT HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE
THINK ABOUT THAT? LET'S BE
CLEAR, BECAUSE WE'VE GONE DOWN A
TANGENT, A RELATED TANGENT. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IT IS NOT ABOUT GENDER
DYSPHORIA, AND IT IS NOT ABOUT
MEDICAL DECISIONS THAT IS
COVERED IN SEPARATE CONVERSATION
AND IS VERY ALSO CLEAR IN
TODAY'S LAW. IN CALIFORNIA, THIS
IS ABOUT HARMFUL POLICIES. AND
WHEN WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
LOCAL DISTRICT POLICY, WHICH IS
FORCIBLY IS OUTING STUDENTS AND
IT FURTHERMORE, AND I THINK TO
SOME OF THESE POINTS AS WELL,
ACTUALLY IS PROACTIVE IN ITS WAY
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE DISTRICT
RESOURCES THAT REALLY TAKE THAT
CONVERSATION OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM. REFERRALS FOR
PARENTS, GUARDIANS, FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS TO SUPPORT GROUPS,
SPACE, SAFE SPACES, REFERENCE TO
ANTI-BULLYING AND HARASSMENT
POLICIES, COUNSELING SERVICES.
THESE ARE APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORT
NETWORKS THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
FOR THE CLASSROOM, FOR THE
TEACHER TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOB, AND THAT IS TO TEACH THE
SUBJECTS FOR WHICH THEIR, THEIR,
THEIR, THEIR JOB IS DIRECTED. SO
I JUST I DON'T WANT TO JUST
RETRACT. I THINK THE CORE
OBLIGATION OF THIS LEGISLATION
FROM WHAT IT IS INTENDING TO DO,
SEPARATE FROM OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT I KNOW INTERSECT WITH THIS
POPULATION, I AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT
US BACK TO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATION. AND SO, SENATOR
WILK, GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL, I
APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY, AND I APPRECIATE THE
WAY THAT THAT YOU'RE HANDLING
THIS AND YOU ALREADY KNOW THAT
I'M NOT GOING TO BE BE
SUPPORTIVE AND THESE MAY BE BAD
OR ROGUE SCHOOL DISTRICTS, BUT I
THINK PARENTAL IN MY VIEW,
PARENTAL RIGHTS TRUMPS, YOU
KNOW, BAD POLICY THERE. IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO CHANGE SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS. I MEAN, IF WE GOT
JUDGED ON THE JOB WE DO AS
POLICY MAKERS, WE SHOULD ALL BE
OUT OF HERE BECAUSE WE'VE NOT
DONE A GOOD JOB FOR CALIFORNIA.
BUT THAT'S A SIDE. SO THIS IS
THIS IS GOING TO BECOME LAW. SO
I KNOW THAT. SO I JUST WAS
READING THROUGH THE BILL LAST
NIGHT. SO I JUST I JUST GOT A
COUPLE SECTIONS I WANT TO READ
AND THEN JUST, JUST SO I HAVE IT
ON THE RECORD. SO AND I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO KNOW I'M NOT
TRYING TO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANSWERS TO ALL THIS. I JUST WANT
TO KIND OF GET ON THE RECORD. SO
I'M GOING TO READ THIS, READ THE
SECTION, THEN ASK, ASK THE
QUESTION. SO IN SECTION 2K1 IT
STATES TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF
CAN PROVIDE CRUCIAL SUPPORT TO
LGBTQ PLUS YOUNG PEOPLE AND PLAY
AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN ENCOURAGING
THEM TO SEEK OUT APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT. SO A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. SO UNDER THE
BILL, IF AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY IDENTIFIED
THAT IT COULD START KINDERGARTEN
UP, IF AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENT IDENTIFIED AS
QUESTIONING AND SAID THEY DIDN'T
WANT THEIR PARENTS TO KNOW AND
WANTED TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
GENDER IDENTITY AND POTENTIALLY
TRANSITIONING, WHAT WOULD AN
EDUCATIONAL PROVIDER BE REQUIRED
TO DO TO COMPLY WITH THAT LAW?
SO THE SUBSECTION THAT YOU HAD
REFERENCED IS PART OF OUR
FINDINGS. AND DECLARATION, WHICH
ESTABLISHES, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
HOW TO WRITE A BILL, AND YES,
IT'S JUST AN AFFIRMATIVE
STATEMENT THAT IT'S NOT
EXCLUSIONARY OF OTHER STATEMENTS
AS WELL, THAT TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS AND STAFF CAN PROVIDE
CRUCIAL SUPPORT TO YOUNG PEOPLE
AND SO, TO YOUR QUESTION, WHAT
WOULD THE DIRECTION THAT I THINK
REFERENCES ALSO IS HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE ANALYSIS, A TEACHER TO BE
ABLE TO DO AND THAT IS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS RESOURCES THAT
ARE REGULARLY UPDATED, WHICH ARE
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE, FOR
SERVING PUPILS IN GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH 12, A MENU OF OPTIONS
THAT PROVIDES FOR SUPPORT
GROUPS, SAFE SPACES, EXISTING
POLICIES LIKE ANTI-BULLYING,
HARASSMENT, SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES, COUNSELING SERVICES, A
GAMUT OF OPTIONS THAT CAN COME
WITH THAT. SO AGAIN, THEY CAN BE
ABLE TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
AND HOPEFULLY, HOPEFULLY TAKE
THAT HOME TO THE PARENTS AND
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS AS.
RIGHT. WELL, YOU AND I HAVE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT I KNOW
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE A GREAT
PARENT AND I KNOW YOU AND YOUR
AND YOUR SPOUSE AND I HAVEN'T
MET YOUR KIDS, BUT I'M SURE THAT
THEY'RE GREAT. AND WE KNOW THAT
VAST MAJORITY OF PARENTS LOVE
THEIR KIDS AND BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE. AND THERE IS SOME
THAT THAT AREN'T. AND SO I
SOMETIMES I THINK WE, PENALIZE
THE 97% THAT ARE GOOD TO GO
AFTER THE 3% WHO ARE BAD. SO I
JUST ONE ONE OTHER QUESTION AS
IT RELATES. SO UNDER THE FEDERAL
FAMILY EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS AND
PRIVACY ACT, PARENTS HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO ACCESS ANY AND
ALL PUBLIC RECORDS RELATED TO
THEIR CHILD. SO UNDER FERPA,
WOULD PARENTS BE ENTITLED TO
ACCESS INFORMATION REGARDING THE
CHILD'S GENDER IDENTITY AND
PRONOUNS? AND DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE FOR THAT? CAN YOU CAN
YOU READ THE. YEAH, OF COURSE.
YEAH. SO UNDER FEDERAL LAW,
PARENTS HAVE AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO ACCESS ALL ALL THE
INFORMATION. SO WOULD THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT? YES. UNDER
FERPA, THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
SCHOOL RECORDS. SO, IF THE
SCHOOL, IF THE STUDENT, CHANGED
THEIR IDENTITY OR WHATEVER IS
THIS IS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
OBLIGATED TO PUT THAT IN THE
OFFICIAL RECORDS? ANY OFFICIAL
RECORDS? Ã. AND I THINK THAT
WOULD INCLUDE MEDICAL, SAY, AT
THE SCHOOL NURSE'S OFFICE, ANY
ANYTHING THAT IS THAT IS A
RECORD WOULD BE ELIGIBLE UNDER
FERPA. OKAY, GREAT. APPRECIATE
THAT. AGAIN, I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY
BECAUSE THIS CONCEPTUALLY, I
THINK IT GOES TOO FAR. BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DIALOG
WE'VE HAD AND THE WAY YOU
CONDUCT YOURSELF AND TRYING TO
BRING THE TEMPERATURE DOWN,
BECAUSE THESE ARE AS YOU KNOW,
SENSITIVE ISSUES. SO JUST JUST
APPRECIATE YOU. BUT JUST CAN'T
BE THERE WITH YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU. AND LET ME ALSO POINT OUT,
SENATOR WILK HAD A BILL EARLIER
THIS YEAR THAT THAT WOULD ENSURE
THAT PARENTS HAD ACCESS OR
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY A SCHOOL. I'M SURE
IT'S GOING TO GET KILLED IN
THESE. I, I WAS HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR IT, AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
WRAP UP HERE AND LET, LET ME SAY
I WANT TO, YOU KNOW, HONOR THE,
SORT OF ASSERTION BY ALL OF THE
PARTICIPANTS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
PARENTS DO LOVE THEIR KIDS AND
THEY WANT THE BEST FOR THEIR
KIDS, AND THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
THE IRONY HERE IS THAT THIS BILL
IS NOT REALLY INTENDED FOR THOSE
PARENTS WHO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THOSE KIDS THAT ALLOWS FOR
THAT SORT OF FREE AND LOVING
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION. THIS IS
VERY, VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION
WHERE WHERE STUDENTS ARE
CHILDREN DO NOT HAVE THAT
COMFORT AND FIND IN SCHOOL THE
ONLY PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY, SORT OF EXERCISE AND
AFFIRM THEIR GENDER IDENTITY AT
THAT TIME IN THEIR LIVES, WHICH
IS A CHALLENGING TIME. AND SO
IT'S FOR THOSE KIDS WHO ARE
GOING THROUGH, YOU KNOW, AN
AWKWARD AND VERY EXCRUCIATING
TIME THAT THAT I THINK THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY. AND AS I
UNDERSTAND, THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS BILL THAT PREVENTS A
SCHOOL OR TEACHERS FROM ACTING
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THOSE
CHILDREN. IT'S WE'RE TRYING TO
ENSURE A SITUATION WHERE WE
DON'T REQUIRE, AS A BLANKET
MATTER, THE SCHOOLS TO INSERT
THEMSELVES IN A WAY THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE, THAT MAY INFLAME
THOSE TENSIONS AT HOME. AND SO
WITH THAT, I THIS IS CLEARLY A
BIG DEAL. AND. I OKAY, MISS
FRIDAY. WHAT WHAT FERPA AND THE
WAY IT WORKS IN THE REAL WORLD,
BECAUSE I AM A LICENSED
ATTORNEY. AND SO WHEN MY
DAUGHTER CAME OUT AS A
TRANSGENDER CHILD, I DID A FERPA
REQUEST TO TEST THE SCHOOL TO
SEE IF THE SCHOOL WOULD LIE TO
ME ONE MORE TIME. I REQUESTED,
UNDER FERPA, ALL OF MY
DAUGHTER'S RECORDS, AND I KNEW
THAT THEY WERE CALLING HER BY A
MALE NAME AND USING MALE
PRONOUNS. AND I DID NOT RECEIVE
ONE OF THOSE RECORDS. AND I WORK
WITH HUNDREDS OF PARENTS, AND I
TELL THEM TO SEND THE SAME FERPA
REQUEST, AND THEY KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILD IS BEING CALLED BY A
DIFFERENT NAME, AND THEY NEVER
GET THOSE RECORDS. I GUARANTEE
YOU THEY NEVER GET THOSE RECORDS
BECAUSE THEY CREATE A SECRET
FILE. ALL THAT IS HELD BE HELD
IN A Ã ADMINISTRATOR'S OFFICE.
SO THEY KEEP THAT INFORMATION
SECRET FROM PARENTS. SO LET ME
THAT'S FAIR. SO,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S, WHERE DOES
THIS BILL ALLOW FOR A SCHOOL TO
KEEP A SECRET FILE OR OTHERWISE
NOT ADHERE TO FERPA? THAT'S
BLASPHEMY. THERE THIS LAW DOES
NOT SUPERSEDE FERPA, RIGHT?
STATE LAWS DO NOT SUPERSEDE
FEDERAL LAWS. WE UNDERSTAND THIS
. AND I'M SORRY IF THERE WAS A
RECORD THEY DID NOT PROVIDE FOR
YOU, THEN YOU PROBABLY HAVE
GROUNDS TO BE ABLE TO CHALLENGE
THEM FURTHER ON THAT. BUT THEY
SHOULD HAVE PROVIDED YOU ALL OF
THE RECORDS THAT EXISTED. IS
THERE ANYTHING IMPLICIT IN YOUR
BILL THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE A
SCHOOL? ABSOLUTELY NOT. FEDERAL
LAW. FAIR ENOUGH. SO HAVING SAID
THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS THIS
CONVERSATION AND I'VE GIVEN IT A
VERY DELIBERATE KIND OF LONG
LEASH BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR BOTH
SIDES AND WE HEAR IT FULLY, AND
I THINK WE HAVE TODAY, AND I
APPRECIATE THE INPUT OF BOTH THE
SUPPORT WITNESS, THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE, I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY, AND I
HOPE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE, SORT
OF WORKING ON THESE
CONVERSATIONS TO THE
SATISFACTION OF ALL PARTIES. AND
SO WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, SENATORS, I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING FOR A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE, I KNOW THAT THE
CONVERSATION DOES NEED TO
CONTINUE. AND BECAUSE THERE ARE
A LOT OF, RELATED, POINTS THAT
ARE WORTHY OF CONSIDERATION,
THAT THIS DESERVES TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE. SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR, ATTENTION THIS MORNING,
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, IS
OVER THE LAST YEAR, WE HAVE
SEEN, AN EXPLOSION OF UNREST AND
ULTIMATELY HARMFUL POLICIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. AND AS I WANT
TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT AND THANK, OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, WHO WENT RIGHT DOWN
TO CHINO VALLEY AND WAS FORCIBLY
EVICTED FROM THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONVERSATION, UNABLE
TO BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE AS OUR
LEAD, AS OUR LEAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHO HAS,
THROUGH HIS LEADERSHIP, BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW, ATTESTING OF A LOT
OF THESE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AS
WELL. AND SOME OF THOSE ARE NOT
FULLY RESOLVED THROUGH OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM, BUT WHERE THIS BRINGS US
HERE TODAY IS AN AFFIRMATION
THAT I THINK ON, ON SEVERAL
FRONTS. ONE, MUCH OF THE COURT
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN UPHOLDING, I
THINK, SUPERIOR ELEMENTS OF THE
LAW THAT RESPECT A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AND REALLY TRY TO
DE-EMPHASIZE, I THINK, THE
POLITICIZATION OF A LOT OF THIS
POLICY MAKING. TWO, WE'VE GOT TO
REMEMBER THAT NOTHING IN THIS
BILL ACTUALLY PREVENTS PARENTS
FROM HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR, THEIR
CHILDREN, AND THAT SHOULD BE
DONE IN A TIME AND A PLACE IN A
MANNER, THAT IS APPROPRIATE TO
THEM AS WELL. SO THEY CAN HAVE
THOSE KINDS OF CONVERSATIONS,
AND I ENCOURAGE THEM TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. AND IF A
CHILD IS EXPRESSING ANY
CONFUSION OR QUESTION OR JUST,
YOU KNOW, HOW THEIR, HOW THEIR
HOW THEIR DEVELOPMENT IS GOING,
I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD
LOVE THEM UNCONDITIONALLY.
THIRD, IT MAKES SURE THAT
THROUGH ALL OF THIS
POLITICIZATION AND LOCAL
DISTRICT NOISE THAT WE'RE
SEEING, THAT WE'RE JUST GETTING
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE A FEW
YEARS AGO, WHICH IS ALLOWING
TEACHERS TO TEACH AND BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH TO THRIVE.
BECAUSE WHEN THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN, AND OUR OWN RESEARCH IS
SHOWING THAT THOSE STUDENTS THAT
ARE FEELING THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
A SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT ARE LESS LIKELY TO
CONTINUE ON TO HIGHER EDUCATION,
MORE LIKELY OF HARM TO
THEMSELVES, AND THE SPIRAL
EFFECT DOWNWARD, I THINK, IS
SHOWING IN THE NUMBER OF YOUTH
THAT WE SEE ON OUR STREETS AND
THOSE THAT ARE HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AS YOUNG
ADULTS, AND EVEN LATENT EFFECTS
INTO FULL ADULTHOOD. SO FOR ALL
OF THESE REASONS, I BELIEVE THAT
THE SAFETY ACT, AS WE PROVIDED
HERE TODAY IS WELL GROUNDED, NOT
JUST IN ITS CONCEPTUAL PRINCIPLE
AND WHAT SOME OF US FEEL ARE
BEST APPROACHES, BUT ALSO IN THE
DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST 12 MONTHS AS THIS HAS
EXPLODED IN OUR IN SOME HOME
COMMUNITIES. AND SO FOR THAT, I
ASK THAT YOU LET THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO WORK ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
I AM ALWAYS REVISITING MY OWN
LEGISLATION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING THIS RIGHT, AND I'M
WILLING TO AND OPEN TO BE ABLE
TO THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE DEEP
AND FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS THAT
THAT ESPECIALLY THIS BILL, BUT
ANY OF MY PIECES OF LEGISLATION
WORK ON BUT THERE ARE
PRINCIPLES, AND I THINK THOSE
ARE MUCH DATA DRIVEN FOR ME THAT
WE HAVE TO DRAW A LINE ON. AND
ULTIMATELY, THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR YOUTH. AND THAT'S
WHY I'VE INTRODUCED THIS HERE
TODAY. AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. AND I KNOW WE HAD A MOTION
FROM WHAT SEEMS LIKE A VERY LONG
TIME AGO FROM SENATOR GLAZER,
AND WITH THAT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR ITEM ONE. AB 1955 WARD
MÐI IS Dð PASS TO THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA BOGH.
CORTESE. CORTESE, AYE. GLAZER
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. NÓ.
WILK NO. THAT MEASURE NOW HAS
FOUR VOTES FOR ONE AGAINST.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS, MEMBER, AND WITH
THAT, THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A SHORT RECESS, I'M NOT
SURE YOU ALL WANT TO STAY FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN'S BILL.
ALTHOUGH YOU SHOULD. HE DOES.
EXCELLENT LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU. EVERYBODY.
THE NORMAL ORDER OF BUSINESS
HERE, WE WELCOME NOW TO THE
PODIUM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HOLDEN,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE,
SIR. YOU MIGHT HAVE WISHED YOU
DIDN'T SHOW UP ON TIME FOR.
WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE, NØ.
AND YOU WILL BE PRESENTING AB
359. AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
FOR GIVING ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 359, WHICH IS A PHASE
ONE OF DUAL ENROLLMENT REFORM,
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND COMING UP WITH AN
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT AND I APPRECIATE
THE COLLABORATION. AB 359
CONSISTS OF POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM DUAL
ENROLLMENT ADVOCATES THAT WERE
PRESENTED AT LAST YEAR'S
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
OVERSIGHT HEARING. THIS BILL
MAKES NECESSARY CHANGES TO
EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS OF C-CAP BY MAKING IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY STUDENT
TO PARTICIPATE. THE EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING. JUST HOW IMPACTFUL
AND EQUITABLE C-CAP IS AT
IMPROVING COLLEGE READINESS FOR
OUR STUDENTS. C-CAP STUDENTS ARE
MORE LIKELY THAN OTHERS TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND EARN
COLLEGE DEGREES. IT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN MY INTENTION SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF AB 288. IN 2015,
TO ALLOW SCHOOLS THE FLEXIBILITY
TO PREPARE THEIR STUDENTS FOR
THE WORKFORCE AND FOR FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES. THIS BILL BUILDS
ON GREAT WORK C-CAP HAS
ACCOMPLISHED BY ELIMINATING
BARRIERS FACED BY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS, LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES, AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS. AB
359 PROVIDES CLARIFYING CHANGES
AND ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK TO
INTEGRATE PATHWAYS INTO EVERY
C-CAP PARTNERSHIP. SPECIFICALLY,
AB 359 DOES THE FOLLOWING.
STREAMLINE STUDENT ENROLLMENT
AND PARTICIPATION IN C-CAP BY
REMOVING THE PRINCIPAL'S
RECOMMENDATION AND REQUIRING
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE ONE
APPLICATION. ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OUTSIDE OF THEIR SERVICE AREA IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
PROVIDES SCHOOLS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH COURSES
ONLINE WITH APPROPRIATE STUDENT
SUPPORT IN PLACE, AND ENSURE
STUDENTS RECEIVE CREDIT FOR THE
COURSES THEY COMPLETE ON THEIR
UNIQUE PATHWAY. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE CELESTE
LOPEZ, FORMER C-CAP PARTICIPANT
AND CURRENT COLLEGE STUDENT, AND
CAROL GONZALEZ, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH EDUCATION TRUST
WEST. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOUR
WITNESSES ARE WELCOME TO BOTH OF
YOU. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CELESTE LOPEZ AND I
AM A STAFF. IS IT WORKING? OH IT
WAS. YEAH JUST. YEAH. BRING THE
MIC JUST A LITTLE BIT CLOSER,
MISS LOPEZ. YOU'RE GOOD. THAT
DOESN'T COUNT AGAINST YOUR THREE
MINUTES. NO THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CELESTE LOPEZ AND I AM A
SOPHOMORE MAJORING IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT SAC CITY. WITH FUTURE
GOALS OF GOING TO LAW SCHOOL TO
BECOME A LAWYER. I PARTICIPATED
IN THE C-CAP DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAM, THE FIRST YEAR IT WAS
INTRODUCED AT DAVIS SENIOR HIGH
AS A JUNIOR IN 2022. GIVEN THE
ONLY A LIMITED VARIETY OF
COURSES WAS AVAILABLE, I ONLY
MANAGED TO TAKE SEVEN COURSES
ACROSS MY REMAINING HIGH SCHOOL
YEARS WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT
THE C-CAP PROGRAM, IT'S HONESTLY
SEEMS LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TOO
GOOD TO BE TRUE. AS SOMEONE
WHOSE GOAL WAS ALWAYS TO PURSUE
MY EDUCATION WHILE EQUALLY
WANTING TO DO SO IN THE MOST
FINANCIALLY EFFICIENT WAY. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE COLLEGE
COURSES AND RECEIVE TRANSFERABLE
UNITS AT NO COST SEEMED
INCREDIBLE. EVEN STILL, THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAM OFFERS SO
MUCH MORE TO STUDENTS THAN A
MORE ATTAINABLE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE. THE HSC TEAM AT MY
SCHOOL WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND TO
ENSURE THAT I WAS NEVER ALONE IN
THE APPLICATION PROCESS. ONCE I
WAS READY TO TRANSFER TO SAC
CITY, AND REASSURING THAT I FELT
SECURE IN KNOWING THAT HELP WAS
ONLY A PHONE CALL AWAY, MY
COLLEGE JOURNEY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN AS SMOOTH AND AS EASY HAD I
NOT GOTTEN ACCLIMATED DIRECTLY
BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAM. IN
TRYING TO FIND SOMETHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT DUAL ENROLLMENT,
THE ONLY THING THAT COMES TO
MIND IS DISAPPOINTMENT THAT I
DID NOT HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
SINCE I WAS A FIRST YEAR STUDENT
IN HIGH SCHOOL, AS I KNOW THE
ENORMOUS POSSIBILITIES AND
INFLUENCE THIS WOULD HAVE HAD ON
YOUTHS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
THEIR ACADEMIC DREAMS AS WELL AS
MINE. ASSEMBLY BILL 359 WOULD
ONLY HELP REINFORCE THE LIFE
CHANGING PATHWAY. THE CAP DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAM WOULD OFFER,
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE FACING
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES IN PURSUING
THEIR EDUCATION. THERE IS NEVER
A DOWNSIDE TO PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY AND PATH TO THOSE
WHOSE EDUCATIONAL DREAMS OF
SUCCESS SEEM FAR REACHING. FOR
THESE REASONS, I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL 359 AND
HOPE IT RESONATES WITH YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE WELCOME. HI. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN AND
MEMBERS, MY NAME IS CAROL
GONZALEZ, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF EDUCATION TRUST WEST, A
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING POLICIES AND PRACTICES
THAT DISMANTLE THE RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC BARRIERS EMBEDDED IN
OUR CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND A LANDMARK REPORT, JUMPSTART
US WEST, ANALYZES DUAL
ENROLLMENT DATA AND FINDS THAT
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE NOT YET
EQUITABLY SERVING BLACK, NATIVE,
AND LATINX STUDENTS THROUGH DUAL
ENROLLMENT EDUCATION LEADERS AND
POLICYMAKERS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REIMAGINE HOW STRATEGIES LIKE
DUAL ENROLLMENT CAN TRANSFORM
OUR SYSTEM AND STUDENTS LIVES.
THEREFORE, STRATEGIES TO
INCREASE DUAL ENROLLMENT, ACCESS
AND PARTICIPATION MUST CENTER ON
THE NEEDS OF THESE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. COLLEGE AND CAREER
ACCESS PATHWAYS, OR C-CAP
PARTNERSHIPS AIMED TO PROVIDE
EARLY EXPOSURE TO COLLEGE
COURSES FOR STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT
BE COLLEGE BOUND OR ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. AB 359 WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LEAS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENTS AND
EXPAND COURSE OFFERINGS, AN
ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP TOWARDS
IMPROVING ACCESS. WE ARE
PARTICULARLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
STUDENT FRIENDLY AMENDMENTS THAT
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
PRINCIPAL RECOMMENDATION.
CLARIFY THAT STUDENTS SHOULD
ONLY SUBMIT ONE APPLICATION FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION AND ENABLE
COLLEGES TO OFFER COURSES ONLY
TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AT
COLLEGE CAMPUSES, HIGH SCHOOL OR
ONLINE. MODALITIES WE ARE. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT AB 359
PROHIBITS FROM OFFERING PRE
COURSE PRE TRANSFER COURSEWORK
THROUGH C-CAP AND ENHANCES
STUDENTS ACCESS TO COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSEWORK. THESE CHALLENGES
THESE CHANGES SORRY. THESE
CHANGES WILL ENSURE THAT C-CAP
PARTNERSHIPS ARE ALIGNED AND
ENGAGED WITH STATEWIDE EFFORTS
TO PHASE OUT REMEDIAL EDUCATION.
WITH THAT, I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN FOR BEING
A STEADFAST CHAMPION OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND COMMITTED TO
GETTING C-CAP PROGRAM RIGHT
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN 2015, AND
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
DILIGENCE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS, ADVOCATES,
COMMITTEE STAFF TO ADDRESS DUAL
ENROLLMENT, STUDENT NEEDS AND
CHALLENGES. IT'S OUR GOAL TO
MAKE C-CAP A REALITY FOR EVERY
STUDENT AND TO ENSURE THEY GET A
JUMP START FOR THEIR EDUCATION.
JUST LIKE CELESTE AND HOW SHE
SHARED WITH US TODAY. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
AND THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? IF SO,
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE,
STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. DIANA VU, ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
SARAH BACHUS WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. SAMARA
PALKA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. ANA IOAKIMIDIS ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
DOMINIQUE TANI WITH EDVOICE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MARIA MORALES ON BEHALF
OF HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ADAM
KAGAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
TELEVISION ACADEMY FOUNDATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, STELLA
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
AND SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, BELLA KERN ON BEHALF OF
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SEAN O'NEILL, DIRECTOR
OF DUAL ENROLLMENT FOR LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. NAYELI. THE SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION, EARLY COLLEGE
PROGRAM AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO, SAM NASH, ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. BRENDAN AMMERMAN, STUDENT
SUPPORT SPECIALIST, ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, KARLA RODRIGUEZ
BELTRAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
LET'S NOW GO TO OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO. OH, PLEASE. SORRY,
TIFFANY MOCK, ON BEHALF OF CFT,
I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS. WE HOPE THAT THE
PROGRAM EXISTS AS EXACTLY AS THE
OUTSTANDING WITNESS HAD
DISCUSSED. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S JUST A FEW
MORE THINGS WE'RE LOOKING OVER
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD HAS
THE QUALITY ACCESS TO THESE
OUTSTANDING PROGRAMS THAT WE
HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY. I'M JUST
GOING TO REGISTER YOU AS A
TWEENER. YES. OKAY. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU. HELLO, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRYSTAL PADILLA WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF OUR CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD AND OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR FOR ENGAGING WITH US
AS WE WORK THROUGH OUR POSITION
AND CONCERNS, MORE SPECIFICALLY,
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON
THE FORMAT OF THE REQUEST
LETTER, THE RECIPIENT OF THE
REQUEST LETTER, AND ESTABLISHING
A LENGTH ON THE KI¾M AGREEMENT
OUTSIDE OF THE SERVICE AREA.
AGAIN, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND OUR
BOARD AS WE REACH A
COLLABORATIVE AGREEMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, LET US
NOW COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR BOGUE, MEMBER
HOLDING, WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL. I'M VERY EXCITED FOR
IT. I BEEN AN ADVOCATE. I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION, WHICH I IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN KIND OF AT THE EDGE
OF MY MIND FOR MANY YEARS. WHEN
YOU DO THE DUAL ENROLLMENT AND
YOU GRADUATE FROM THE PROGRAM,
ARE YOU TECHNICALLY A, DO YOU
RECEIVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
DO YOU RECEIVE A COLLEGE
DIPLOMA? WHAT? HOW DOES THAT
WORK? WELL, IT DEPENDS. IT
DEPENDS ON HOW MANY CREDITS THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO ACCUMULATE DURING
YOUR YOUR TIME IN HIGH SCHOOL,
AS WAS POINTED OUT, IF YOU TAKE
THE YOU START THE PROGRAM AND
YOUR JUNIOR YEAR OR SENIOR YEAR,
THEN YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET AS MANY. IT'S
15 CREDITS PER SEMESTER, PER
YEAR. AND SO FOR AS AN EXAMPLE,
THERE WERE EIGHT STUDENTS IN THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THIS YEAR WHO WILL GRADUATE WITH
THEIR AA DEGREE IN ADDITION TO
THEIR COLLEGE, THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. SO YOU GET BOTH RIGHT.
AND SO THEY START BASED ON THE
AMOUNT OF CREDITS THAT ARE
APPLICABLE TO THE UNIVERSITY
THAT THEY WOULD BE ATTENDING.
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY START AS
A SECOND YEAR OR FIRST YEAR
JUNIOR. I LOVE THIS PROGRAM. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THIS BILL AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO MOVE IT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. APPRECIATE THAT,
FOR MY PART, I, YOU KNOW,
APPRECIATE THE BILL AS WELL, YOU
KNOW, GRATEFUL FOR YOU ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENT. WHAT THAT
AMENDMENT ALSO DOES IS IT ALIGNS
IT WITH THE BILL THAT I HAVE, SB
1244, WHICH IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR, YOURS PROBABLY HAS SOME
MORE FEATURES. MAY THE BEST BILL
WIN, ANYTHING THAT'S GOT IT FOR
GOOD OF THE CAUSE. I APPRECIATE
THAT, AND I'M GLAD IT'S
SUPPORTED. AND I WILL SAY OF
DUAL ENROLLMENT, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. AND I THINK
MISS LOPEZ TOUCHED ON IT IS WHAT
IT GIVES TO STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE NOT HAVE REALIZED HOW
FAR THEIR PATH MIGHT TAKE THEM,
SO THAT EXPOSURE TO HIGHER ED
THAT YOU CAN GET DURING HIGH
SCHOOL IS SO IMPORTANT TO HELP
WITH ATTAINMENT AND GRADUATION
IN HIGH SCHOOL, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, TO GIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE A CHANCE TO AT LEAST SEE
THEIR POSSIBILITIES. SO I THANK
YOU, MISS LOPEZ, FOR BEING HERE.
YOU'RE A TERRIFIC EXAMPLE OF
WHAT DUAL ENROLLMENT CAN DO WITH
THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YOU KNOW, THIS IS, THIS IS MY
LAST YEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE. SO
12 YEARS OF WRITING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF BILLS, THIS
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST THAT I
WROTE WHEN I BECAME A
LEGISLATOR. AND IT'S ONE OF THE
LAST AND THE WHOLE IDEA WAS TO
ESTABLISH A FOUNDATION WHICH
C-CAP DOES, TO ALLOW FOR THESE
STUDENTS TO REALLY GET THE MOST
OUT OF THEIR EXPERIENCE IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND PREPARE FOR THEIR
FUTURE. AS WE'VE NOTICED, AS
TIME HAS GONE ON, THERE WERE
DACA STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT
INCLUDED. SO WE WROTE A BILL TO
INCLUDE THEM. THERE WERE CAUGHT
STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT INCLUDED.
SO WE WROTE A BILL TO INCLUDE
THEM. SO THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
EVOLUTION OF MEETING THE NEEDS
AND CREATING FLEXIBILITY. AND AS
THE AND I DON'T WANT TO REFER TO
THE OPPOSITION AS OPPOSITION, I
HOPE THAT THEY WOULD CONSIDER
THEMSELVES TWEENERS AS WELL,
BECAUSE I'VE YET TO HAVE
OPPOSITION ON ANY DUAL
ENROLLMENT BILL, BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE'RE LOOKING AT
CREATING NEW HORIZONS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO MAYBE DIDN'T SEE
THEMSELVES AS COLLEGE PREPARED
OR BE IN THE FIRST IN THEIR
FAMILY TO, TO, YOU KNOW, TO GET
OVER THAT HURDLE. AND, AND SO
WHEN YOU'RE ABLE TO WORK IN AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS, I HEARD
IT REFERRED TO EARLIER AND
PREVIOUS, HEARING THAT WE DON'T
GET A LOT OF GOOD THINGS DONE OR
WORDS TO THAT EFFECT. AND HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE, I BEG TO
DIFFER. I THINK THAT WE DO A LOT
OF IMPORTANT THINGS, AND THIS IS
ONE OF THEM. AND I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE, AND IT'S
ALLOWING THE BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD TODAY. BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS A BILL THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AS THE
YEARS AND DECADES UNFOLD AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF A GROWING AND
MORE PARTICIPATORY, DIVERSE
GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO WILL SEE
AND HEAR FROM OTHERS, WHO WILL
COME BACK AND TELL THEM HOW
VALUABLE IT'S BEEN, THAT THEY
CAN REALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHEST GOALS.
AND SO I THINK THIS COMMITTEE,
FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CONSULTANT, WE
HAD A MOTION FROM SENATOR BOGUE,
AND, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN,
AB 1160. NO. EXCUSE ME. FILE
ITEM TWO, AB 359 HOLDEN MOTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN I OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. I CORTESE. CORTESE I.
GLASER. GLASER I. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK HI. WILK
I. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
FOR. IS IT? FIVE HAS FIVE VOTES.
WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN FOR AFTERNOON
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, NEXT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO. WELCOME. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING AB 1160, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU, I
THINK IT'S STILL MORNING, BUT
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
1160. THE BILL YOU SEE TODAY
REFLECTS MONTHS OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH OPPOSITION AND GOOD FAITH,
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS AND
PROVIDE CLARITY ON THE BILL'S
INTENT. THIS BILL AIMS TO
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC HARMS
ASSOCIATED WITH INSTITUTIONAL
DEBT, WHILE PRESERVING A CRUCIAL
TOOLS FOR COLLEGES TO COLLECT
DEBT AND MAINTAIN REVENUE
STREAMS. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT AB 1160 DOES NOT CANCEL
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT, NOR REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO CANCEL SUCH DEBT. IT DOES NOT
ALLOW STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN A
COLLEGE FOR FREE, NOR DOES IT
ABSOLVE STUDENTS FROM THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PAY THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT. 11 AB 1160
WILL GRANT STUDENTS A ONE TIME
GRACE PERIOD WHERE THEY CAN RE
ENROLL IN THEIR COURSEWORK AND
MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS THEIR
DEGREE WHILE THEY WORK TO GET
BACK ON TRACK AND REPAY THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT. THE BENEFIT
FROM THE GRACE PERIOD. STUDENTS
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR THE
TERM THEY'RE ENROLLING IN, AND
MUST ENTER A PAYMENT PLAN FOR
THEIR PAST DEBT IF THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE ENROLLING AFTER THE
GRACE PERIOD. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES SAFEGUARDS ON THE
USE FOR ON THE USE OF FOR PROFIT
THIRD PARTY DEBT COLLECTION,
REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO WAIT 180
DAYS BEFORE SUBJECTING STUDENTS
TO COLLECTIONS, OR REPORTING
NEGATIVE MARKS ON THEIR CREDIT
REPORTS. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
SCHOOLS TO COMMUNICATE TO
STUDENTS THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES OF BEING
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIONS. THESE
PROVISIONS WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE SAME DEBT
COLLECTION PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
AFFORDED TO CALIFORNIANS WITH
MEDICAL AND OTHER DEBTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. ADDITIONALLY, AB
1160 PROVIDES MORE TIME FOR
SCHOOLS TO BUILD OUT DATA
REPORTING SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND CAPACITY
TO ADEQUATELY COLLECT AND REPORT
DATA ON INSTITUTIONAL DEBT. THE
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT CRISIS HAS
GONE UNDER THE RADAR FOR FAR TOO
LONG, ACCORDING TO THE MOST
RECENTLY AVAILABLE DATA, MORE
THAN 750,000 LOW INCOME STUDENTS
OWE MORE THAN $390 MILLION IN
DEBT. THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES WE CAN AND WE MUST DO
MORE TO PROTECT STUDENTS ACROSS
OUR STATE AND AB 1160 WILL DO
JUST THAT. THE BILL TODAY IS A
COMPROMISE, AND I BELIEVE IT
WILL BENEFIT STUDENTS AND
COLLEGES ALIKE. AND I HAVE HERE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I HAVE
CELINE IRIDIAN IRIDIAN, CURRENT
UC DAVIS STUDENT WHO SERVES AS A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
AND ALSO WE HAVE PROFESSOR
CHARLIE EATON, ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT UC
MERCED, AND I WILL PASS IT ON
OVER TO THEM. SO MISS ABERDEEN.
YES, THAT'S CORRECT. PLEASE
PROCEED. WELCOME. YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. AWESOME. HELLO. MY NAME
IS CELINE CARRIDINE. THANK YOU
FOR THE WARM INTRODUCTION. I'M A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS, AND I ALSO
SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION, WHERE WE
REPRESENT THE 230,000 PLUS
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE ARE
A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 1160.
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM FOR STUDENTS ACROSS ALL
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. WHILE THE
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT CRISIS IS NOT
NEW, IT WAS EXACERBATED
EXACERBATED BY THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. OVER THIS SAME TIME,
OUR STATE HAS BEEN FACING AN
ENROLLMENT CRISIS. INSTITUTIONAL
DEBT BARS MANY PEOPLE FROM
RETURNING TO SCHOOL AND
ACHIEVING THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
DREAMS. IT CAN ALSO HAVE SERIOUS
LONG TERM IMPLICATIONS FOR
STUDENTS FUTURE, WHETHER THAT BE
THEIR FUTURE EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
DIPLOMA WITHHOLDING OR HURTING
THEIR CREDIT SCORE, WHICH TAKES
YEARS TO REBUILD. MANY TIMES,
THESE DEBTS COME UP UNEXPECTEDLY
FOR STUDENTS WITHOUT TIME FOR
THEM TO CORRECT THE ISSUE, AS IN
THE CASE OF ANNA, A STUDENT WHO
WAS JUST TWO SEMESTERS AWAY FROM
EARNING HER DEGREE AT CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS. ANNA HAD BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY TOWARDS HER
GOAL FOR MANY YEARS, AND HER
DEDICATION WAS A SOURCE OF PRIDE
AND EXCITEMENT FOR HER FAMILY.
HOWEVER WHEN HER HUSBAND
SUFFERED A STROKE, ANNA MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO DROP HER
COURSES IMMEDIATELY TO BE BY HIS
SIDE. THIS DECISION, ALTHOUGH
NECESSARY, RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT INSTITUTIONAL DEBT
THAT THEN TRIGGERED AN
ENROLLMENT BAN ON HER ACCOUNT,
WHICH PREVENTED WHICH HAS
PREVENTED HER FROM RETURNING TO
COMPLETE HER EDUCATION. ANNA'S
STORY IS A PAINFUL EXAMPLE OF
HOW LIFE'S UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN DERAIL EVEN
THE MOST DETERMINED STUDENTS,
BURDENING THEM WITH DEBT AND
DISRUPTING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY. IN THE CASE OF A UC
STUDENT, ONE OF MY FELLOW UC
DAVIS STUDENTS, AVA, WAS DROPPED
FROM ALL HER COURSES AND HAD TO
REAPPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID AND
SCRAMBLE TO FOR NEW COURSES
AFTER THE QUARTER HAD BEGUN DUE
TO JUST A $3 DEBT FROM A DRINK
SHE FORGOT SHE HAD PURCHASED ON
HER SCHOOL ACCOUNT. THESE
SITUATIONS HIGHLIGHT THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR AB 1160, AND
PASSING AB 1160 WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN SUPPORTING
STUDENTS LIKE ANNA AND AVA,
ENSURING THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TO OVERCOME LIFE'S CHALLENGES
AND ACHIEVE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS WITHOUT BEING DERAILED. IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOW
INCOME STUDENTS, WHO ARE ALSO
MORE LIKELY TO BELONG TO
RACIALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. AT UCS, NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF UNDERGRADUATES ARE THE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILIES TO
ATTEND COLLEGE, AND NEARLY HALF
OF UC STUDENTS ARE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES. IN
ADDITION, HALF OF UC
UNDERGRADUATES RECEIVE THE PELL
GRANT, INDICATING THEIR
FINANCIAL NEED. THE UC PRIDES
ITSELF AS A LEADER IN SOCIAL
MOBILITY, WITH MULTIPLE CAMPUSES
RECEIVING NATIONAL RECOGNITION
FROM PUBLICATIONS SUCH AS US
NEWS AND WORLD REPORT AND THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL. THIS
CRITICAL MOBILITY IS HAMPERED
WHEN INSTITUTIONAL DEBT PREVENTS
A STUDENT FROM COMPLETING THEIR
DEGREE. THERE IS A MAJOR NEED
FOR LEGISLATION LIKE AB 1160 TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
ONLY ABLE TO ENROLL IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS, BUT ALSO FINISH
THEIR DEGREES AS YOU DELIBERATE
THIS BILL, I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER ANNA'S STORY AND AVA'S
TO HELP ADDRESS THE STATE'S
ENROLLMENT CRISIS AND IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. THREE
MINUTES, PROFESSOR EDEN? YEAH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M AN
ECONOMIC SOCIOLOGY ARTIST AND
PROFESSOR AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, MERCED, WHERE I
CO-FOUNDED THE HIGHER EDUCATION
RACE AND THE ECONOMY LAB, OUR
LAB COAUTHORED THE CREDITOR
COLLEGES STUDY OF INSTITUTIONAL
STUDENT DEBT WITH UC IRVINE LAW
PROFESSOR DAHLIA JIMENEZ AND UC
BERKELEY LAW PROFESSOR JONATHAN
GLAZER. INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS WORK
DIFFERENTLY THAN STUDENT LOANS,
AND THEY TEND TO BE MORE HARMFUL
. WE ESTIMATE THAT 300,000,
MOSTLY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS INCUR THESE DEBTS IN AN
AVERAGE YEAR. CURRENT ONLY
AROUND 25% OF THESE DEBTS ARE
EVER REPAID. BECAUSE STUDENTS
LACK THE MEANS, AB 1160 WILL
HELP THOUSANDS OF THESE STUDENTS
TO COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION. AS
YOU JUST HEARD, AND IT WILL ALSO
HELP OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS TO BRING IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE TO SERVE STUDENTS.
HERE'S WHY MOST STUDENTS INCUR
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS WHEN THEY
WITHDRAW FROM SCHOOL IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ACADEMIC TERM
BECAUSE OF A HEALTH OR ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP, SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED
TO RETURN SOME OF THESE
STUDENTS, PELL GRANT AND STUDENT
LOAN AID TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. MOST SCHOOLS THEN
PLACE REGISTRATION HOLDS THAT
BAR FURTHER ENROLLMENT UNTIL
STUDENTS REPAY THEIR FEDERAL AID
TO THE SCHOOL. AB 1160, AS
AMENDED, WOULD GRANT STUDENTS A
ONE TIME GRACE PERIOD TO
REENROLL FOR AN ACADEMIC TERM
AFTER INCURRING AN INSTITUTIONAL
DEBT. THIS WOULD ALLOW TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO ARRANGE A PAYMENT
PLAN FOR WHAT THEY OWE, WHILE
CONTINUING TO PROGRESS TOWARDS
THEIR DEGREE. THIS GRACE PERIOD
WILL ACTUALLY BE REVENUE
POSITIVE FOR SCHOOLS, AND THIS
IS BECAUSE STUDENTS WITH
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS ARE OFTEN
ELIGIBLE FOR PELL GRANT AND CAL
GRANTS TO COVER TUITION DURING
THE GRACE PERIOD, AND THESE
GRANT FUNDED TUITION PAYMENTS
ARE LIKELY TO EXCEED THE
STUDENTS DEBTS. BUT GRANTS CAN'T
BE USED TO MAKE PAYMENTS ON
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS THEMSELVES.
USING THE GRACE PERIOD TO
ARRANGE A PAYMENT PLAN WILL ALSO
BE LIKELY TO INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT A STUDENT WILL
REPAY THE DEBT. SEVERAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, CSU'S AND
UC'S HAVE ALREADY DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS WITH THIS APPROACH, AND
CONTRARY TO SOME
MISUNDERSTANDINGS, AB 1160 WILL
NOT CREATE A LOOPHOLE FOR
STUDENTS TO GET OUT OF PAYING
TUITION. THIS IS BECAUSE AB 1160
PRESERVES SCHOOLS DROP FOR NON
PAYMENT POLICY, AS THESE
POLICIES DROP STUDENTS WHEN THEY
HAVE NOT PAID TUITION FOR THE
CURRENT TERM. IN SUM, AB 1160,
AS AMENDED, TAKES A BALANCED
APPROACH TO PROTECT STUDENTS
WHILE HELPING SCHOOLS TO KEEP
THEM ENROLLED. WHEN HARDSHIPS
CREATE UNEXPECTED DEBTS. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM? WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE, PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE, STATE
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION,
YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING,
SAMANTHA SINGH WITH NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA AND PROUD, SUPPORT
AND CO-SPONSOR ALSO ON BEHALF OF
SOME OTHER CO-SPONSORS. I
COULDN'T MAKE IT TODAY. STUDENT
BAR PROTECTION CENTER, STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS CENTER, THE CSU
STUDENT ASSOCIATION, YOUNG
INVINCIBLES, AND CONSUMER
REPORTS ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MISS CHEN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ANNA MATTHEWS
WITH THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. BELLA KERN, ON BEHALF
OF THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CHAIR NEWMAN.
SENATORS DAVID HAWKINS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INDEPENDENCE
FACULTY UNION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MR. HAWKINS. LET'S NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, I SEE
JESSICA DONG, AND THAT'S IT.
OKAY, OKAY. AND MAGGIE WHITE.
OKAY. IF I'M SORRY. THANK YOU.
MOVE. WELCOME, MISS WHITE. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHO'S GOING FIRST,
BUT YOU CAN FLIP A COIN. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I'M JESSICA
DUONG WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 1160. WE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS, AND WE WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT
THEY HAVE DONE TO CLARIFY
CERTAIN PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
HOWEVER, YOU SEE, STILL OPPOSED
AB 1160 WOULD PROHIBIT UC'S
ABILITY TO USE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS TO COLLECT UNPAID
STUDENT DEBT. OUR CAMPUSES WORK
CLOSELY WITH STUDENTS, OFFERING
PAYMENT PLANS, PROVIDING
COUNSELING VIA MEETINGS,
TELEPHONE CALLS, ONLINE
APPOINTMENTS AND WRITTEN
CORRESPONDENCE. THESE MEASURES
ARE AIMED AT COMMUNICATING
OPTIONS TO SET THE STUDENT ON A
PATH TO GOOD STANDING AND
PREVENT VÌ ADVERSE FINANCIAL
IMPACTS. AB 1160 WOULD ALSO
PREVENT THE UC FROM CONTRACTING
WITH A COLLECTION AGENCY UNTIL
180 DAYS OR SIX MONTHS HAVE
PASSED. OUR CAMPUS ACCOUNTING
OFFICES HAVE SEEN THAT AFTER
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT WINDOW OF
TIME HAS PASSED, IT BECOMES LESS
LIKELY TO FOR THE DEBT TO BE
COLLECTED. ADDITIONALLY UC IS
FACING A LIKELY $125 MILLION CUT
TO OUR BASE BUDGET AS PART OF
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET ACT.
RESTRICTING OUR ABILITY TO
COLLECT DEBT WILL FURTHER STRAIN
UC'S FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
ULTIMATELY, UC BELIEVES THAT
MAINTAINING THE ABILITY TO
EMPLOY STANDARD DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND, BY
EXTENSION, FOR SAFEGUARDING THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF HIGHER OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR ALL STUDENTS WITHIN THE UC
SYSTEM. FOR THESE REASONS, YOU
SEE OPPOSES AB 1160. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MISS WYATT.
GOOD MORNING. I'M MAGGIE WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. I'M HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
1160. I'D LIKE TO FIRST THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
MEETING WITH US MANY TIMES TO
TRY TO BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
OUR TWO SIDES. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE BILL HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED SINCE IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY ON THIS BILL AND
IN THIS BUDGET CLIMATE, WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME AS WE
HAVE ONGOING CONCERNS AT THE
CSU. WE BASICALLY HAVE THREE
WAYS OF COLLECTING ON PAST DUE
INSTITUTIONAL DEBTS. WE CAN PUT
A HOLD ON THE NEXT SEMESTER'S
REGISTRATION, WHICH GETS THE
STUDENT TO COME TALK TO THE
CAMPUS AND FIND A SOLUTION FOR
STRUGGLES THEY MAY BE
EXPERIENCING. WE CAN OFTEN
CONNECT THEM WITH AN EMERGENCY
GRANT FROM THE CAMPUS. WE CAN
ADJUST THEIR FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE IF THEY'VE INCURRED
UNEXPECTED EXPENSES, OR HAD A
JOB LOSS OR HEALTH ISSUE IN THE
FAMILY. WE CAN CONNECT THEM WITH
BASIC NEEDS SUPPORT, RAPID
REHOUSING, CALFRESH AND OR A
PAYMENT PLAN TO KEEP THEM
ENROLLED IN MAKING ACADEMIC
PROGRESS WHILE ADDRESSING THE
DEBT TO THE UNIVERSITY. IN OTHER
CASES, WHEN THE DEBT HAS GONE
UNPAID AND THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
LEFT THE CAMPUS, WE UTILIZE
THIRD PARTY DEBT COLLECTION AND
TAX OFFSET. I DO WANT TO BE
EXTREMELY CLEAR. THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST STEP WE TAKE EVER, AND WE
DON'T TAKE IT LIGHTLY. EVERY
CAMPUS IS REQUIRED TO MAKE A
MINIMUM OF THREE OUTREACH
ATTEMPTS TO GET THE STUDENT TO
COME INTO THE OFFICE. COME TALK
TO US ABOUT WHATEVER YOU MAY BE
EXPERIENCING AFTER THE DEBT HAS
BECOME PAST. DUE MOST OF OUR CSU
CAMPUSES MAKE AN AVERAGE OF FIVE
OUTREACH ATTEMPTS BEFORE
ESCALATING TO DEBT COLLECTION. I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT A MAJOR
PRIORITY OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
TO ADDRESS THE DEBT THAT OCCURS
WHEN A STUDENT LEAVES PARTWAY
THROUGH THE SEMESTER, AND THEN
IS REQUIRED TO PAY BACK THEIR
PRORATED FINANCIAL AID TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE CURRENTLY
CHOOSE TO ASSUME THAT DEBT ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT. WE PAY IT
BACK FOR THEM. SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DEAL DIRECTLY WITH THE
BUREAUCRACY OF THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, BUT WE ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DO SO. WE CONSIDER
THAT A BEST PRACTICE FOR OUR
STUDENTS, BUT IF WE ARE UNABLE
TO COLLECT ON THAT DEBT IN THE
FUTURE, WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD DOING SO IN AN ONGOING
MANNER, AS WE DO FACE A
POTENTIAL $75 MILLION BUDGET CUT
IN THE YEAR AHEAD. WE FEEL IT'S
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE
RETAIN THE TOOLS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IN OUR TOOLBOX TO COLLECT
ON PAYMENTS. I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU,
LET US NOW HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD. MR.
BACK. THANK YOU. SIR, MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS MATT BACK,
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY SCHOOLS, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. CHAIR MEMBERS.
SCOTT. GOVERNOR, UNIVERSITY OF
PHOENIX. HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, AND RESPECTFULLY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR BEING OPEN TO OUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ALEX GRAVES. THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES, REPRESENTING 89
PRIVATE, NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, LET'S COME BACK
TO THE DAIS, COLLEGE QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. SENATOR
GLASER. THANK YOU, I HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT, AND LOOKING AT THIS
BILL INITIALLY, IT HAS ALL MY,
YOU KNOW, SYMPATHY AND I JOIN
AND THE GOALS IN WHICH YOU HAVE
ADVANCED, NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE
THIS DEBT OVER STUDENTS. NO ONE
WANTS TO SEE A DIPLOMA DENIED
FOR A DEBT, BUT I, YOU KNOW, IN
LOOKING AT IT MORE DEEPLY, I'M.
I'M STRUGGLING. AND MAYBE THE
AUTHOR CAN HELP IN TERMS OF THE
DATA ON HOW CAMPUSES ARE REALLY
DOING. YOU KNOW, WE HEAR èC SAY
$90 MILLION A YEAR AT LEAST. I
THINK IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
THEY LOSE 90 MILLION A YEAR IN
DEBT. THAT'S A LOT, CSU MAY HAVE
SIMILAR NUMBERS, BUT IT'S REALLY
ABOUT HOW. AND THE CSU TESTIFIED
TO HOW THEY HAVE, YOU KNOW,
THEIR BEST PRACTICES, BUT I
WELCOME INFORMATION FROM YOU OR
FROM THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO SHARE WITH US THE REAL DATA
THAT EXPLAINS WHY THINGS ARE NOT
NOT BEING HANDLED WELL, THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A STATE MANDATE LIKE
YOUR BILL PROPOSES. OKAY, I'LL
HAND IT OVER TO MY WITNESS.
GREAT. YEAH SO ONE THING I CAN
ADD, AND I MENTIONED THIS IN MY
TESTIMONY, ONLY AROUND 25% OF
THESE DEBTS ARE EVER REPAID. AND
THAT INCLUDES AT OUR, YOU KNOW,
MOST ESTEEMED UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES. I THINK
WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE DATA FOR
UC BERKELEY, IT WAS BELOW 20% OF
THESE DEBTS WERE EVER COLLECTED.
AND THE REASON IS, IS THAT THEY
TYPICALLY ARISE, AS I MENTIONED
DURING HARDSHIPS, EITHER HEALTH
OR ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS THAT LEAD
TO THESE MID-SEMESTER
WITHDRAWALS. AND STUDENTS
TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY EXPENDED
THEM ON EDUCATIONAL
EXPENDITURES. THEY DON'T HAVE
THE IN POCKET FUNDS TO REPAY
THEM, AND IF I CAN PAUSE YOU FOR
A SECOND, THEN I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THEN HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT THE DENIAL OF A DIPLOMA?
BECAUSE IF THEY ARE IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES, THEY THEY CAN'T
CONTINUE. WELL, EVEN
REREGISTERING IN ANOTHER
SEMESTER. NO, AND I KNOW THAT
TOO. I KNOW THAT YOU AND MANY OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERTISE IN OUR FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM. WHAT A STUDENT CAN
DO IS RECEIVE A PELL GRANT OR A
CAL GRANT AS OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS OFTEN DO TOWARDS PAYING
THEIR SUBSEQUENT SEMESTERS OF
TUITION. BUT WHAT THEY CAN'T DO
IS USE THAT FINANCIAL AID
TOWARDS THE DEBT THAT THEY'VE
INCURRED, AND SO WHAT THE BILL
IS PROPOSED TO DO AND AS HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED, THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE AUTHOR AND THE SEGMENTS
THAT'S MADE THE BILL, FRANKLY, A
LOT BETTER, AND SO WHAT IT'S
SAYING IS NOT STUDENTS NEVER
HAVE TO REPAY THESE DEBTS. THEY
STILL DO HAVE TO REPAY THESE
DEBTS. I ACTUALLY WOULD EXPECT
THAT REPAYMENT RATES WILL GET
BETTER. THE REASON BEING, IF YOU
HAVE THE GRACE PERIOD OF ONE
TERM TO KEEP THE STUDENT
ENROLLED, THEY STAY CONNECTED TO
THE INSTITUTION, AND THEY CAN
WORK WITH THE INSTITUTION TO
WORK OUT A PAYMENT PLAN AND PAY
FOR PAYING OFF THE DEBT OVER
TIME, WHILE USING AVAILABLE
FINANCIAL AID TO MAKE THEIR
FUTURE TUITION PAYMENTS AND
SUBSEQUENT TERM'S. RIGHT. AND I
HEARD THAT IN YOUR TESTIMONY
EARLIER, BUT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE DATA ON EXACTLY
HOW, THE CAMPUSES ARE HANDLING
THE DEBTS. I MEAN, YOU'RE SAYING
75. YEAH. AREN'T COLLECTED,
YEAH. SO AND WHAT I MEAN, THERE,
YOU WANT THEM TO KEEP
REREGISTERING AND WHAT I MEAN
WHEN I SAY THAT IT'S NOT THAT
THE SCHOOLS DON'T SEND THEM TO
COLLECTIONS. WHAT I MEAN IS WHEN
THEY SEND THEM TO COLLECTIONS,
THE THIRD PARTY DEBT COLLECTORS
AND THE TAX OFFSET PROGRAM WHEN
EMPLOYED ARE ONLY SUCCESSFUL IN
RECOVERING AROUND 25% OF THE
FUNDS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET
WATER OUT OF A STONE. I GET
THAT, BUT I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE WORST
CASE, RIGHT? YEAH, I'M STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
CAMPUSES ARE PRAGMATICALLY
HANDLING IT FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU HAVE
10,000 STUDENTS WHO HAVE THAT
PROBLEM IN THE COURSE OF A YEAR
AT èC AND MAYBE èC CAN SPEAK
TO THIS, YOU KNOW, HOW HAS THEIR
CARE AND CONCERN FOR THOSE
STUDENTS RESULTED IN WHAT
HAPPENED TO THOSE 10,000? AND
MAYBE èC CAN SPEAK TO THAT
BECAUSE IT'S STILL ABOUT DATA.
WHO'S COLLECTING THE DATA? SO I
HAVE REAL INFORMATION TO MAKE A
POLICY CHOICE ABOUT IT. AND I
WOULD I'D BE INTERESTED IN UC'S
RESPONSE. CAN I JUST SO I DON'T
HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION LATER.
BUT I HEARD FROM MISS WHITE THAT
CSU, I ASSUME YOU SEE, DOES HAVE
A POLICIES AND APPROACHES THAT
WOULD WORK WITH THE STUDENTS. SO
WHAT'S WHAT'S MISSING? AS YOU
ANSWER THIS QUESTION THAT THE
LEGISLATION ASPIRES TO FILL. GO
AHEAD. OH THANK YOU SIR I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION, YES
, WE DO OFFER PAYMENT PLANS FOR
OUR STUDENTS. WE WANT THEM TO
REENROLL. WE WANT THEM TO GO
INTO THAT NEXT SEMESTER AND
CONTINUE THEIR ACADEMIC JOURNEY
WITH US. I THINK THAT THE DEBTS
THAT ARE THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE
BILL, AND I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR THE SPONSORS, ARE THESE
LARGER DEBTS THAT I THINK WOULD
BE VERY INTIMIDATING TO A
STUDENT? IT MAY BE A COUPLE OF
THOUSAND DOLLARS IF THEY'VE LEFT
MORE THAN 60% OF THE WAY THROUGH
THE SEMESTER AND HAVE THAT THAT
DEBT OF THEIR PELL GRANT BEING
REPAID TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
, THAT WE SHOULD BE OFFERING A
PAYMENT PLAN TO THOSE STUDENTS
TO GET THEM RE-ENROLLED FOR THE
NEXT SEMESTER. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR, AND I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MYSELF AND NOT THE COALITION OF
OPPOSITION. THAT'S THE AREA OF
THE BILL I HAVE THE LEAST
CONCERN WITH. I THINK THE
LANGUAGE DOESN'T EXACTLY ALIGN
WITH WHAT WE DO, BUT THIS IS A
BEST PRACTICE AND POLICY FOR US
AT CSU OF BRINGING THAT STUDENT
BACK ON CAMPUS. WE LOST A LOT OF
STUDENTS DURING THE PANDEMIC WHO
LEFT OUR CAMPUSES. I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE SEE SOME OF THE
DATA ABOUT THIS INSTITUTIONAL
DEBT. OF THOSE PELL GRANTS BEING
REPAID BY THE CAMPUS TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF ED, WE WANT TO
BRING THOSE STUDENTS BACK. SO I
THINK THERE MAY BE PARTICULARS
THAT DIFFER. I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH PAYMENT PLANS. EVEN SOMEONE
MIGHT HIT ME FROM THE AUDIENCE
FOR SAYING THIS. I DON'T KNOW,
EVEN THE DIPLOMAS. WE ALREADY
OFFER TRANSCRIPTS TO STUDENTS,
WHETHER THEY HAVE THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT TO US OR NOT.
THAT WAS FROM A BILL SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THAT WE CANNOT
WITHHOLD THEIR TRANSCRIPT, WHICH
IS WHAT REALLY SHOWS THAT
THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR DEGREE,
I THINK, MORE THAN THE DIPLOMA.
SO THAT IS NOT A HUGE PRIORITY
FOR US. OUR OUR OPPOSITION
LARGELY TODAY IS ON THE TAX
OFFSET WHEN ALL OTHER AVENUES
HAVE FAILED, THEY CAN GARNISH
THE TAX RETURN OF A FORMER
STUDENT TO RETURN THE
INSTITUTIONAL DEBT TO THE
UNIVERSITY. WE WE'VE ONLY BEEN
ABLE TO, SURVEY A FEW CAMPUSES
AT THIS TIME, HOPING TO HAVE THE
REST OF THE CAMPUSES WITHIN THE
NEXT WEEK OR SO. BUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT ABOUT A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR PER
CAMPUS AT THE CSU, $250,000 PER
YEAR. THAT'S RECOUPED IN THAT
WAY. AND SO WHEN WE'RE FACING A
POTENTIALLY LARGE BUDGET
DEFICITS AND CUTS TO THE SYSTEM,
WE REALLY CAN'T SAY, WELL, IT'S
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE, IT'S MINOR
AND ABSORB ALL. WE HAVE TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL THAT THOSE
AVENUES AREN'T SHUT DOWN FOR US
WHILE WE ARE VERY OPEN TO
GETTING THOSE STUDENTS BACK ON
CAMPUS AND HAVING THOSE PAYMENT
PLANS IN PLACE, AND I'M SORRY, I
PROBABLY WENT WAY BEYOND WHAT
YOUR QUESTION WAS. IT'S REALLY
SENATOR GLAZER'S QUESTION. èC
RESPONSE, AND AGAIN, I'M NOT
HEARING DATA. I'M HEARING A
TOTAL AMOUNT THAT YOU COLLECT OR
DON'T COLLECT, BUT I'M REALLY
NOT HEARING THAT SOME, YOU KNOW,
THE HEART OF HOW EACH STUDENT IS
HANDLED. AND BECAUSE LOOK IT.
YEAH. LET'S JUST HEAR FROM èC
AND THEN I'LL FOLLOW AT èC. WE
DON'T HAVE A UNIFORM POLICY ON
HOW OUR CAMPUSES COLLECT THIS
DEBT. EACH CAMPUS HAS THEIR OWN
POLICY, BUT MOST OF THEM DO
OFFER PAYMENT PLANS. GENERALLY,
WE PROVIDE FIRST COMMUNICATION
WITH STUDENTS THAT THE DEBT IS
OWED, AND THEY CAN ALSO CONTACT
OUR ACCOUNTING OFFICES TO SEE
WHAT THEY CAN DO, OUR CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL, IT'S WITH THE
COLLECTION TIME FRAME. JUST
BECAUSE IF THE LONGER YOU KIND
OF WAIT TO COLLECT DEBT, THE
HARDER IT IS TO RECRUIT RECOUP
THAT MONEY. AND RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT, WE ALSO ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE TAX OFFSETS
AS WELL. IN THIS BILL. SO WE
FEEL LIKE 1160 WILL MAKE IT EVEN
HARDER FOR US TO COLLECT ANY OF
THE DEBT, THE 90 MILLION THAT
WAS REFERENCED IN OUR LETTER GOT
IT. AND MY FRUSTRATION WITH THE
TESTIMONY IS THAT IT'S STILL NOT
VERY SPECIFIC. SO THE DEBT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR, THE DATA
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IS WHAT, LIKE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS, THE
SHARE OF STUDENTS WHO REPAY HOW
MUCH THEY HAVE LEFT TO PAY?
THERE'S PAYMENT PLANS, HOW MANY
STUDENTS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT?
HOW MANY DON'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT, AND WHAT WHAT THE RECOURSE
OF THAT. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
WITH A DELAY. WHAT DOES THEY
THINK THAT WOULD MEAN I'M TRYING
TO GET. YEAH. RIGHT. AND SORRY.
APOLOGIZE BUT, SENATOR, THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IN
THIS BILL FOR THE DATA THAT YOU
THAT YOU ARE ASKING FOR. NO, I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT. TYPICALLY YOU
WOULD GET THE DATA AND THEN
YOU'D MAKE A POLICY CHOICE. AND
THAT WOULD BE MY LAST FOLLOW UP
QUESTION, IF I CAN, MR. CHAIR,
WHICH IS THAT HAVE YOU WORKED
AND MAYBE THIS IS YOUR SPONSOR
TO AGENDIZE THIS AT A TRUSTEES
MEETING? AT A REGENTS MEETING
THERE. VERY GOOD, THOUGHTFUL
PEOPLE IN LEADERSHIP AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO HAVE THE ISSUE
EXPLORED AND EXAMINED SO THAT IF
THERE'S SOME BAD POLICIES ON THE
CAMPUSES, THAT THEY'LL ADJUST
THEM AND CHANGE THEM TO MAKE
THEM MORE RESPONSIVE. BECAUSE AS
I'VE HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES, I
MEAN, NOBODY WANTS THIS
SITUATION. THIS IS A BAD
SITUATION. AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT DISASTER AND IF YOU
FOLLOWED MY WORK ON THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATES, THE WORST
THING WE EVER HAVE ON THE CAMPUS
IS DEBT AND NO DEGREE. I MEAN,
THERE CAN'T BE ANYTHING WORSE
FOR A STUDENT, AND PEOPLE HAVE
HEARD FROM ME ON THAT FROM FOR A
WHILE. BUT HAVE YOU WORKED WITH
THESE INSTITUTIONS TO INTERNALLY
TO FIGURE THIS STUFF OUT BEFORE
WE DO A ONE SIZE FITS ALL LAW?
SO GO AHEAD. YOU KNOW, I, I
ACTUALLY WE'VE WORKED QUITE A
BIT WITH THE INSTITUTIONS AND I,
YOU KNOW, I'M A FACULTY MEMBER
MYSELF AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, MERCED. I'M THE
CHAIR OF OUR FINANCIAL AID
COMMITTEE FOR OUR ACADEMIC
SENATE. WE'VE WORKED REALLY
CLOSELY ON OUR OWN CAMPUS. OUR
CAMPUS ACTUALLY DOESN'T USE THE
TAX OFFSET PROGRAM. AND THAT'S A
POLICY THAT WE DON'T USE IT
BECAUSE WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT, ABOUT GARNERING TAX
REFUNDS FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO BENEFIT FROM THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
WE SHOULD LEAST BE TARGETING
WITH THE TAX OFFSET PROGRAM, AND
WE USE MORE HANDS ON, MORE, LESS
PUNITIVE, MORE, TO POLICIES TO
BRING STUDENTS BACK BECAUSE
WE'VE LEARNED IT HELPS TO BRING
STUDENTS BACK. WE'VE ALSO HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT, NOT JUST WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE FOLKS, BUT FROM THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING WITH, DAVID
ALCOCER, SEAN BRICK, BUT THE AND
WE'VE GOT LOTS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHO HAVE DONE THE RIGHT
THING HERE. THE PROBLEM IS IT'S
A COLLECTIVE ACTION PROBLEM.
WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE POLICY HERE,
INCLUDING GETTING THE DATA FROM
THE DATA COLLECTION IN THE BILL.
AND SO THAT'S WHY A LEGISLATION,
RATHER THAN BRING BACK MY
QUESTION TRYING TO FIX, HAVE YOU
GONE TO THE BOARD OF REGENTS,
HAD IT AGENDIZED AT A REGENTS
MEETING. HAVEN'T HAD IT
AGENDIZED AT THE REGENTS. THIS
IS AN END RUN AROUND WHAT WE
HAVE GOVERNING BOARDS FOR A
REASON. WHAT ABOUT WITH THE
TRUSTEES? HAS THERE BEEN AN
EFFORT TO AGENDIZE THIS AT THE
TRUSTEES MEETING? WE'VE MET WITH
WE'VE MET WITH INDIVIDUAL
REGENTS, INCLUDING THE STUDENT
REGENT, WHO'S BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND WHO'S BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF US TAKING A
LEGISLATIVE APPROACH, BECAUSE,
AGAIN, IT'S A SYSTEM WIDE
PROBLEM. YEAH I WAS A STUDENT
LEADER BACK THEN, TOO, AND I
ALWAYS LIKED COMING HERE FIRST,
BUT THAT THAT'S THE BLIND SPOT
THAT I SEE IN THIS BILL WITH THE
BEST OF INTENTIONS IS THAT HAVE
YOU REALLY EXHAUSTED THE
INTERNAL PROCESSES OF OUR
SYSTEMS, GIVEN THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXAMINE THEIR
POLICIES AND MAKE APPROPRIATE
CHANGES? I KNOW FROM OUR POINT
OF VIEW IS WE'RE CUTTING THEM.
YOU KNOW, AND THEY'RE RAISING
TUITION. AND THAT'S CREATING
HUGE IMPACTS ON KIDS DROPPING
OUT. SO YOU KNOW, WE SEE THE
UGLY CIRCUMSTANCE OF BUDGET CUTS
AND BUDGET CHALLENGES. AND YET
THIS IS GOING TO PUT YOU KNOW,
EVEN MORE PRESSURE WHEN WE'RE
ABOUT TO POTENTIALLY CUT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS FROM THEIR
BUDGET. SO THAT'S A REAL DILEMMA
FOR ME. BUT MY HEART IS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. I JUST DON'T KNOW IF THE
PROCESS HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED TO
THE POINT AT WHICH WE REALLY
SHOULD ACT TODAY. THAT'S MY
DILEMMA. AND JUST, SO YOU'RE A
SENATOR, SO YOU'RE AWARE WE'VE
BEEN HAVING EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS EVER SINCE LAST
YEAR. THIS IS A TWO YEAR BILL.
AND THIS THIS BILL HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED TO WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US. SO THAT WAY IT
BECOMES A BETTER BILL, AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND MORE
DISCUSSIONS TO EVEN PERFECT IT
EVEN MORE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES? NO. SO I GUESS
THE STRIKING FEATURE HERE IS, IS
TO SENATOR GLASER'S POINT. I
MEAN, THE ADMIRABLE INTENT, BUT
BUT UNIVERSAL OPPOSITION FROM
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT PLAYERS IN
HIGHER EDUCATION, RIGHT. SO CSU,
èC, INDEPENDENT COLLEGES,
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, SO I GUESS
LET ME ASK THE WITNESSES. IS
THERE AN AMENDABLE VERSION OF
THIS SOMEWHERE DOWN THE
LEGISLATIVE ROAD THAT YOU CAN
ENVISION IN? SO WE SEGMENTS HAVE
LET THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE KNOW
THAT WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEM ON A POLICY LIKE A POLICY
WITHIN OUR INSTITUTIONS. WOULD
COMMUNICATIONS AND OUTREACH
PLANS AND PAYMENT PLANS AT OUR
CAMPUSES. AND WE FEEL LIKE THIS
IS THE BEST STRATEGY MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
AREN'T HARMED. ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY THIS, AND TO THE
AUTHOR, IS THAT I MEAN, THIS
CONVERSATION YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY
BEEN HAVING, I ASSUME YOU'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO SENATOR
GLASER'S POINT, WHAT'S PROBABLY
MISSING IS DATA. SO NOTHING
WRONG WITH ACTUALLY FORCING THE
COLLECTION OF THAT DATA. BUT BUT
ON THE OTHER, PARAMETERS HERE,
IT SEEMS CHALLENGING, RIGHT? TO
GET TO A CONSENSUS. SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING, WE HAVE AN OPEN
DOOR POLICY, WE'VE ALREADY
REMOVED SOME OPPOSITION FROM
THIS BILL. WE'VE BEEN PERFECTING
THIS BILL, AND OUR DOOR'S ALWAYS
OPEN. AND, SO IF THERE'S ANY,
LIKE, AMENDMENTS SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED, SO
THAT WAY WE CAN PERFECT THIS
BILL, SO TO THE OPPOSITION,
PLEASE, PLEASE SEEK OUT MY
OFFICE. SO THAT WAY WE CAN HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE I DO
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY. AND SO
IT DOES SEEM I MEAN, THERE'S A
KIND OF AN INHERENT TENSION
HERE. ON THE ONE HAND, 180 DAYS
IS THOUGHT TO BE THE KEY TO
KEEPING STUDENTS IN SCHOOL,
RIGHT? IF THEY GO AWAY FOR TOO
LONG, THEY DON'T COME BACK ON
THE OTHER SIDE. THAT SEEMS TO BE
THE SORT OF HORIZON WHERE DEBTS
DON'T GET REPAID. SO IS THERE
SOMETHING LESS THAN 100 DAYS,
180 DAYS THAT SORT OF MEETS
FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE? GO AHEAD,
MR. WONG. WE REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS TO CHANGE THE 180
DAYS TO 90 DAYS, MOST OF èC IS
ON THE QUARTER SYSTEM, SO THIS
IS MORE REFLECTIVE OF OUR
QUARTER SYSTEM. SO THEN THEN TO
THE AUTHOR, WHY NOT 90 DAYS OR
ONE OF THE WITNESSES? WHY?
WHAT'S WHAT WOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
SORT OF ADVERSE ABOUT TAKING
THAT AMENDMENT? I WILL LET MY
WITNESS ANSWER. YEAH REGARDING
INDUSTRY STANDARDS. SO THE 180
DAYS WAS ACTUALLY SUGGESTED BY
THE DEBT COLLECTORS ASSOCIATION
BY THEIR, THEIR TRADE GROUP,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT OUR STANDARD
IS FOR MEDICAL DEBTS, IT SEEMS
THAT WE SHOULD BE TREATING
STUDENTS DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS, THE SAME AS WE
TREAT FOLKS WITH MEDICAL. BUT
YOU COULD YOU COULD PROVIDE FOR,
HOLDING OFF ON DEBT COLLECTION
UNTIL 100 DAYS, BUT OTHER OTHER
SORT OF CURES MIGHT BE INITIATED
SOONER, RIGHT? I MEAN, THAT
MIGHT BE RIGHT. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, SO I KIND OF GET THE DEBT
COLLECTION PIECE, BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE BUNCH OF, OTHER STEPS THAT
MIGHT BE TAKEN IN THE INTERIM
THAT MIGHT BE POSITIVE AND SORT
OF MORE APPEALING TO THE
SEGMENTS. RIGHT. MISS WHITE?
WELL, I'LL GO DOWN MY LIST AND
TRY TO BE RELEVANT. THE TAX
OFFSET IS ONE OF OUR AVENUES WE
HAVE CURRENTLY THAT WOULD BE
COMPLETELY PROHIBITED. SO NO TAX
OFFSET. THE DEBT COLLECTION
WOULD HAVE A 180 DAY WAITING
PERIOD. WE HEAR THAT IT HAS
WORSE RESULTS AS FAR AS
REPAYMENT. THE LONGER YOU WAIT.
I HEAR FROM THE SPONSOR THAT
THERE'S ONLY 25% REPAYMENT RATE.
CERTAINLY THAT'S LOWER THAN 100,
BUT IT'S HIGHER THAN ZERO. AND
SO WE ARE STILL EAGER TO HAVE
THAT AVENUE OPEN TO US WHEN
POSSIBLE, I THINK THAT THE 90
DAYS LIKE ZONG SAID, ALIGNS MORE
SO WITH THE CURRENT SEMESTER OR
QUARTER THAN A SIX MONTH PERIOD.
SO WE IDEALLY WOULD STILL BE IN
CONTACT WITH THAT STUDENT. THEY
WOULD STILL HAVE THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CAMPUS,
AGAIN, I THINK THERE'S ROOM FOR
NEGOTIATION IF IT'S NOT 90, IS
IT 120? IS IT 110? I THINK THERE
MAY BE SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE
TO MEET. BUT AGAIN, MY PRIMARY
CONCERN AT CSU IS THE TOTAL
PROHIBITION OF DIFFERENT
METHODS, INCLUDING TAX OFFSET,
WHICH IS TOTALLY CLOSES THAT
DOWN FOR US. YOU WANT TO RESPOND
TO THAT. AND ACTUALLY SOME OF
THIS OPPOSITION, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OPPOSITION JUST CAME IN
LAST WEEK, AND KEEP IN MIND,
IT'S A TWO YEAR BILL. SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE LIKE ANY AMENDMENTS,
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY HAVEN'T HAD A CLEAR SET
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY TAKE, SO IF WE COULD
GET THOSE AMENDMENTS. SO THAT
WAY WE CAN WORK THROUGH THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS AGAINST EVER SINCE
LAST YEAR. WE'VE SAID, COME TO
US, LET'S HAVE DISCUSSIONS. AND
I THINK WE'VE MET A COUPLE OF
TIMES AS WELL. SO I'M WILLING TO
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS TO FINE
TUNE THIS BILL, BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN
ORDER TO DO THAT. OKAY. AND SO
TO SENATOR GLASER'S POINT ABOUT
STUDENT SUCCESS, THIS IS
IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY WITH NOT
ONLY DECLINING ENROLLMENT, BUT
AN INCREASING COSTS AND BUDGET
DEFICITS BEING FACED BY THE
SEGMENTS. SO I GUESS, YOU KNOW,
I'LL SAY I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY, BUT BUT I WOULD I WOULD
URGE YOU TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND TO BE CLEAR, I,
YOU KNOW, I'M WILLING TO
WITHHOLD MY VOTE LATER IF THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO THEIR
SATISFACTION. THÀNH SENATOR
GLASER. YEAH. AND YOU MAY HAVE
THE VOTES TODAY AND THAT'S FINE.
I KNOW THE AMENDMENT THAT I
WOULD FIND REASONABLE TO ME,
WHICH IS THAT YOU DIRECT BOTH
SYSTEMS, ALL THREE SYSTEMS, TO
AGENDIZE THIS ISSUE BEFORE THEIR
GOVERNING BOARD AND REPORT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE DATA
ON WITH ANY KIND OF CHANGE OR
BUT CERTAINLY ON THE DATA ON
EXACTLY HOW ALL THE CAMPUSES ARE
HANDLING THE MATTER. SO WE WOULD
AT LEAST THEN IF WE WERE TO HEAR
THIS BILL LATER, WE WOULD HAVE
SOME MORE INFORMATION. WE WOULD
HAVE A CLEARER ABILITY OF THE
CAMPUS LEADERSHIP, NOT JUST THE
STAFF AND THE, YOU KNOW, THE
CHANCELLORS AND THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT, BUT THE GOVERNING
BOARD MEMBERS PROBABLY HAVE NO
IDEA ABOUT YOUR BILL IN FACT,
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE OPPOSITION
POSITION FROM THE CSU, IT SAYS
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR. THAT
MEANS IT PROBABLY HAS NEVER BEEN
HEARD BY THE TRUSTEES, WHICH WE
PUT IN CHARGE OF THE SYSTEM,
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
BLINDSIDED UNLESS THEY ARE YOUR
BILL COULD FORCE THEM TO ENGAGE,
AND THAT WOULD BE AN AMENDMENT.
AGAIN, YOU MAY HAVE THE VOTES
TODAY, BUT THAT WOULD BE AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD MAKE ME
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL
BECAUSE YOUR HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE. WE ALL ARE AGREEING
ABOUT THE GOALS YOU'RE TRYING TO
MEET. I JUST DON'T LIKE THE
CLEAVER HERE. AND WHEN I
STILETTO MIGHT BE THE RIGHT WAY
TO DEAL WITH IT. AND I GUESS,
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT THE
SEGMENTS HAVE ACTUALLY,
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
YOU DID NOT ACCEPT. IS THAT
CORRECT? I'M SORRY. WHAT WAS
THAT AGAIN? THAT THE OPPOSITION
ACTUALLY PROVIDED SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE REJECTED.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED A SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS, LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER, WE HAD THE AMENDMENTS
FROM THE 182 90 DAYS. AND THEN
THERE WAS ALSO ANOTHER REJECTED
AMENDMENT, SO THAT THE
DEFINITION OF INSTITUTIONAL DEBT
WOULD NOT INCLUDE LOANS,
INSTITUTIONAL LOANS, WHICH WAS
ALSO REJECTED. OKAY SO DO I SEE
A WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE? YES
YES, DEFINITELY. OKAY, AND I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION. AND I THINK
OPPOSITION CAN ATTEST TO THAT,
THAT WE HAVE HAD AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS. AND TO
SENATOR GLASER'S VERY SENSIBLE
SUGGESTION, LIKE, WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO GET THAT DATA BEFORE
WE NEXT CONSIDER THIS
LEGISLATION, WHICH I ASSUME BE
ON THE FLOOR LATER THIS SUMMER?
WELL, OTHER OPTION, MR. CHAIR,
IS WE HAVE YOU HAVE THREE MORE
HEARINGS THIS MONTH, THE MONTH
OF JUNE, THAT GIVE THE AUTHOR
THE CHANCE AND TAKE HER UP ON
HER WILLINGNESS TO TRY TO WORK
THESE ISSUES OUT. AND LET'S NOT
MOVE THE BILL OUT YET. GIVE THEM
A COUPLE OF WEEKS TO WORK IT
OUT. AND SO THIS IS REFERRED TO
JUDICIARY THAT HAS AN INTENSELY
BUSY AGENDA, RIGHT. SO I'M SORT
OF I WANT TO BE CONSIDERATE OF
THAT. BUT LET ME GIVE THE AUTHOR
A CHANCE TO RESPOND. SO, WE I,
I'M THE TYPE OF LEGISLATOR WHO
WORKS WITH OPPOSITION. AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL HAS BECOME
A TWO YEAR BILL. SO THAT WAY WE
COULD IRON OUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THE OPPOSITION HAS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE JUST CAME OUT WITH THEIR
OPPOSITION LAST WEEK. SO THIS
WAS SOMETHING NEW TO US. BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
IT, WITH THIS BILL, WITH
OPPOSITION, AND I KNOW WE HAVE
TO STILL GET THROUGH JUDICIARY.
SO IF IT GETS THROUGH TODAY,
EVERYONE HAS MY COMMITMENT THAT
I WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
BILL EVEN AS IT GOES THROUGH THE
PROCESS, WHILE IT GOES THROUGH
JUDICIARY. AND HOPEFULLY ONCE IT
GETS TO THE SENATE FLOOR, I CAN
EARN YOUR SUPPORT FOR MY BILL.
AND FOR THE RECORD, I MEAN, IF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REGISTERED
THEIR OPPOSITION LAST WEEK, I
ASSUME THAT IS NOT THE CASE FOR
CSU. AND YOU SEE, YOU REGISTERED
YOUR OPPOSITION HAS BEEN ON THE
RECORD FOR QUITE SOME TIME. UC'S
OPPOSITION WAS FROM LAST WEEK.
HOWEVER, WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE WITH THE CSU
AND ACU WITH THE SAME CONCERNS,
AND UC AND CSU HAVE BEEN SINCE
LAST YEAR, SIR. OKAY, THAT IS
CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. SO, I AM
WILLING TO, YOU KNOW, TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR THAT DEFERENCE WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WILL
WORK ACTIVELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THÀNH. AND I THINK,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN EQUAL
MEASURE OF CHALLENGE WITH
JUDICIARY IF YOU DON'T, FIND
SOME ACCOMMODATION THERE. SO
WITH THAT, DO I HAVE A MOTION? I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL A MOTION,
SENATOR GLAZER AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. SO THIS BILL
IS ALL ABOUT PROTECTING STUDENTS
AND TO ALLOW THEM TO ACHIEVE
THEIR GOAL OF RECEIVING THEIR,
EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND THEIR
DIPLOMAS. SO I WILL COMMIT
MYSELF TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION TO FINE TUNE THIS
BILL TO MAKE IT BETTER, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SENATOR GLAZER.
MADAM, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE ITEM SEVEN, AB 1160
PACHECO. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE SENATE JUDICIARY. JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN.
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. NO. OKUBO. NO
CORTESE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. NOT VOTING. WILK ALL
RIGHT, THEN. MEASURE CURRENTLY
HAS TWO VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, AND THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES, LET US MOVE ON TO
DOCTOR WEBER, WHO HAS BEEN
WAITING SO PATIENTLY, APPRECIATE
THAT. AND YOU BRING TO US NOT
ONE, BUT TWO BILLS. SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT, AND THE FIRST OF YOUR
BILLS I SHOW AS AB 1841. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. YES THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1841. AB 1841 WOULD
REQUIRE THE CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND REQUEST THE UC TO
REQUIRE THE RESIDENTIAL ADVISOR
ADVISORS TO BE TRAINED AND HAVE
EASY ACCESS TO NALOXONE. WE ARE
ALL AWARE OF THE RISING OPIOID
RELATED DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA,
AND THE BENEFICIAL ROLE NALOXONE
PLAYS IN REDUCING THAT HARM.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS NO
LEGISLATION MANDATING CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES
TRAIN THEIR RESIDENTIAL LIFE
EMPLOYEES ON HOW TO ADMINISTER
NALOXONE, WHILE STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE NALOXONE THROUGH THE
NALOXONE DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM ON
CAMPUS, THIS DOES NOT MEAN THAT
STUDENTS KNOW WHERE THE NEAREST
DOSE OF NARCAN IS LOCATED. IN
THE EVENT OF AN OVERDOSE, EVERY
SECOND MATTERS, AND HAVING
STUDENTS KNOW WHERE THE LIFE
SAVING MEDICATION IS AND THAT
IT'S RIGHT DOWN THE HALL CAN
SAVE LIVES. THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO TURN RA INTO FIRST
RESPONDERS. WE SIMPLY WANT TO
PUT THIS LIFE SAVING MEDICATION
CLOSE TO STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE A DOSE AVAILABLE.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL REQUIRES
Ã CAMPUSES TO SEND OUT EMAILS
TO STUDENTS TO ALERT THEM THAT
THE RA IS HAVE ACCESS TO NARCAN
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE INFORMED
. AB 1841 PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR ON
CAMPUS UNIVERSITY RESIDENTIAL
LIFE STAFF, AS WELL AS OFF
CAMPUS, UNIVERSITY AFFILIATED
GREEK LIFE FOR THE OVERALL
WELLNESS OF THE STUDENT
POPULATION. HERE TO SPEAK WITH
ME IN SUPPORT TODAY IS ESPERANZA
BAUER REPRESENTING CHEN UP, ONE
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU, MR. BAUER. I THINK
WE'VE HAD YOU AS A WITNESS
BEFORE. IS THAT CORRECT? YES
WELCOME BACK. PLEASE PROCEED.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN NEWMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ESPERANZA BAUER, AND I'M
CURRENTLY A SECOND YEAR AT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE, SERVING
AS A DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING AT
GENERATION UP CHEN UP IS PROUD
TO BE AN ENTIRELY STUDENT LED
AND RUN YOUTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSING ON
ADVANCING EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
THROUGH COMMUNITY ORGANIZING AND
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS NATIONALLY. AS A PROUD
WRITER AND PRINCIPAL SPONSOR,
CHEN ADVOCATES FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
1841 TO FOSTER A SAFER CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES THROUGH HARM
REDUCTION AWARENESS AND AID. AB
1841 WORKS TO INCLUDE NALOXONE
TRAINING AND ACCESSIBILITY ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES, SPECIFICALLY
WITHIN STUDENT HOUSING. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS SADLY HAD TO
FACE THE REALITY OF WITNESSING
MY CLASSMATES AND CLOSEST
FRIENDS OVERDOSE AND NOT KNOWING
WHAT TO DO OR HAVING ANYTHING TO
HELP IN THE MOMENT. I WAS VERY
EXCITED WHEN NALOXONE BECAME
AVAILABLE THROUGH MY CAMPUS
BECAUSE OF NALOXONE, I NO LONGER
HAVE TO FEEL HOPELESS, AND I CAN
FIND COMFORT IN KNOWING I'M
ALWAYS CARRYING SOMETHING THAT
CAN SAVE MY FRIENDS. ALTHOUGH
DESPITE ITS IMPORTANCE, I WAS
BEYOND SURPRISED WHEN I LEARNED
THAT CAMPUSES ARE NOT MANDATED
TO OFFER THE NALOXONE TRAINING
TO RESIDENTIAL LIFE STAFF FOR A
TOOL SO POWERFUL IT ONLY HAS AS
MUCH POWER AS ITS ABILITY TO BE
ADMINISTERED CORRECTLY.
NALOXONE, MORE COMMONLY KNOWN AS
NARCAN, IS A LIFE SAVING OPIOID
REVERSAL DRUG THAT HAS SAVED
ALMOST 200,000 LIVES SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE NALOXONE
DISTRIBUTION PROJECT IN 2018.
OVERDOSE IS A PREVENTABLE CAUSE
OF DEATH, WITH THE USAGE OF
NARCAN, AND THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ENSURES THE SAFETY
OF STUDENTS STATEWIDE BY
PROVIDING RESOURCES AND TRAINING
TO ALL STUDENTS OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS, CHEN SEEKS THEIR
SUPPORT IN PROMOTING HARM
REDUCTION ON CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
CAMPUSES. RATHER THAN SHAMING
STUDENTS FOR ADDICTION BY
PROVIDING UNIVERSITY AFFILIATED
STAFF SUCH AS RA AND GREEK LIFE
HOUSE MANAGERS ACCESS AND
TRAINING TO LIFE SAVING
MEDICATION, WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THIS IS
IMPERATIVE TO THE SAFETY OF
STUDENTS, AS PEOPLE HOLDING
THESE LIVE IN POSITIONS ARE
CLOSER TO STUDENTS STUDENTS THAN
CAMPUS HEALTH CENTERS. BY
EXPANDING STUDENTS EDUCATION AND
ACCESS TO UNIVERSITY HARM
REDUCTION RESOURCES, AS WELL AS
OFFERING ACCESSIBLE AID AND
SUPPORT, WE AT CHEN URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 1841 TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO GROW IN A
COMMUNITY THAT VALUES THEIR LIFE
AND TAKES ACTION FOR THEIR
SAFETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE.
STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION.
WELCOME. CAPS. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, DAVID HAWKINS WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INDEPENDENCE FACULTY UNIONS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHAIR MURPHY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAMS
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, ANNA MATTHEWS, WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND WELCOME CHAIR
NEWMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MARIO GUERRERO, ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT IN OPPOSITION,
BUT I DID WANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THAT WE'VE
PROVIDED THE AUTHORS OFFICE, TO,
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESS CONCERNS. WE HAVE NO
ISSUES, OF COURSE, WITH THE
NOTIFICATION, NO ISSUES WITH THE
TRAINING, NONE OF THAT. BUT WE
DO. WE WOULD LIKE TO WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED REMOVING THE
LANGUAGE REQUIRING ACADEMIC
ADVISORS TO HAVE THE OPIOID
OVERDOSE REVERSAL MEDICATION IN
THEIR DORMS. AND I BELIEVE THAT
IS AN AMENDMENT THAT IS COMING.
I JUST WANT TO BE ON THE RECORD
ON THAT. THE SECOND IS TO
INSTEAD OF REQUIRING RESIDENTIAL
ADVISORS TO CARRY THE OPIOID
REVERSAL MEDICATION WHILE ON
DUTY TO HAVE THE MEDICATION
AVAILABLE IN AN ACCESSIBLE
LOCATION IN THE DORMITORIES, WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS MAY ACTUALLY
INCREASE ACCESS BECAUSE OVER THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE, BECAUSE
RESIDENTIAL ADVISORS, THEY'RE
NOT ALWAYS IN THE RESIDENTIAL
HALLS WHEN THEY'RE ON DUTY.
ADDITIONALLY RESIDENTIAL
ADVISORS ARE STUDENTS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT, YOU KNOW, PLACING
AN ADDITIONAL, REQUIREMENT ON
THEM MAY, MAY, MAY NOT BE AN
APPROACH, THAT WE'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH, BUT WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE ACCESS.
AND SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THOSE
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS AND JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. SO JUST TO START
THOSE, LIKE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS MAKE SENSE TO YOU,
DOCTOR WEBER? YES ACTUALLY, THE
FIRST ONE THAT HE MENTIONED, WE
WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE TAKEN IT,
BUT IT WAS MISSED WHEN WE DID
OUR LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS. AND
SO WE'LL DEFINITELY BE TAKING
THAT UP. AND WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE SECOND
ONE. OKAY APPRECIATE THAT. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
MOVE THE BILL? I'VE GOT A MOTION
FOR SENATOR GLAZER. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, APPRECIATE YOU
ALL ALLOWING US TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. REALLY APPRECIATE IT, THE
SPONSOR CHEN UP AND ALSO OUR
WITNESS FOR COMING AND SPEAKING
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THE BILL
AND WOULD APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
GLAZER, MADAM KANSEN, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM 13 AB
1841. WEBER. MOTION IS Dð PASSED
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTESE GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WILK. HI. WILK. AYE THAT MEASURE
HAS FOUR VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR NOW. AND LET US NOW
MOVE ON TO YOUR SECOND, PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, AB 1891. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISS BOHR. WELCOME TO
YOUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 1891, WHICH
WILL GIVE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE OPTION TO UTILIZE
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING IN
THEIR ADMISSION PROCESS FOR
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS. AS THE
LARGEST EDUCATOR OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE, COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN
ADDRESSING HEALTH CARE AND
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. HOWEVER,
DUE TO THE INCREASING DEMAND FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALLIED
HEALTH PROGRAMS, THERE IS
LIMITED CAPACITY TO ADMIT ALL
STUDENTS TO APPLY. SINCE 2007,
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING HAS
PROVIDED COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
NURSING PROGRAMS WITH THE TOOLS
TO ADMIT DIVERSE AND
ACADEMICALLY STRONG APPLICANT
POOLS AMIDST LIMITED CAPACITY.
TODAY, 58 OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING PROGRAMS USE
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING TO GROW
DIVERSITY AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
HOWEVER, CURRENT LAW PERMITS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO USE THESE
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING FOR
NURSING PROGRAMS ONLY, NOT FOR
ALL. ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS.
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS TRAIN
STUDENTS FOR PROFESSIONS THAT
PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE OF SUPPORT,
SERVICE IN CONNECTION TO THE
MAJOR HEALTH CARE SECTORS,
INCLUDING PROGRAMS FOR DENTAL
ASSISTING, PARAMEDICS,
PHLEBOTOMY, AND MORE. AB 1891
WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
UTILIZE THIS MULTI-CRITERIA
SCREENING IN THEIR ADMISSION
PROCESS IN ORDER TO EQUITABLY
ADDRESS CAPACITY LIMITATIONS
WHILE IMPROVING THE SUCCESS OF
ADMITTED STUDENTS. THIS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WILL NOW BE
ABLE TO EITHER USE
MULTI-CRITERIA CRITERIA
SCREENING, A LOTTERY SYSTEM, OR
A COMBINATION OF MULTI-CRITERIA
SCREENING AND THE LOTTERY IN
THEIR ADMISSION PROCESS. THIS
VERSATILITY ALLOWS FOR COLLEGES
TO ADOPT ADMISSION PRACTICES
BENEFICIAL TO THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF THEIR DISTRICT. AS THE NAME
INDICATES, THERE ARE SEVERAL
ASPECTS OF AN APPLICANT'S
BACKGROUND THAT COLLEGES
CONSIDER WHEN UTILIZING THIS
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING. THIS
INCLUDES THE STUDENT'S PAST
ACADEMIC RECORD AND WORK
EXPERIENCE, SUCH AS GRADE POINT,
AVERAGE, AND CREDENTIALS, ALONG
WITH LIFE EXPERIENCES OR SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE AGE OF THE
APPLICANT, INCLUDING DISABILITY,
LOW FAMILY INCOME, FIRST
GENERATION STATUS, REFUGEE OR
VETERAN STATUS, AND OTHER
LANGUAGES SPOKEN, AMONG OTHERS.
BY TAKING THESE CONSIDERATIONS
CRITERIA INTO CONSIDERATION,
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS WOULD
SIMULTANEOUSLY IMPROVE THE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND THE
DIVERSITY. TODAY, I HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES VICE
CHANCELLOR DAVID O'BRYANT, IN
SUPPORT DOCTOR LUCIA AS A
WITNESS. WELCOME, MR. BRIAN.
WELCOME PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN.
GOOD LAST FEW MINUTES OF
MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. LET'S
ENJOY IT TOGETHER. MY NAME IS
DAVID O'BRIEN. I'M THE VICE
CHANCELLOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS DOCTOR
WEBER NOTED, WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF AB 1891. AND, I
WON'T TAKE UP TAKE UP TOO MUCH
TIME REPEATING SOME OF THE
EXCELLENT POINTS THAT THE AUTHOR
MADE. I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING ALLOWS
COLLEGES TO GIVE ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION IN NURSING
PROGRAMS TO APPLICANTS WITH
PRIOR ACADEMIC ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
AND WHO HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCES
SUCH AS BEING FIRST GENERATION
OR LOW INCOME, AND WHO SPEAK
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES, IT'S USED IN
53 OF OUR 77 CURRENT NURSING
PROGRAMS, AND WE VIEW IT AS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO HELP DIVERSIFY
THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE. AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO NOT
ONLY BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
USE MULTI CRITERIA SCREENING IN
OUR NURSING PROGRAMS, BUT ITS
EXPANSION TO ALL OF OUR ALLIED
HEALTH PROGRAMS. REALLY JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON HEALTH EQUITY
ISSUES AND OUR OUTSTANDING
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS IN
THESE FIELDS, AND HAPPY TO TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU AND WELCOME,
DOCTOR LUCIEN, PLEASE, MR. CHAIR
NEWMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 1891, WHICH WOULD
ALIGN ADMISSION PROCESSES OF A
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING
PROCEDURE TO THE ALLIED HEALTH
PROGRAMS. MY NAME IS DORIS
LUCIEN. I AM A REGISTERED NURSE
AND C  ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AND
FACULTY MEMBER OF THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE NURSING PROGRAM AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE. SCC I
AM FAMILIAR WITH THE
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING FOR THE
NURSING PROGRAM. ENROLLMENT IN
2010, SCC CHANGED THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FROM
TRADITIONAL MEASURES OF WEIGHTED
GRADE POINT AND RANDOM SELECTION
TO IMPLEMENT THE MULTI-CRITERIA
ADMISSION PROCESS,
MULTI-CRITERIA VÀ HAS PROVIDED
AN EQUITABLE ADMISSION PROCESS.
IT PROVIDES ACCESS FOR CAPABLE
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE MADE
THE GRADE POINT AVERAGE CRITERIA
TO PICK UP POINTS IN LIFE
EXPERIENCE AREAS, AND THEREFORE
QUALIFY TO ENTER THE APPLICATION
POOL. MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING
HAS MADE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
ACHIEVING A MORE DIVERSE
REPERTOIRE OF APPLICANT POOL,
WHICH PROVIDES A PIPELINE HÌNH
FOR INCREASED DIVERSITY IN THE
CLASSROOM AND WORKFORCE
INTEGRATION OF THE DIVERSE
STUDENT SHARING PERSPECTIVE
BUILDS THEIR CONFIDENCE, EMPATHY
WITH INCREASED BELONGING AND
RETENTION IN THE NURSING
WORKFORCE. THESE STUDENTS ARE
BETTER EQUIPPED TO CARE FOR
DIVERSE PATIENTS THAT REFLECT
THE CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
US POPULATION. IN OUR LAST THREE
YEARS, OUR OUR LICENSURE PASS
RATE HAS AVERAGED 95.7 AND
EMPLOYMENT RATE HAS BEEN ABOUT
100% IN THAT FIRST YEAR. USE OF
THE MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING
TOOL HAS IMPROVED THE ADMISSION
PROCESS FOR OUR STUDENTS. IT
WILL PROVIDE THE SAME BENEFITS
FOR ALL ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS
AT SCC. THAT INCLUDES OUR
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSING
PROGRAM, OCCUPATIONAL AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY PROGRAM, OUR
DENTAL ASSISTANTS AND OUR DENTAL
HYGIENE PROGRAMS. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND YOUR URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT 1891. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE LIKE TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE? OH I'M SORRY.
PUBLIC SUPPORT. LET'S DO IT.
DOES ANYBODY HERE LIKE. SO YOU
COULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING.
YOU'RE ALSO POLITE. PLEASE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
. PLEASE PROCEED. HI. I'M KEISHA
HUNT HERE WITH NOSSAMAN. HERE ON
BEHALF OF CITRUS COLLEGE AND
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE. AND
WE DO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. ANNA MATTHEWS
WITH THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
BELLA KERN, ON BEHALF OF
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE AND EL
CAMINO COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, STELLA JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
CERRITOS COLLEGE, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NOW, IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? STILL SEEING NONE.
VERY GOOD. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. SENATOR GLAZIER,
I'LL ASK THE NAIVE QUESTION. THE
INNOCENT CHILD QUESTION. WHY DO
YOU NEED A STATE LAW TO DO THIS?
AREN'T THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ABLE TO DO THIS NOW? SO AND I'LL
LET THEM SPEAK ON THAT. BUT THEY
CAN ONLY DO THIS AS OF RIGHT NOW
WITH THEIR NURSING PROGRAM. AND
SO THIS WOULD ALLOW THEM IN EACH
COLLEGE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO USE IT, IF THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE WITH THEIR LOTTERY
PROCESS OR DO A COMBINATION OF
THE MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING OR
THE LOTTERY. BUT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
BUT TO BE CLEAR, TO EXTEND IT TO
ALLIED HEALTH AS WELL AS
NURSING. OKAY. RIGHT BUT MY
QUESTION IS WHAT IN STATE LAW
PROHIBITS THEM FROM DOING THAT?
NOW, DID THEY NEED THAT
AUTHORIZATION FOR NURSING, AND
WHY CAN'T THEY JUST DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES? IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION, SENATOR, THERE WAS
LEGISLATION IN, I BELIEVE, 2007.
I WASN'T AROUND FOR IT, BUT,
YES, IT WAS ORIGINALLY
AUTHORIZED THROUGH STATUTE. SO
PRESUMABLY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE CONDUCTED A STUDY
INITIALLY TO EXAMINE THE OPTIONS
FOR, YOU KNOW, AN EXPANDED
ADMISSION AND SCREENING PROCESS
AT THE TIME THAT LED TO THAT
STATUTE. SO PRESUMABLY, AT SOME
POINT DURING THE CONDUCT OF THAT
STUDY, IT WAS DETERMINED THAT
THERE WAS A STATUTORY CHANGE
NEEDED, IF I HAD TO GUESS AND
I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY, I WOULD MY
EDUCATED GUESS WOULD BE THAT IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY, WE'RE OPEN ACCESS
INSTITUTIONS. RIGHT? SO, WE
DON'T HAVE A COMPETITIVE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS LIKE UC OR
CSU EXCEPT FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IMPACTED, WHICH ARE
NURSING AND ALLIED HEALTH
PROGRAMS CONSISTENTLY ARE AMONG
THE MOST IMPACTED. I SEE,
BECAUSE CERTAINLY AND THIS
DOESN'T RESOLVE IT IN THIS BILL,
BUT GIVING THEM AUTHORIZATION TO
DETERMINE THEIR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS BROADLY WOULD SEEM
TO BE LIKE AN APPROPRIATE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTIVE WHERE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO KEEP COMING TO
US FOR THESE THINGS, WHICH JUST
CAN BE DECIDED BY THE GOVERNING
BOARDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OR AT
THE STATE LEVEL, THE SECOND
QUESTION IS IN MY DAY, WE WOULD
I WE WOULD REFER TO THIS AS
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, WHICH I
SUPPORT. ISN'T THIS THE SAME AS
JUST AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, JUST
UNDER A DIFFERENT NAME? WELL, I
THINK AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, LOOKED
AT IT WAS A RACE BASED SYSTEM,
THIS IS NOT THIS IS TAKING INTO
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS,
INCLUDING LIFE EXPERIENCES. SO
IF YOU'RE GOING INTO THE HEALTH
SECTOR AND YOU'VE ALREADY HAVE
SOME KIND OF HEALTH BACKGROUND,
THAT WOULD PROBABLY MEAN THAT
YOU'D BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND FINISH THE
PROGRAM THAN SOMEONE WHO HADN'T,
IT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT OF, YOU
KNOW, DISABILITY OR LANGUAGES.
IF YOU ARE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN A PARTICULAR AREA THAT, YOU
KNOW, SERVICES A LARGE
PROPORTION OF PEOPLE FROM
ETHIOPIA, AND YOU HAPPEN TO
SPEAK AMHARIC, THEN THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR THEM TO TAKE INTO
THOSE CONSIDERATIONS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WOULD NOT
ONLY BE SUCCESSFUL AT FINISHING
THE PROGRAM, BUT WOULD ALSO STAY
IN THE COMMUNITY, BECAUSE THIS
IS THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH
THEY'RE FROM, AND THEY SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE AND THE CULTURE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. IT'S A
LITTLE BROADER THAN THE EARLIER
DEFINITION, AND SOMETHING THAT I
SUPPORT AND FINALLY, MY THOUGHT
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE REAL
SOLUTION HERE IS TO OPEN UP MORE
SLOTS. IF PEOPLE WANT TO GET
INTO THESE ALLIED HEALTH, GOD
BLESS THEM. WE NEED THEM AND WE
SHOULD BE FUNDING THEM. AND THE
SYSTEM SHOULD BE HIRING MORE
FACULTY IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES,
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
THING. SO I'M SORRY TO SEE THAT
WE HAVE TO HAVE A BILL TO DEAL
WITH LIMITATIONS THAT SHOULDN'T
REALLY BE THERE. AND I KNOW
THAT'S I WOULD SAY ABOVE MY PAY
GRADE AND PERHAPS YOURS, BUT
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT FROM
A STATE POINT OF VIEW, WE SHOULD
BE RESOLVING IN OUR BUDGET. I
HARDLY THINK THAT'S ABOVE YOUR
PAY GRADE, BUT IT IS MINE. WELL,
IT IS A VERY I THINK, IMPORTANT
AREA. AND RIGHT NOW I THINK TO
YOUR POINT, I MEAN, WE'RE FACED
WITH SEVERE BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS. THERE'S ALSO
SPATIAL CONSTRAINTS. AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD SOLUTION TO
AT LEAST ON THE ON AN INTERIM
BASIS TO, TO THIS CHALLENGE. BUT
TO, TO SENATOR GLASER'S POINT
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THIS SORT OF
HAVING THE LOOK AND FEEL OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, I ASSUME
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY ISSUES
AROUND THE NURSES APPLYING
MULTI-CRITERIA SCREENING TO THE
NURSES PROGRAM TO DATE, IS THAT
CORRECT? CORRECT. OKAY. GOOD TO
HEAR. I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND DO
WE HAVE A MOTION, SENATOR GLAZER
MOVES THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE, JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
OUR SPONSORS AND THOSE WHO HAVE
COME IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL. VERY GOOD, GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GLAZER,
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CALL. ITEM 14 AB 1891
WEBER. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH OKOBOJI. CORTESE.
GLASER. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK OH. VERY
GOOD. THAT. NOW, THAT MEASURE
NOW HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE, WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE SECOND LAST
OF OUR BILLS TODAY, AND THAT
BILL IS OR IS IT, ITEM 16. I'M
SORRY. AB 1947 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS, YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING
EXTREMELY PATIENTLY. SO WELCOME.
AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING LYNN FOR HER WORK AND
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS ON THIS
BILL. AB 1947 WOULD EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF STAFF TRAINING DAYS
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND ALLOCATE ONE OF
THOSE DAYS FOR DLL OR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS TRAINING IN
2020, THE GOVERNOR RELEASED THE
MASTER PLAN, INTENDED TO
TRANSFORM THE STATE'S APPROACH
TO EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
THE MASTER PLAN PROVIDES A
ROADMAP TO ADDRESS RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES, AND CALLS
FOR LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE
DEVELOPMENTAL ASSESSMENTS, BOTH
IN ENGLISH AND IN CHILDREN'S
HOME LANGUAGES, AMONG OTHER
THINGS. IN 2021, CALIFORNIA
SIGNED THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO
LAW AB 1363, WHICH TOOK THE
FIRST STEP OF IMPLEMENTING THE
MASTER PLAN BY REQUIRING THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO DEVELOP A
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY
DLS AS AB 1947 BUILDS ON THE
PROGRESS MADE IN AB 1363, IN
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN TO SUPPORT OUR DLS
BY HELPING OUR EDUCATORS CATER
TO THE LEARNING NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN. TODAY, I HAVE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY, PATTY
HERRERA, EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF SCHOOL SERVICES OF
CALIFORNIA, AND CHRISTINA
SALAZAR, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER, MISS
SALAZAR, THANK YOU. YOU LOOK
READY TO START NØ. OH, SHE'S
CONCEDING. SHE'S CONCEDING. MR.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS MENTIONED,
I'M PATTY HERRERA HERE ON BEHALF
OF EARLY EDGE, CALIFORNIA, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 1947.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK AND RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IN OUR EARLY LEARNING
SYSTEM AND HER LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE. SECOND, WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
LYNN FOR HER COMPREHENSIVE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT REALLY
ARTICULATES THE WHY BEHIND AB
1947 AND WHY WE'RE PURSUING THIS
BILL, WHICH IS THAT CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS, WHO ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THE RICH AND PROMISING ASSET OF
BECOMING BILINGUAL AND
BILITERATE THAT RESEARCH
CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT BI OR
MULTILINGUALISM REAPS LIFETIME
BENEFITS FOR CHILDREN, AND
LARGER SOCIO ECONOMIC BENEFITS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
THAT STAFF WHO TEACH AND SUPPORT
OUR YOUNG DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
NEED ACCESS TO TRAINING ABOUT
HOW TO BEST TO SUPPORT THEIR
CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS, AS WELL AS
HOW TO EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE THEIR
FAMILIES AND PARENTS IN HELPING
TO DEVELOP THEIR NEEDS. EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT EARLY LEARNING
EDUCATORS WHO UNDERGO DL
SPECIFIC PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COMPLETED THEIR
PROGRAMS BETTER EQUIPPED, MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE, AND MORE
CONFIDENT ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT CHILDREN IN THEIR
PROGRAMS. WE SIMPLY CANNOT
IGNORE THE NEED IN OUR STATE TO
ENSURE THAT DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNER CHILDREN ARE GIVEN THE
PROPER SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
THRIVE. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MISS SALAZAR.
WELCOME. YES. THANK YOU.
CHRISTINA SALAZAR. WITH
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER, I WOULD
SECOND EVERYTHING. OUR PARTNERS
WITH EARLY EDGE MENTIONED AND
THE AUTHOR AS WELL. AND JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, YOU
KNOW, THIS BILL IS IN LINE WITH
THE MASTER PLAN. AND THEY FOUND
THAT THEY, CARE CAREGIVERS OFTEN
LACK THE SUPPORT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE CHILDREN
WITH HIGH QUALITY AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT EXPERIENCES IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND THEIR HOME LANGUAGE.
AND SO THIS IS WHERE THE BILL
COMES IN AND WHY IT'S HIGHLY
NEEDED. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES FROM THE
PREVIOUS POLICY COMMITTEE, WHO
WAS A PRESCHOOL TEACHER, SAID,
YOU KNOW, EVEN IF YOU YOURSELF
HAVE A DIVERSE BACKGROUND,
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS THAT YOU HAVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL SO DIFFERENT, AND SO
CALIFORNIANS, TOGETHER, WE SEEK
TO OVERCOME AND TRANSFORM THE
HARMS OF SYSTEMIC RACIAL
LANGUAGE AND CULTURALLY
INEQUALITIES IN EDUCATION TO
CLOSE OPPORTUNITY GAPS FROM
EARLY CHILDHOOD THROUGH
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION. AND
THIS BILL IS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BECAUSE IT EMPOWERS
EDUCATORS BY GIVING THEM THE
NECESSARY SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
TO EFFECTIVELY SUPPORT
EDUCATIONAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
NEEDS OF CHILDREN LEARNING MORE
THAN ONE LANGUAGE. SO THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT, I SEE SOME.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
NATALIA KING WITH CATALYST
CALIFORNIA. HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARY CREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ESTARÁ MATCHES WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CARLOS ROJAS, REPRESENTING
THE KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND LACOE, LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU,
MISS GIBBS. GOOD TO SEE YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, ON IOAKIMIDIS WITH
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
NOW, LET US MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO THE
DAIS, COLLEAGUES. SENATOR GLAZER
, I KNOW THIS IS IN THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE, BUT I DO. I DID NOT
UNDERSTAND WHO PAYS FOR THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
THING. VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. HOW IS IT
PAID FOR? DO YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD, THANK YOU, SENATOR.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. SO
UNDER CURRENT LAW, AND WHAT OUR
BILL WOULD EXPAND IS THE NUMBER
OF ALLOWABLE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAYS THAT ARE
PROVIDED IN A CONTRACTOR'S
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO A STATE PRESCHOOL
CONTRACTOR ENTERS INTO THE, AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'LL RECEIVE
UNDER THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. WITHIN THAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT, A CONTRACTOR MAY OFFER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT DAYS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO, OR ELECT TO USE
THOSE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
DAYS, THEIR CONTRACT WILL PAY
FOR IT. SO IT DOESN'T COST THE
STATE ANY ADDITIONAL DOLLARS,
MEANING IT'S BUDGET NEUTRAL. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULDN'T
HAVE TO PUT OUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES BEYOND WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
APPROPRIATED FOR THE STATE'S
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM, BECAUSE IT'S
COVERED IN THE CONTRACT. RIGHT.
DOES THAT MEAN, THEN, THAT WE
WOULD COVER FEWER CHILDREN THEN,
BECAUSE IF IT'S A FIXED AMOUNT
BY THE STATE? YEAH, IT DEPENDS
ACTUALLY. SO CURRENT LAW AND OUR
BILL WOULD OFFER SOME
FLEXIBILITY AS TO HOW
CONTRACTORS WANT TO PROVIDE THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING. THEY CAN PROVIDE IT
OUTSIDE OF BUSINESS HOURS, IN
WHICH CASE IT WOULDN'T REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN SERVED IN
A CONTRACTOR'S PROGRAM. HOWEVER
OUR BILL DOES CHANGE THIS
PARTICULAR AREA OF LAW WHERE WE
AUTHORIZE THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM TO BE
OFFERED DURING BUSINESS HOURS,
FRANKLY, TO MEET THE PERSONAL
NEEDS OF THE STAFF WHO
THEMSELVES COULD FACE, PERSONAL
HARDSHIP IF, IF THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO ATTEND A TRAINING, IN THE
EVENING OR ON THE WEEKENDS
BECAUSE THEY THEMSELVES OFTEN
HAVE CHILDREN WHO NEED CARE. AND
SO IF A CONTRACTOR OFFERS THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING DURING BUSINESS HOURS,
AGAIN THROUGH THE STATE
PRESCHOOL CONTRACT, IT WOULD
COVER THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. AND OF COURSE, THAT
PARTICULAR CENTER WOULD BE
CLOSED FOR THE DAY. AND SO
FAMILIES WHO UTILIZE THE
SERVICES OF THAT CONTRACTOR
WOULD NEED TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
CARE FOR THAT. THAT PERIOD OF
TIME OR THAT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAY. SO YOU THINK
THE COST OF THIS IS ACTUALLY
BORNE BY THE, THE CHILD CARE
RECIPIENT BECAUSE THE CENTER
WOULD CLOSE BECAUSE OF A
TRAINING DAY. IT WOULDN'T BE
BORNE BY THE STATE IN TERMS OF
HIGHER COSTS FOR THOSE CONTRACTS
. THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IT. I'M JUST TRYING TO
BE GROUNDED. I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. IT'S A GOOD BILL, BUT I
JUST WANT TO BE GROUNDED ON ON
WHERE SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY. IT'S
A GOOD THING. AND WHETHER THAT'S
THAT'S ALL I'M TRYING TO BE REAL
ABOUT. YEAH, SURE. THE COST HAS
TO BE ABSORBED. AND YOU SAID IT
MIGHT IT BE DISCRETIONARY. YEAH.
UNDER UNDER EXISTING LAW,
CONTRACTORS CAN'T PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT DURING
THE BUSINESS DAY. THAT'S AN
EXISTING LAW OR OUTSIDE OF
BUSINESS HOURS. IF THEY OFFER IT
DURING THE BUSINESS DAY, THEY DO
NOT GET TO THEY DON'T DRAW DOWN
THEIR STATE REIMBURSEMENT S, FOR
THE NUMBER OF STUDENT CHILDREN
THAT THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE
SERVING DURING THE DAY. OUR BILL
CHANGES THAT AND AUTHORIZES THEM
TO EARN STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES, FOR WHEN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS OFFERED DURING
BUSINESS HOURS. BECAUSE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM CONTRACTORS THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO ACTUALLY UTILIZING
THIS AUTHORITY AND LAW. I WANT
TO BE CLEAR, THERE'S NO MANDATE
IN THIS BILL TO OFFER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT UNDER
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF A
CONTRACT THAT'S EFFECTIVE, A
CONTRACTOR MAY OR MAY NOT DO SO.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT, VERY FEW
CONTRACTORS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT EXISTING AUTHORITY BECAUSE
THAT IT IS DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO, UTILIZE THEIR CONTRACT
DOLLARS TO PAY FOR TO PAY FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
BUT TO SENATOR GLASER'S POINT,
THAT MEANS THAT YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SOME DAY PROBABLY THAT
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
CARE, RIGHT? THAT'S THE NET
IMPACT. BUT YEAH, I MEAN, WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IF A
CONTRACTOR ELECTS TO OFFER THE
PROFESSIONAL THE TRAINING DURING
BUSINESS HOURS, THAT FAMILIES
WILL NEED TO FIND ALTERNATIVE
CARE FOR THAT DAY. I MYSELF, AS
A PARENT, WHEN MY KIDS WERE
REALLY YOUNG, I OFTEN HAD DAYS
WHERE MY CENTER WAS CLOSED AND I
HAVE TO FIND ALTERNATIVE CARE.
WE'VE WEIGHED THE POLICY TRADE
OFF AS SPONSORS. WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS EXPLICITLY AND A COUPLE OF
THINGS. WE INFORMED OUR DECISION
TO PURSUE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THAT'S BEING PURSUED IN THIS
BILL. ONE IS THAT WE HEARD FROM
THE STAFF THEMSELVES, WHO ARE
AMONG THE LOWEST PAID WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THAT
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT AND HARD
FOR THEM TO BE MANDATED TO
ATTEND TRAININGS OUTSIDE OF
THOSE HOURS. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, WE'RE WE HEAR FROM
FAMILIES AFTER THEIR STAFF HAS
GONE THROUGH THE TRAINING THAT
THEY GET BETTER SUPPORT. SO WE
IT'S A IT CERTAINLY IS AN
INCONVENIENCE, BUT IT'S A SHORT
TERM INCONVENIENCE THAT ON THE
OTHER END OF IT REAPS BIG
BENEFITS FOR STAFF AND FAMILIES.
WOULD THERE BE A LIMITATION ON
THE NUMBER OF DAYS THAT A
FACILITY COULD CLOSE TO PROVIDE
THAT TRAINING? THE EXISTING LAW
IS TWO DAYS, AND WE ARE WE ARE
EXPANDING THAT TO SIX DAYS, UP
TO SIX DAYS OF TRAINING, AND
THAT IS INFORMED PER YEAR, PER
YEAR, PER YEAR, PER CONTRACT
TERM. YES OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES. I
APPRECIATE THE NEED, GLAD TO
SUPPORTED LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
GOT A MOTION FOR SENATOR GLAZER.
GOT GOT IN THE HABIT HERE, SO
I'VE GOT A MOTION. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE. ITEM 16 AB 1947 THREE OF
US. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSED THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, A NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WILK, THAT MEASURE HAS THREE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
NOW WE HAVE ONE MORE MEASURE.
AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS WHO WAS ABSENT. THAT'S
GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
WILK. SENATOR WILK, IF YOU'RE
WATCHING SOMEWHERE, WE'RE
LOOKING FOR YOUR RETURN HERE, IN
THE INTERIM, LET'S DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GLAZER?
MAKES THE MOTION. THANK YOU. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK CONSENT CALENDAR HAS THREE
VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN,
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR SENATOR
WILK TO RETURN.
SO. SO WHILE WE'RE WAITING,
LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL ON,
MEASURE EIGHT AB 1955 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM ONE AB 1955, WARD.
MOTION TO Dð. PASS TO THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. OKOBOJI NØ
OKOBOJI. NO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR SENATOR
SMOKE.THE, THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES FOR TWO
AGAINST, THANK YOU, AND LET'S I
GUESS WE'LL RECESS UNTIL,
SENATOR WILK AND OTHERS COME
BACK.
DURING IT, IS QUITE ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR WILK. YOU'RE DOING A
GOOD DEED PRESENTING THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS, YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
AB 2053, AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
PROCESS OF ELIMINATION. SAYS
THAT'S PROBABLY YOUR WITNESS,
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY,
SENATOR GLASER, YOU MAY WANT TO
SIT DOWN, BECAUSE THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT BILL TODAY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S LAST. ALL RIGHT,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2053 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH ACT
REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADMINISTER SEXUAL HEALTH,
EDUCATION AND HUMAN, JUST GO
WITH HIV, PREVENTION EDUCATION
TO STUDENTS AT LEAST ONCE IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND ONCE IN HIGH
SCHOOL. UNDER THE ACT,
INSTRUCTION INCLUDES INFORMATION
ABOUT ADOLESCENTS RELATIONSHIP,
RELATIONSHIP ABUSE AND INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE. HOWEVER THERE
IS NO REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON SPECIFIC
RESOURCES AND HOTLINES AVAILABLE
TO THE STUDENTS. AB 2053 WOULD
ADDRESS THIS BY REQUIRING
INFORMATION TO BE INCLUDED THAT
DIRECT STUDENTS TO AVAILABLE
RESOURCES, SUCH AS INCLUDING
NATIONAL LOCAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINES, COMMON SENSE MEASURE,
YADDA YADDA YADDA. AB 2053 2053
HAS RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM A
VARIETY OF GREAT ORGANIZATIONS
AND IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY IS COURTNEY
THOMAS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES. YOU GUYS GOT TO
WORK ON THAT NAME WITH THAT.
TURN IT OVER TO YOU, MISS
THOMAS. WELCOME AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. PLEASE
PROCEED, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
NEWMAN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE, AS
WELL AS STAFF, AS MENTIONED, MY
NAME IS COURTNEY THOMAS, AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES, OR KBA. AND
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2053.
WE ARE A STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER COMMUNITY AGENCY
SERVING OVER 1 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN. AND OUR PROVIDERS ALSO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE, IPV, AND THEIR
FAMILIES AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
IN THE LAST HOUSE, INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE, OR IPV AND
TEEN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, TÊ DV IS
A HUGE ISSUE FACING MANY
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS INCREASING
IN FREQUENCY ALONGSIDE THE DATA,
WHICH CURRENTLY INCLUDES THAT
19% OF TEENS EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
OR PHYSICAL DATING VIOLENCE,
ABOUT HALF FACED STALKING OR
HARASSMENT, AND AS MANY AS 65%
REPORT BEING PSYCHOLOGICALLY
ABUSED. ADDITIONALLY, DATA FROM
THE CDC'S NATIONAL INTIMATE
PARTNER AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
SURVEY INDICATES THAT ABOUT 16
MILLION WOMEN AND 11 MILLION MEN
WHO REPORTED EXPERIENCING
CONTACT VÌ, SEXUAL VIOLENCE,
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE, OR STALKING
BY AN INTIMATE PARTNER IN THEIR
LIFETIME SO THAT THEY WERE FIRST
EXPERIENCING FORMS OF VIOLENCE
BEFORE THE AGE OF 18. ALSO,
ABOUT 1 IN 9 FEMALES AND 1 IN 36
MALE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS REPORT
HAVING EXPERIENCED SEXUAL DATING
VIOLENCE IN THE LAST YEAR, NOT
ONLY IS THIS DATA STAGGERING,
IT'S CONCERNING AND IT'S
HEARTBREAKING. FURTHERMORE,
TEENS OFTEN THINK SOME BEHAVIORS
LIKE TEASING AND NAME CALLING
ARE A NORMAL PART OF A
RELATIONSHIP. HOWEVER, THESE
BEHAVIORS CAN BECOME ABUSIVE AND
DEVELOP INTO SERIOUS FORMS OF
VIOLENCE. MANY TEENS DO NOT
REPORT UNHEALTHY BEHAVIORS
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID TO TELL
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. ONE KEY TOOL
AND OPPORTUNITY THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO TACKLE IPV AND DV IS
EDUCATION ABOUT DEVELOPING
HEALTHY, RESPECTFUL, AND
NONVIOLENT RELATIONSHIPS,
INCLUDING RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
YOUTH SHOULD THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP. IPV STARTS EARLY
AND CONTINUES THROUGHOUT
PEOPLE'S LIVES. THEREFORE, THE
CURRICULUM AND INFORMATION
PROVIDED TO TEENS AND YOUNG
ADULTS DURING THEIR TIME IN
SCHOOL IS CRITICAL. FOR THESE
REASONS, KBA HOPES THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY WILL
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU, DOES ANYBODY HERE WHO
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE, SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE? SCIENTIFIC AND
MEASURE, SEEING NONE. LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS, I'VE GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GLAZER
THAT'S ENCOURAGING, COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
NO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ABSOLUTELY. FIRST OF ALL, I WANT
TO THANK MISS THOMAS FOR COMING.
I APOLOGIZE FOR KEEPING YOU
WAITING. AND SHE DID A GREAT JOB
PRESENTING YOU DATA. SO YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL. SO THAT'S GREAT. SO MY
WIFE USED TO WORK, SHE DIDN'T
WORK. SHE VOLUNTEERED FOR A
NONPROFIT THAT WENT INTO SCHOOLS
AND TAUGHT HIV EDUCATION. IT'S A
THREE DAY PROGRAM. I THINK THIS
IS TOTALLY APPROPRIATE TO BE IN
THERE WITH EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THEY'RE LEARNING. AND I KNOW
THAT PROGRAM, WAS EFFECTIVE, AND
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT PLACE TO
PUT IT. SO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD TO THE
ASSEMBLYMAN. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
GLAZER WHO'S IN THE SPRINTERS
POSITION BY THE DOOR, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM 19 AB 2053. MATHES
MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
Ã NEWMAN I OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTESE CORTESE I. GLASER.
GLASER I GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK I. WILK I. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
WHO IS CLOSED OUT, WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLL OPEN FOR THE TIME BEING
FOR HIM AND I GUESS. YEAH. LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL FOR SENATORS WILK
AND CORTESE, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE WORK YOUR WAY THROUGH IT
AT YOUR LEISURE. OKAY. ON THE
CONSENT ITEM IS CORTESE. CORTESE
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK WILK. AYE. OKAY.
THAT MEASURE NOW HAS FIVE VOTES.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO HOLD IT OPEN,
PLEASE. NEXT. OKAY. A FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB 1160. PACHECO MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO EYES AND ONE NO. WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTESE.
CORTESE? AYE OKAY. THAT MEASURE
STILL FITS 3 TO 1. WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN. NEXT, PLEASE. OKAY. FOR
ITEM 13 AB 1841, WEBER MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NOS. CORTESE.
CORTESE AYE. GONZALEZ. REQUEST
OKAY. THE MEASURE IS FIVE
VOIGTS. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
PHÐ. ITEM 14 AB 1891 WEBER.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
. CORTESE. CORTESE. AYE.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. WILK. I MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW, FILE ITEM 60 TÍNH AB 1947.
THREE OF US MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE EYES AND NO NOS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTESE.
CORTESE. AYE GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. WILK
AYE. THE MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
FOR NONE AGAINST. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR NOW. OKAY. WELL, THANK
YOU TO ALL THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
FINISHED. AND WE'LL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR THE TWO ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WE'LL WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR THEM. SO IF YOU ARE A MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE, YOU HAVE YET
TO VOTE, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING YOU BACK DOWN IN
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM 2100, TO
THE REST OF YOU. GOOD DAY.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO. WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS FOR THE TIME
BEING AND WAIT FOR THE TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME BACK, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE REOPEN
THE ROLL AND PROCEED. OKAY. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, GONZALEZ.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO, FILE ITEM
ONE AB 1955. WARD. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR EYES AND TWO NOES WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE, SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. FIVE
VOTES TO TWO, FILE ITEM TWO AB
359. HOLDEN. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE AYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE ZERO. THAT MEASURE
IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO
FIVE. ITEM SEVEN AB 1160.
PACHECO CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
EYES AND TWO NO'S, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE THAT
MEASURES OUT FIVE VOTES TO TWO.
FILE ITEM 13 AB 1841 WEBER.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE AYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
THAT MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM 14 AB 1891.
WEBER. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE EYES
AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES
ZERO. FILE ITEM 16 AB 1947 THREE
OF US CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE EYES
AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO. ITEM 19. AB 2053.
MATHES. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
AYES AND NO NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. MAN
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. SO THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE. NOW
GO TAKE A NAP AND WE WILL WE
WILL ADJOURN IN A MOMENT. SO
WELCOME. YOU'VE COME TO AN EMPTY
ROOM, WHICH USED TO BE A FULL
ROOM, BUT I'M GLAD TO WELCOME A
STUDENT GROUP FROM THE ACLU TO A
BUNCH OF STUDENT ADVOCATES WHO
TRAVELED TO THE CAPITOL TODAY
AND HERE WITH US IN THE HEARING
ROOM, PLEASED TO WELCOME
STUDENTS AND PARENTS FROM THE
ACLU, LIBERTY SQUAD, STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE BLACK
PARALLEL SCHOOL BOARD AND THE
BLACK STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
UNITED. THESE STUDENTS ARE HERE
AS PART OF AN EVENT TO MARK THE
70TH ANNIVERSARY OF THE LANDMARK
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION
DECISION, AND TO LIFT UP THE
ONGOING INEQUALITIES AND
CHALLENGES FACING CALIFORNIA'S
BLACK STUDENTS TODAY, A NEW ACLU
REPORT CARD FINDS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS STILL THE THIRD
MOST SEGREGATED STATE FOR BLACK
STUDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO TO
IMPROVE EQUITY AND ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND OPPORTUNITIES,
SUSPENSIONS AND ARRESTS, STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND SO MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU, STUDENTS, FOR BEING
HERE AND BEING GREAT ADVOCATES
FOR YOURSELF AND YOUR PEERS. WE
WILL APPLAUD YOU FROM THE DAIS.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME AND WITH
THAT, THE THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU TO STAFF
AND SPECIAL SERVICES FOR YOUR
HELP. SPECIAL SERGEANT SERVICES,
SERGEANT.